foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
this year saw the return of the protest
league and thank goodness chat so good
to have you back PCL this is nice
let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh one
hundred thousand dollars up for grads
the final day of the protest League
playoffs has finally arrived Queen to
achieve oh my gosh
I'm Out Boy the PCL is here to stay who
will be crowned its next Champion Oh
What A Move relax everywhere relax
board for pranesh does it once again for
the Indian yogis
wow
it's Championship Sunday at the protest
League welcome everyone we've got the
big game coming up later today as the
Tigers will take on the Gotham Knights
for the championship but before that you
got another big game coming up oh for
the third place I am International
Master Tanya alongside me Peter Master
James Canty James such a big day of
Chess yesterday today an all Indian
Clash what's your prediction when the
yogis take on the MGD one my prediction
is this is gonna be tough but I have
it's gonna be an Indian team is going to
win for sure I'm a bet my house on it
I'm about everything on it an Indian
team is gonna walk away successful today
100 Indian team will be in third place
so I'm ready for today it's lots of
matches lots of fun Championship day
Championship Sunday it's a great day
it's been amazing thing so far and
continues to be super exciting today
James I can tell you if you make that
bet your house is super safe but this is
what the players are fighting for today
there is a lot at stake in the third
place match the winner of the Indian
yogis versus mgd1 walks off with 15 000
fourth place gets ten thousand dollars a
difference of 5K but James more than
that it is pride on the line which team
is the strongest Indian team and both of
them want to prove that absolutely do
you want to prove of course the bragging
rights there who's the stronger Indian
team but also that extra money is going
to help as well you know you can do
whatever you like with that money and
also hey maybe get some more chess uh
chess uh you know stuff for for the uh
for the fans and stuff like that too
right so I'm buying chess equipment and
just uh super computer stuff you know
what a kids do the Indian teams are
always working on chess and in fact they
just had another GM it was on Facebook I
saw it so correct congrats to that brand
new GM it was like announced maybe like
last 24 hours there's been another GM
from India whatever they're doing over
there it's working so shout out to India
again for that pretty pretty strong
stuff lots of money online today
yeah GMS from India are coming out
weekly and it's been a five-week battle
at the protest league and after this we
will also be revealing today the most
valued player from these themes now it's
been a fantastic season so far we
started with 16 incredible teams going
into the postseason we had eight teams
and the yogis started their battle
against Blitz had a convincing Victory
and in the semi-finals one of the most
dramatic matches of the league it was
the Shanghai tigers that came out
roaring pushing down knocking out the
Indian yogis to fight for the third
place wow and on the other side of that
bracket you see mgd1 taking on the
Wizards and the Wizardry was not strong
enough for the strong Indian in GT1 team
and they were able to take them down
make it to the semis there then the
Knights versus Bishops the epic battle
right from classics from injury from
centuries in a way right of course Long
Time battle for existence Knight versus
Bishops the knights won that one and
then they beat MGD one to make it to the
finals today so you know long stories
here and it's gonna game today tanyas
it's just it's sad right you know just
it hurts because it ends today
it ends today and James I have to say
that this is not the match the two
Indian teams wanted to fight for but
they're still gonna bring out their
competitive best as you said the
bragging rights it is pride on the line
and this is the squad that will be
fighting to win the third place prize at
the pro chess league and we see some big
changes that the Indian yogis are back
with that quarter final winning Squad
they bring in Vivid Gujarati they bring
in nehal Serene and they have rotated
out pragnananda and Rana sadwani from
yesterday meanwhile mgd1 getting in
savitashri instead of harika yeah this
is a strong team I mean both sides
obviously I mean uh and Niha were able
to get a good excuse me day of rest and
that day of rest I mean rest does
wonders like you just feel like a brand
new person especially in chess which is
very important to get that rest so you
can come back even stronger there so I
like that I like to switch up there that
the Yogi's there just put in the hall
and did it there and then using the same
team for mgd1 just switching out one
player switching out harika there uh
origin ready to go I mean the team is
very strong if adibon is hot today I
mean this is it's 50 50. I I have no I
don't know what's going to happen in
that match of course it could be
anybody's uh anybody's game but I do
know again Indian team is going to win
for sure
nice steak hot take that by James candy
that an Indian team will win the third
place prize with James it is amazing to
watch these players these are exactly
the players who are also fighting in
different teams at the Olympiad it is a
youth versus experience match the future
of Indian chess with the present
strongest players in the Indian chess
the most emerging the biggest emerging
talents and this is our round one
pairing we see whether Gujarati will
start his battle today against savitasri
and forget that W I am in front of her
because James take a look at that rating
she's at 24 11. yeah she's swinging in
fact I mean even princes 24 42 of course
he went down a little bit you gotta be
25 but he dripped he dipped a little bit
and that happens because chess is very
hard like that but she can have far from
pranesh who's a GM right so very strong
she's swinging well above the class the
weight whatever you know the title says
he's definitely ready to play today and
she's gonna take it to the other Indian
team hoping for something
yeah definitely pronation has already
made it he's already a grand master he's
just 16 years old and those ratings are
from back in November so there have been
a lot of switch-ups there he is knocking
on 2500 currently so a lot to fight for
here and I would love to hear it from
Chad it's a big day for chat I know it
was heartbreaking for the Indian fans in
the semi-finals but today you've got the
Indian bullet genius the speeches genius
from India nehal Serene he became a
grand master when he was 14 years old he
has been such a big Prodigy in India he
is the winner of the 2021 Junior speed
Chess Championship he will be playing
for the yogis and against him his
compatriot from the Olympiad Arjun
aragasi fighting for MGD one on the top
board it was a tough day for Arjun
yesterday in the semi-finals James how
do you what would be your advice today
for MGD one coming out of that very
difficult loss in the semis yeah you
have to just forget about it you just
literally forget about it and just say
you know what hey it's another day even
Carl says it to you have to have
short-term memory loss when it comes
with losses like when you lose hey it
happens it's not doesn't feel good but
you have to get over it very quickly or
it does trickle into the next game or
even the next match that psychology part
Gary Kasparov says the psych part is
even more bigger than the moves itself
right so look at him getting in the zone
there look at the shirt he's rocking too
you look at the MGD one sir that's like
a thousand dollar shirt my guy right
sign that boy assign it it'll be like
ten thousand dollars I'm gonna have to
hit him up about that that's our generic
icy ready to go yeah I love it he's got
MGD one on one side the protest on one
side and of course the Quan box his big
sponsors which was a historic 1.5
million dollar deal that Arjun got as
sponsorship last year and then this has
been another star player for the Indian
yogis vaishali prague's sister she's
been a Mainstay in their team getting so
many big points taking down so many
Grand Masters including Daniel dubov in
the league she also beat Grand Master
Sufi she's been having fantastic results
and she needs to deliver today as well
for her team this time she won't be
playing with Prague on her side instead
it's with it oh she can definitely play
you know with anyone by her side they're
very strong very aggressive player also
uh so you can play really any style here
she's also you know Prague is in the
family it's in the blood probably the
mom is probably like 2300 right so I
mean it's just that whole family is very
strong and she looks focused and ready
to go today she has to perform for the
team yeah and look at the focus on
savita's SRI right now she has been
rotated for harika for the MGD one today
James I have known savitashri for a
while I've been I've played with her on
the same team she is super hungry for
the win she plays Fearless chess she's
16 years old and Savita Shri and
vaishali are extremely good friends so
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they can bring out that beast in
themselves to actually fight each
other's theme but of course the top
board and we can see our generic acid
that he is getting ready for this match
he needs to make sure he gets in those
points leading from the front absolutely
and he definitely does especially when
he like you know he loses the same way
he wins and when you see that type of
player it's excellent you have to
develop yourself into a player like that
and you become just more of a universal
you can you can control your emotions
more you can do more when you can
control how you feel about a win and a
loss right so I see that a lot with the
top players especially Arjun right he
lost some games before it is what it is
sometimes you do get a little upset but
then at the end of the day right you
just have to bounce back and be ready
for the next one we got Vivid here on
the screen look at the August
throw a little smirk on his face it
might make him smile something like that
he's ready to go
he's super ready to go he's super ready
to unleash that potential way then
because that's exactly what he has to do
he knows it's a tough task these players
know each other so well they've been
teammates they've been competitors
against each other they know each
other's repertoire and look at that this
is the reason that with it surprises
savitasri with the French he starts with
the French that's not something that
Buddha uses often absolutely not in fact
Francis uh it's fun to see sometimes
right you sometimes use some good
friendships sometimes you get some
strange ones as we talked about before
we've seen I guess this is just like an
Indian thing too as well with a Arjun
played the French too as well with that
crazy game he played against kosnia
which was like how do you even get these
type of games out of the French it's
only usually in the middle games where
you see those super aggressive tactical
strange things that can happen this is
already a little bit weird here in the
theory for this one in the French
defense I think you have moves like
Knight B3 Bishop C4 as usual Theory as
well G3 is a movie at Bishop C4 followed
by Castle we get the pawn by convention
I'll tell you one thing about Savita
street she is playing board number one
of the Indian yogis but she doesn't care
she's gonna still try to build an attack
she's a player who plays for the
initiative she loves dynamic position
she doesn't care about material so that
extra Pawn in the center will be
eventually picked up and even though the
central pawns have been liquidated
savitasri will try to look for activity
in this position and I think what
reddit's doing right now he's playing
against that style he wants to try to
trade off as many pieces in the end game
I think with it with his experience will
have the upper hand you know what's
funny uh with aggressive players uh
which I'm sure uh SRI is actually
aggressive the problem is something like
the French
you can try to play aggressive but if
it's very very very solid like this is
right here I mean it's open and you can
have lots of chances for attack but it
definitely is uh solid and a lot of
times aggressive players have problems
with the solid Styles because you you
have to break it and if they're strong
as you know vid it is it's going to be
very difficult to break down we have a
tray here so you just want something
very simple this is equal all the way
equal 100 thousand percent equal here
guys this is just equal equal Tanya
it doesn't matter James it might be
equal for now but with it is going to
play this out till the end we're gonna
have a lot of moves and he will try
again this is what I was saying that for
with it a queen trade he's happy with it
he wants to avoid any kind of attacking
possibilities tactics that Savita might
get on the board he believes his best
chances might be to Simply go in a
queenless position where clearly his
experience will count so he's gonna play
this out till the end right now of
course the opening outcome a very level
game so far we will take this
opportunity to take a look on some of
the other boards because there is I do
see some more offbeat stuff that we are
seeing across the board we've got some
action on look at that top right there's
a knight that has jumped to B4 my first
feeling looking at this it looks like a
reverse Jabara London that's exactly
what it is
London there come on now you know I know
about that one but this is uh yeah
that's a reverse show Bravo but a lot of
ideas are actually the same you just are
down that one tempo which does matter
there so it is important to understand
that and we see vishali making United
free audible trying to figure out what's
going on over there but nihals soaring
with the reverse Obama very nice choice
there I want to I wonder how we got
there which we'll pull that up in a
minute
there we go perfect
let's see how we got to that position
negative three D5 nice C6 and Bishop F5
just to Obama like very nice it's
literally the reverse javama London
it's a very nice uh touch here from Niha
sorry and you know that your wobble
London is an Indian trademark in a way I
guess Arjun plays it a lot in fact
highest rated player from India that
does play it is origin even um uh vidit
had a game in it where he had a winning
position it was somewhere in a protest
League early on but did not was it
wasn't able to converge so pretty
familiar with all the Joe Boba games in
both ways pretty good Queen B3 on the
board here hitting B7 and now we have to
figure out what to do usually in Reverse
you would go Rook B1 so here's probably
so Rook B8 you need to defend that Beast
B7 fawn
six right now trying to go in for that
trap if you take on B7 then you've got
the move Knight A5 which would actually
win the game on the spot and I'm just
wondering if A6 is also a useful move in
these positions 100 A6 is definitely a
move to provoke it you can also play B5
he plays Rook B8 here but you can also
you could have also played A6 to play a
B5 and if Queen B7 obviously 95 which
traps the queen so pretty cool stuff
here usually in the reverse the Knight
of 694 here yes
you said cool stuff and of course this I
know is really exciting because it is a
reverse jababa London but you know
what's really cool is what's happening
on another board wow I'm gonna ask if we
can just pull out for a second zoom out
from here get our bird's eye view
because you're gonna love where I'm
taking you right now look at that bottom
right board wow I know exactly what is
going on it's like a french vanilla
variation the pawn has arrived on H5
Bishop B5 check black can't trade the
bishop but that creates a long-term
weakness on the a file this is absolute
Madness James do you want to take a look
at this absolutely you want to take a
look at this one in fact the French
defend this looks like something out of
a Geary has a lifetime repertoire of the
French here for you guys that like
accessible uh it's a very nice tool to
use especially if you want to get up to
date on certain theories as well but you
know nice nice so far winner let's
actually see how we got here too from
the beginning which is E4 E6 another
French here from the Indian team that's
funny both Indian teams Knight C3 Bishop
B4 E5 all Theory C5 A3 you have many
ways to play this takes takes and then
H4 right H5 and we live A4 grabbing all
the spaces you can check takes and
Knight E7 and Knight F3 usually you
would see a queen G4 here but after
Queen G4 you can actually allow CD4
Queen G7 Rook G8 right and queen C it's
like it's very very strange and tactical
so neither three was the move here and
after Knight F3 we have C D4 this is the
live position nice things for white is
we do have the bishop that can come here
like this we also can Rook lift this way
I saw Fabi had a very nice game that he
won playing this way well Rook lifting
in this manner and also putting the
bishop on A3 as well black does have his
own trumps B5 is hanging you also stop
in the castle right now right and black
can also make me you know break like F6
at some point and try to break up the
structure if we can get uh Queens traded
so lots of play though for both sides
yeah and really interesting how both the
top boards Yogi and mgd1 with it
employing the French and Arjun employing
the French very different middle game
position because you've seen a queen
trade in with its game but again both
start with the French trying to create
Chances with the black pieces I wonder
what that tells us about friends being
the way to try to get some Advantage
with black or create chances at least
now James the B5 Pawn is attacked and
actually the only way I see for white to
defend it is to offer a queen trade Rook
B1 it just feels like you won that Rook
on the open file Rook B1 would defend
the B5 Pawn but I don't know how happy
you are letting go of control of the a
file and making your own Rook passive
Queen E2 is a move that comes to mind
because yes you do trade Queens but that
a file is a long-term situation for
white a long-term strategic Advantage
for white yeah I'm actually not a fan of
uh the queen trade at all either because
like if I go crazy to Queen C3
get him off the board my goodness
tactics Tanya right okay that's not a
move my guy so Queen D3 is pretty gross
makes a lot of sense pretty gross I'm
not gonna lie engine's like oh it's fine
but like I mean bro I guess we have a C
file and look at the Knights this Knight
is absolutely disgusting you cannot move
it anywhere really you can play
something like A6 but I mean that
doesn't mean I'm even gonna take it
right so I mean this ugly structure
though but I mean I guess it is the way
Rook B1 feels a little passive there
like as you pointed out on the board
though
you have to trade the Queens here
and blunder and one James so easy to
fall for these but of course pranesh too
strong he says I want to trade the queen
keep that end game Advantage but he
places it at the right square and you
were mentioning Queen D3 takes on D3 and
it might wow
King D7 dang that is not something I was
expecting because this allows white to
actually trade on C4 and create a weak
bond for black absolutely I mean I
actually lost the game to a grand master
Gabriel from
um in the French defense from the black
side we I play King t7 a little bit too
early something like this it is it's a
move that you use but a little bit too
early here due to Queen takes C4 takes
and just Knight D2 after Rook C8 I mean
maybe we can even Rook lift Rook A3 or
H3 and try to hit the pawn on C4 so for
instance take take Knight D2 and then
after Rook C8 we can try to bully this
Pawn we also have Knight E4 to D6
ourselves quite annoying Rook H3 or A3
maybe and going over after this Pawn
there are some problems maybe we even go
Rook A4 immediately to make make the
pawn push a little bit further we go 94
Rook H3 right we're hitting this pawns
week and night is still pretty gross on
ba you have you can't move it which
means this is locked in you have eight
points over here locked in on the uh on
the queen side and you need to finish
this development so definitely white is
for Choice all day here in fact nicely
refreshed to see the live position and
we have a weight we have a weight
and as you mentioned that's half the
board locked in on the queen side that
move King D7 also takes away the
developing Square for the Knight on B8 I
think for Arjun the only way to get that
Knight out he is hoping to get in a move
like A6 or A5 in to try to at least take
care of the weaknesses along the a file
and Knight D2 played you immediately
start targeting the C4 weakness and I
just don't believe that Arjun will have
enough time to make sure that the Pieces
come out C4 is under attack it looks
like he's going to end up down upon
pranesh with a big Advantage he is the
ball for the yogis and with the white
pieces this is a dream position against
Arjun yeah this is a disaster for origin
uh especially the star here I mean with
the board board four especially if
you're board four three and four can
perform very well you're gonna have a
great round or at least you you know
especially if one and two can do their
thing here but Arjun if this is uh if he
goes down in here this is going to be
rough for the first round especially for
finesse is going to give him confidence
boost and you don't want a confidence
boosting your board four already taking
down your board one so it is something
it's definitely something to it but
origin is definitely in some trouble
right now
yeah King D7 strange decision there by
Arjun but we'll see if he manages to
create some play that C4 Pawn is a
long-term weakness the a file in control
for pranesh things are looking good for
the Indian yogis on that bottom right
board but let's do a little bird's eye
view tour of what is happening on the
other boards we were talking about the H
Pawn marching down the board look at
that top top right board black Sage Pawn
has arrived on H3 the Queens are still
on the board that is some ambitious play
by nehal Serene that's exactly what he's
known for and James that position even
though the bar says it's leveled right
now it's gonna be fireworks it's
definitely fireworks on that board uh
right now especially if we just I just
want to see how does where did this this
H Pawn push come from like we before we
were here in fact we left off right
around this area here nice C6 we saw
Queen B3 Rook V8 so he went in 95. nice
development we allowed the open of the B
file and you Castle you know what's
funny in Reverse this is exactly what
you do with such a baba London and the
whites aside so it's really the same
thing you would see uh just in Reverse
it's kind of nice this is literally a
reverse survival but he pushed the H
Pawn here usually the king is actually a
step over to f8 so you can still have
the Rook here I mean this is like in
Reverse it would be king F1 with the
Rook on H1 and you want to push the H
Pawn so here I mean yes you can still do
it obviously you want to have the Rook
here to have some uh some Firepower down
the diet down the file after you trade
on G3 if you trade on G3 but cast was
fine Queen A4 he plays H4 Knight C2 H3
that pawn is running down there so
there's good and bad things about this
right the good thing is that we do have
some space the bad thing is that this
can actually be a way and it can also
help defend they call us from cheskia
the umbrella Pawn or like you know this
is actually helping defend my king yes
of course it's in here but I it's
helping defend I can maybe go F3 and at
some point ground up this Pawn it's a
long plan queen E1 pushed upon up right
Queen over to H3 or G3 and we win this
Pawn so I mean he could be in some
trouble here you cannot really I I
actually like white not gonna lie I'm a
fan of White's position what about you
I actually like Black's position I'm
going to say it and we have to point out
that white does have an extra Pawn but
again it is about peace activity for
black it's long-term compensation you're
not looking at checkmating white skin
immediately but what you're looking at
is putting that f8 Rook on the C file at
some point you can take on D4 you're
controlling the open files meanwhile
because of that Rook can be it let's
also with our Arrow game point out that
it's difficult for white to actually
finish development that Bishop on C1 is
tied down to defend the B2 Pawn The Rook
on A1 is stuck as well and James I love
peace activity and I think specially in
these time formats when you've got such
little time on the clock for a pawn this
is a lot of compensation and it's often
more difficult to play with little space
and little flexibility than with the
black pieces here down upon with all the
piece play in the position
I do like that I do like it well said
well said definitely there's a lot of
activity for black as Rooks are
connected which tells you full
development is their compensation is
there in fact because we do have the
full development of our pieces white on
the other hand still needs to connect
Rooks here do still kind of like why I
do like having a pawn and have the fact
that I can't win this one but after
looking it's a little bit closer here it
is difficult to make moves here Queen D3
what's up with this queen D3 move today
I mean with a strange structure too like
Queen D3 in both games today we saw with
a strange structure Type move another
one here I mean they just think alike
like the Indian teams thinking of like
playing French two different teams
playing the queen D3 move two different
I mean it's like we're watching the same
people play each other
this is what we were talking about right
extra Bond but again look at Black's
Rooks and pieces he can actually afford
to even trade Queens down upon that
other Rook once again can come down on
the board on the C file it does it and
now where do you find good improving
moves for white and it's hard to answer
that question but James that H3 Pawn you
pointed it out right now it's a strength
it does dominate the position takes away
a lot of key squares but it can be a
potential weakness for black long term
for example in King Pawn endings but
that's a far way off I know nehal and I
see the eval bar also agrees with this
he's loving his position these are the
kind of positions that he likes black
can look at ideas like Bishop d8 Bishop
B6 you just start targeting white spawns
and it's going to be hard at some point
to defend all of them
this looks like in a reverse sort of
like the Catalan type uh there's two
openings that give you this type of
conversation which is Catalan from the
white side when like you give up the
pawn I mean you've even seen it in like
game six of a world championship with
the Magnus and yawn right anytime you
give up that pawn you get that
conversation you get the pieces rolling
then you actually able to get that pawn
back with interest you also see this in
the Banco Gambit 2 as well for you guys
like Bangkok Gambit you can get lots of
conversation for that pawn and usually
it's on the queen side as we see here
it's kind of like a very successful
incog Gambit but now I mean as your plan
Italian Bishop d8 Bishop P6 hit D4 how
do you do anything I thought Rook D2 as
well but this is ugly I mean this is
actually really rough now and because of
the development of the pieces here we
had to focus more on development maybe
even give the pawn back somewhere in
there
um so yeah very nice for Newhall so far
really nice top and rookie to a strange
looking move but white is really trying
to keep things together for Bishop B6 on
that board what white wants on top right
is to fall back with that Knight on C2
to still try to hold the pawns but the
pieces look absolutely ugly on that one
nehal Serene in driver's seat on top
right and on the top left and James this
is what I was talking about end game
with it using his experience he's so
good in these slow positions slow
maneuvering and these are the kind of
games that he really enjoys playing he
is an absolute Master an absolute beast
in that and look at this with black he's
created his chances and I look at it
he's already managed to win some
material he's up a pawn in this uh top
left board I'm actually curious to see
how he won that as well and
I guess he's getting
exactly right our generic I see getting
crushed when do you ever put that in one
sentence right of course uh pranesh is
definitely trying to put the work to
look at the pieces by the way let me
look at remember we talked about eight
pieces I mean King back to D7 you got to
be kidding me look at this guys never
try this at home guys don't try this one
at home the night in The Rook eight
pieces are stuck in here we haven't
moved it Tanya we're almost 25 and I
never moved my knight or my Rook from A8
MBA that's 50 of the board for black
right now you haven't moved any of this
any of the pieces you said don't try
this at home don't try this anywhere
especially don't try it on the top Board
of the protest League James White again
is dominating this position because all
the pieces are playing look at that
Bishop on E7 the pawn on D6 tying
everything down that pawn on B5 is such
a big strength in White's position black
at some point has to start pushing that
a pawn but the problem is that white can
just ignore it let's say you go A6 here
white never in the world will take that
pawn on A6 allowing you to finish
development instead he's just saying you
know what that Rook is pinned you can't
take on B5 there's no Mobility at all
white can start targeting the queen Side
Pawn Rook G3 ideas in the air even at
some point when there's a right moment
The Rook from A1 can slide down to G1
and James the combination of the D6
passer and the H5 passer is big trouble
for black and we see Rook G3 has been
played on the board the g-pawn and the H
pawns have been traded in fact A6 is on
the board as well he's like yeah I can't
do this I can't sit around like this and
of course nobody wants to sit around use
I mean look at this this is just so bad
for the pieces right we haven't moved
them look at I mean he's look at the tie
down here you can't move anything
this is great look at the geometry here
with a classic right triangle and see
Carl says here right this is a classic
right and this is very rough for for
origin's position for sure it's gonna
have to be a mega blunder here or um for
uh for nest to lose this game
there's a check
and so he goes up the board but white
can just push the Deep on can't you just
go D7 oh you're right yeah these are
both yeah G7 wins right yeah
rookie one is very nice hitting check
and make
um
you just win The Rook snake yeah he
might as well hit the button I mean the
resign button that is guys you've done a
whole Rook origin era guy seat down a
whole Rook here for no compensation guys
this was a very clean one for panesh
here who came to play board four of the
Indian yogis phenomenal game very
clinical stuff there by uh pranesh
Wright out of the opening and James just
amazingly handled after the queen trades
nightmare that's a full Rook there is no
compensation Arjun just goes to play he
will go on playing for his team but
pranesh can we just admire his
performance for a moment he has been the
star player on board for for the yogis
time and time again match and match
again taking so many points and that is
a critical factor in this format James
let's say this one pranesh will win he's
up a full Rook no compensation at all
let's use this moment to zoom out and
see where can mgd1 strike back and the
one board that I see that things are
looking super Bleak for mcd1 again is
the top left board and we see that in
fact Arjun has resigned that game has
ended top left with it Gujarati for the
yogis will take that point as well
because look at those two pawns marching
down the board
oh absolutely you got the pawns here you
know one thing in the fridge which it
didn't it wasn't an Argent case but many
times in the French defense if you're
reading French books or the books about
the French it says that Queen trades
will favor Black So you you're cool with
Queen traits right but in that game with
Arjun it was completely different he
didn't develop it says you know I guess
the caveat is like Queen traits are cool
for you if your pieces are developed
right like he didn't develop his pieces
there so it was a tough game here vidit
actually is going on to win this game as
he wins after the last move in King E5
here had a good game trade of Queens
quite early and end game this whole game
from the beginning you know it's tough
if the French is one of those where you
just have this I think the psychology
part too of like you know hey I win the
game I'm playing the French and we get
this end game and you already know what
you're looking for so great job doing
what he does on board one yeah great
game though with the black pieces and
just to tell you what the idea was in
that top left position once The Rook
falls back black simply moves that
Bishop from G2 out of the way the G Pawn
advances down the board there's nothing
that could have been done and white
resign meanwhile time pressure is on on
the other both James where do you want
to jump to I'm looking at the Beast
haribon baskaran is uh playing with the
black pieces here what was this opening
I'm curious he's completely winning here
three four three four why is it
completely winning what was the last
move Rook F1 now it's just crushing
extra Pawn for black oh we have the
extra Pawn we have extra on it's just
like say that it's a big boss really bad
for for black I mean for white
this seemed terrible terrible definitely
she's getting tricky Queen F6 coming in
so watch out a little bit there are
threats along the weakened dark squares
on the on the inside vaishali creating
some ideas
tricky tricky queen of six five oh he
said go ahead I got some tricks up my
sleeve as well and queen and that's mean
and uh but James there was a moment I
think B2 was a mistake there and it's
something that should not have been
played
really
if this is back after that moment
here yeah and I saw the eval bar say
look at that I think the point is that
white can use this moment to actually go
Bishop takes B2 there is a big tactics
combining the idea of Queen F6 and the
open e-line James you can't pick up the
bishop on B2 The Rook on here The Rook
on C4 hangs and if you go Rook takes E3
white can go Queen F6 as you're pointing
out and I think that's a good no not
Queen F6 maybe you just pick up the Rook
on E3 or the queen R6 looks so strong as
well yeah it definitely looks very
strong there yeah
in a way definitely a Miss tough stuff
and it's hard to see that it's hard to
see it's really difficult to find that
especially in the time that she had to
as well I mean she has 1.3 finishing
this game really kind of hard to find
that uh in any way shape or form tough
game and adibon the Beast takes out
that's the one big Silver Lining right
now for MGD one the only win the only
point for MGD one comes on that board
and it could have been a different
storyline had vaishali spotted that
tactic of picking up the B2 Pawn
definitely on a radar but again the
clock was a big factor but what a big
lead we see that going into round two
Indian Yogi's all games and decisively
and for the Indian yogis three points
fitted Gujarati nahal celery pranesh and
I think James Ferris the game of this
round was pranesh versus archan
absolutely of course they always say if
you're bored three and four can perform
you're gonna have a great one especially
if boards one and two just do what
they're supposed to do go in win get
some points for the team draw don't lose
right and that's exactly what we saw in
this round here especially pretty much
being the big dog taking down the big
dog arj and Eric icy what a round that
was for the yogis
just amazing stuff I'm taking down the
top Board of mgd1 16 year old pranesh he
does it time and time again fall the
Indian yogis winning critical critical
points looking confident that and he has
all the reasons too as he takes down
Ward one we will be back with more PCL
action after this break
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a Checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
foreign
thank you
61 she wants queen H6 what are you doing
I'm out what I'm out
that was brilliant a comeback huge win
for the Indian yogis what a crazy game
oh my gosh he got him with his Queen
that's game been a Gujarati about to win
with black against Magnus Carlson this
is an unbelievable comeback oh and what
a beautiful mating pattern this is going
to be the classic Queenie for Rook C2 by
Charlie defeats dubov that is a big win
for the yogis
wow
at just 14 now Serene became a grand
master right now he is only 18 years old
but he is a phenomenal player already
he's India's speed chess genius is what
we call him back home he's known as the
bulletpiece he did make it to the finals
of the 2022 Global Championship after
defeating the current world champion
dingler and Anish giri he also is the
2021 Junior speed chess champion and he
starts with a bang today for the Indian
yogis taking a big point in a convincing
victory in their match against the MGD
one and these are our brackets later on
today James a huge big final coming on
coming up on the top board we'll have
tactical genius way Yi for the Tigers
and of course household name Hikaru
Nakamura for the Gotham Knights that's
gonna be a big I mean it's the biggest
massive look guys if his mother say
Happy Mother's Day out there to everyone
as well and then you're like hey what
are you doing Mom I'm watching the
finals Mom okay so you have to make sure
you put Mom in the loop to let them know
what's going on today because that is a
match that you can't miss
the winner of 2023 protest League yeah
well I'm gonna have to go with the
Knights there I'm gonna have to go
tonight because if they're in good form
it's gonna be a problem it's gonna be
scary it's gonna be scary but if we see
the way gee and the zoo Yi and the yees
we saw yesterday oh it's gonna be a
problem for the knights because game of
the year was played yesterday with five
brilliant moves in it oh my gosh and we
also see amazing action
for the third place Indian Yogi is
leading with a convincing round one
Victory three to one MGD one needs to
switch it up they need to do it fast
they need to do it now they cannot let
this Gap widen any more and we see there
that Vedas Gujarati will be taking on
deep down gosh and Arjun after that loss
in round one James he's got a strike
back absolutely I mean you have to
strike back here originally but again we
didn't see you know he was losing the
game and he didn't bat an eye like he
didn't even it didn't face him at all so
hopefully he can use that same energy
and come in here you know stronger this
game and win look if it did you know
ready to go right
he always is he's always so calm and
composed and in control he's been he's
been a really cool leader in so many
team events for Team India he knows how
to handle the pressure he knows how to
lead from the top he knows how to
unleash his potential and that's what
he's he did in game one trading off the
Queens confidently with the black pieces
going into the end game where he
outplayed savitasri taking that big
point and James I'm just wondering if
for the yogis the question the big miss
that happened in the semi-finals of not
having with it and nehal is that
something that's on their mind it
probably is something on their mind but
you do gotta let him rest too as well
you have to understand I mean you could
let play them and they are capable of
playing but it is something underminer
definitely something on her mind but he
gave him a break here and of course they
still are able to play this match here
for a third place anyway third and
fourth place so you know I know they're
thinking about that one we have an
Italian game it's hard it's tough to get
over that but right now they they can't
afford to because they are playing
against a formidable MGD one we do see
the Italian and black starts with the
move D6 now usually at that moment James
Blackie that develops the Bishop from f8
or the knight from G8 goes on to F6 so
D6 is not the most popular move and
that's why with it slows down here
absolutely I mean this goes more into
Philadelphia's territory here I mean the
aggressive route I love to play from D4
Chase Knight takes D4 Knight takes Queen
takes it Theory goes Knight C3 obviously
after Knight F6 Bishop F4 you Castle
Queen side you go F3 you go G4 you go
Knight E2 Knight G3 H4 you go from eight
every single time this is the plan this
is very fun and it's nice it's
aggressive so hopefully we see something
like that but there we go we have D4
this is the standard move but uh Vida
doesn't play like really aggressive he
does see tactics and very strong he's
more positional like but let's see if he
has an aggressive taste today Knight
before Knight F6 you go Knight C3 as
usual Theory develop pieces right Bishop
B7 Bishop F4 is my favorite move to play
here you can also just Castle
immediately too as well which he does he
goes for that one he's not casting Queen
side so we're gonna have ourselves a
more of a quiet game
you're absolutely right with it he's
tactically sharp but he loves to play
positional strategic games it's super
important for him that his positions
have a strong positional Foundation
before he goes for anything rash now
that Central break on D4 definitely
takes advantage of Black's decision to
start with D6 and again we see with it
he takes a slow approach Rook to E1 but
he will look at building pressure on the
center of the board at some point the F
Pawn can advance to F4 the queen can
come to F3 once the situation with the
Knights is sorted out and we can't see
this position heating up but James let's
zoom out while that happens because
there's one more game that is in action
and it is between nehal Serene and
savitasri on that top right pod and look
at that a perfectly symmetrical position
the players are playing copycat
yeah I'm not gonna lie that one actually
it's not the grow for uh from the black
side of that game usually is some of the
hardest sets you ever play so it is very
difficult I think it is a challenge
um I think it's very a challenge here
for street but for sure because yes it's
symmetrical but also white is the one
dictating a lot of things here we also
didn't take on c42 as well usually
You'll Play C4 and take on D5 I mean and
then you'll have like a symmetrical
Greenfield type way where it becomes
more draw like there are some games
actually with Bobby Fischer Bobby
Fischer burn actually it was a famous
game C4 takes D5 where he had you know
symmetrical grin fail it was fine but
this one it's not even it's not even C4
there so black could black is definitely
fine but you do have to play this very
positionally and it's not you don't get
many tactics and it's kind of like a
sitting in a waiting game for black here
a lot of times it is not the most fun to
play for sure from blacks
a big committed decision there by Savita
she played the bishop B4 so we often
talk about imbalances in chess and now
we see the minor piece imbalance white
trades the Knight for the bishop so we
know that it's going to be an
interesting middle game not a
symmetrical one anymore nehal wants to
get a pure double Bishop pair advantage
and that's a long-term gain once black
trades the Knight on G5 at some point
White's E2 Pawn can advance to E4
opening up the position when you've got
the Bishops you really want the position
to open up so you can realize the full
potential of the pieces absolutely the
Precision required here again from black
is just not the it's not fun to play you
do have to still develop the Knight you
have to watch out for the E4 push which
is there at some point do I play E5
myself where do I put the Knight when I
go from D7 maybe just the natural F6 or
do I need to go to B6 does my queen come
out where does it go when it does right
there's a lot of things that need to be
answered here and it is difficult I
think White's play is very
straightforward and easy we're trying to
get E4 in we can also play F3 E4 at some
point um we're even we're getting rid of
this Knight something's going to be uh
this Knight is going to get dealt with
like immediately there it is Bishop G5
and now we have E4 on tap when we want
to maybe bishop B4 pushing pressure here
right I mean White's for choice for sure
I actually like nihal's position already
and again it comes down to this bishop
pair that he's got and the mobility in
the center with the brakes that we have
been talking about Knight D7 played E5
is a far away dream with that Queen pin
down the board and nehal can in fact
immediately start thinking about
striking in the center we'll see if he
makes that decision but wow
doing adivan things and there is a white
Pawn on G7 so this looks like it's come
from uh from a Moscow bot Clinic from
bot Clinic variation perhaps
I love it
we gotta rush to that one I think this
is more of a something else it's like
because I know there's the H Pawn let's
see what happened oh like this note boom
stuff this should be for E4 Bishop G5 E5
yeah bottleneck type takes Rook G8 G3
yeah this stuff's sharp so from Prince's
point of view and actually I've said
this from both sides I do like black
black isn't a dynamic is look how crazy
the position is like there's a real G8
there's a pawn here like what is this if
you saw this for the first time like
what on Earth is going on and I mean you
know it's it's funny you have to play C5
you actually put the queen on B6 and you
Castle Queen side Tanya I'm sure you've
seen them
yeah and it's crazy I I have to say you
said that you like these positions for a
black but I actually like white wow and
the one I said I like white there has
been a mistake that has been made and
Knight B6 on the board
I'm still trying to figure out why this
is such a big blunder you see I'm trying
to figure out too I was a GG maybe take
take Queen B1 that's a crazy move but
like I'm just getting a pawn back it
doesn't seem that crazy
let me see because we need some
assistance here what's the best
oh this is 95 is just completely winning
oh this is so crazy like one move 95 is
just absolutely winning by a lot
and that makes sense because you moved
that knight from D7 you lose control of
the E5 square but of course what black
wants to do after 95 is put his own
Knight on D5 that's the whole idea of
playing the move Knight B6 again I'm and
I think the point is that you just start
putting pressure you can go Queen H5
James let's show this line 95. 95 Queen
H5 I'm threatening a Checkmate in one on
F7 take that pawn on G7 and then there's
Queen h8 check winning the rook and
that's the problem
that's the problem right there why it's
the problem that is sick line let me
turn this engine over here Perfect all
right so
um Knight B6 yeah yeah yes okay yeah
that's that's all right let's see if he
finds it this is the Beast right look at
him in the zone okay hands on his head
he's ready to go
but this is the thing right for
for audiban these are not
difficult to find but I think what he's
also thinking about is the move A5 A6
because from a human perspective A5 is
also so tempting to get that pawn all
the way down to A6 push has he gone for
it he did see A5 and A6 he's going
forward and I like it I I feel that's
the move that you really want to make
because now Black's King is just stuck
in the center forever we were talking
about Knight E5 being the stronger move
that James but honestly from a human
perspective this just makes so much
sense black is completely tied down yeah
I think he's about to get crushed I'm
not even gonna lie this might be over
this is 17 moves it might be over in
another three to four moves here I mean
queen H5 is that sick Movement we talked
about before hitting F7 C6 is hanging
right now how do you defend everything
maybe a queen C7 because you are holding
C6 and you're temporarily stopping you
know Queen H5 but even then at Queen H5
is coming with Queen H7 like there's too
many threats Knight F6 though I think
Queen H6 King E7 there's there's even G5
is hacking I mean so many things are
hanging yeah three things hunting
everything is hanging right yeah this is
a tough one this is how sharp this this
becomes though this is very important to
understand I mean that theory goes very
deep in that balvinic type line The
Notebook no boom things you go like
Queen B6 you Castle Queen side quite
quickly you need to get your pieces
active and it looked like he got one
piece Act of the night but then the rest
of the pieces did not get active for
your chat make sure you develop your
pieces we got Bishop at night out cool
the queen is one move away from
completing development the rook's being
connected The Rook is still defending
the pawn Bishop's bad h i mean this is
very very bad right now from a human
person right absolutely yeah 17 moves
and only one block piece is out
absolutely node development as you're
saying James it looks like black is
setting up for the next game the king
the Queen the Rooks the bishop
everything on the last rank why does I
mean just imagine the kind of progress
that white has made here there's a Pawn
on G7 there's a Pawn on A6 white has
finished full development is already
coming in with checkmating ideas from H5
this is beast in beast mode
and that's the thing with this opening
right you have to be so precise with
black to not land into trouble and I
think Knight B6 was that big imprecision
by pranesh Bishop D7 has been played to
defend Safeguard the C6 Pawn again black
stream is to move that Queen and go long
Castle but it's not gonna be easy to get
there because I think white can already
start threatening the F7 pawn queen H5
Queen E7 still keeps things a little
defended absolutely it's one of these
it's like Queen H5 Queen F6 or E7 and
then you need we need to increase the
pressure I don't know if F4 is a thing I
mean you might as well send everything
just F4 take take try to get F5 in open
up the king yeah this is uh there's a
lot of things that can happen the next
few moves here exactly just do it right
just play Queen H5 and then after he
defends it maybe just open up everything
and four or eight something like that
I love F4 but again rookie won such a
tempting move you just bring all your
pieces into the game and you can always
go F4 I think it kind of also depends on
where black places the queen do you want
to go Queen to F6 or do you want to
place it on E7 and depending on that
white will take a decision James adiban
in full control on this one he's got all
the trumps pranesh has a big uphill task
to actually defend this and again this
is such an important round for mgd1 to
score on every board so so far things
looking good for adivan to make that
comeback should we just take this moment
to zoom out and I see Queen E7 and
decision has been played has been made
we will come back to this but look at
that top right board as well really
exciting stuff there nehal has the
double Bishop pair advantage and that's
the reason that you you've got that
slight Edge push in the position
long-term weaknesses on the e-file that
E6 Pawn is weak for savitar the doubled
up Rooks so that is a great positional
Advantage strategic Advantage for nehal
on the top left on the other hand with
it playing the slow game
uh top left yeah very slow yeah he
playing a very slow game there D6 is
weak I mean you see this all the time
and good fill the doors there in fact
that's just going to be a very even
match I mean VD is actually down time a
little bit too as well so he has to be
careful but D6 is weak he does have the
trumps in the position A5 is also weak
as well in the knee-haul game there I do
uh like his position he's just hey ask
the bishop here you have the E6 Pawn in
this week we got the double Rooks like
everything you really want for having a
good uh slight advantage in the position
here and again it's just rough playing
from the black side of those type of
openings there where it's symmetrical
it's not a lot going on you have to just
kind of sit and wait that's exactly what
black is doing right now we have a
knight on C4 but this can't be kicked
this is not an outpost but you can stay
on because I can kick you away with B3
at some point right E6 is here kind of
just sitting and waiting maybe doubling
and uh White has I mean white it has to
come up with something obviously but at
the same time white can it would slow
ball it H5 H6 King G2 maybe move a rook
maybe try to play G4 move the queen back
play B3 at some point A3 Queen A2 B3 so
many ideas that I have and black kind of
just has to sit and wait I don't have a
real plan here for black besides holding
and I think that's the point you just
hit the nail on the head that it's just
so much easier for white to make these
moves you've got this Queen Side Advance
pushing down the Knight of the C4 Square
you've got the next few moves easy to
make and that's what nehal is going for
he comes back with the queen to C2 he
will play B3 eventually the a pawn can
start marching down the board basically
he's just got a position where
everything is under control and black
has got no way to make any counter play
for counter play we often talk about
breaks in the center E5 will never
happen as white has full control of the
e-file and plus that F5 weakness C5 will
also create a lot of central weaknesses
for black so it's just going to be a
very passive position for savitar to
handle James I want to zoom out of this
because really where the fireworks are
is the adiban game and I feel that we're
going to see a result there really soon
by the way the idea that you mentioned
bottom right board it's on the board
Queen E7 was played and after a central
trade adiban going for the kill F4 open
up that Rook he gave up that fanchatoed
Bishop on G2 a really nice idea there
because look at Black tax Bishop we
often talk about the G2 Bishop as being
a prime piece in White's position but
when Black's got a bishop like that you
know that there will never be any big
problems on the king side on the lights
Quest so playing with momentum playing
with energy he takes the piece that was
controlling F4 so that after G takes F4
you can recapture with the Rook Rook
comes to F4 the other Rook joins the
attack from F1 that is game over let's
point out black can't take currently the
G7 Pawn Rook takes G7 a move that you
really want to make James would be a
really big mistake because white jumps
in with Queen H a check and black screen
is overloaded you've got to fall back
you take it you win the piece you win
the game oh so what you said is
something about a bishop I don't see a
bishop on the board I don't I mean this
looks like the same position as if this
was gone or if it's there yeah this
looks like oh here's the bishop guys oh
yeah it's in in tuned around all of his
pawns here really rough you're gonna
have to play something like B4 but even
then you don't even have a diagonal to
put it on this is very bad the also the
threat is f takes G5 with Rook takes F7
how do you even stop this how do you
even stop this time I don't even see a
weight he tried it he tried this he went
before he tried to stop that and James
You're Gonna Love what adiban did he
said I don't care about bonds I'm going
for the king he tries to open the e-line
this is once again a beastly attacking
Masterpiece here coming attack he's
gonna have to Rook E1 right let's show
the sample line here Tony after Bishop
E6 you know what the move is you ready
for it here it is Boom Knight takes F7
hit him off the board oh my goodness
hope you did your taxes this morning
after Queen taste is going to Rook takes
E6 right obviously hitting this this is
GG everywhere disgusting decisive
results here this is going to be over in
a few moves
F5 how much do you love that move he
doesn't care about the G4 Pawn it's like
a tunnel vision he's going for black
skin as long as it's in the center and
after F5 if black tries to go along
Castle White can always snap up the f
would be a big disaster so he had to
take F5 he could not allow white to play
F6 and win the the F7 pawn and now James
your idea bring all the toys to the
nursery bring that Avon Rook all the way
to E1 and I really don't see a way for
pranesh to survive this one
yeah he's gonna give up material that's
the only way to survive here is actually
just give up some material in fact when
Rick a to E1 maybe just Castle queen's
eye all right at least I got my king
castle right but you are going to lose
some material I mean very least I could
go Knight to C6 and actually pick up an
exchange that way I can take on F7 and
pick up an exchange that way so it's
going to be a really rough for for
Pradesh in this game had a great game
against uh Ward one with origin but with
the black pieces here it looks like uh
for sure adipon is going to clean this
one up
in this one right out of the opening and
James we're not expecting this to last
for too long the ideas are clear
although adiban has slowed down and I'm
just wondering does he see something
maybe he's thinking about Knight F7
directly is that what adibon's thinking
about no sound direct it does work
though not an option now the seven
directly actually is a good move but
wait is there a Perpetual Queen E3 no
you have requests thinking Rook after
but rookie one why even think about all
these options when you've got
it Knight F7 it doesn't matter if it
works or not and pranesh with the only
option of giving up material to survive
last a little longer James this looks
like it's only delaying the inevitable
do you think we should jump to another
board absolutely Knight F7 on the board
by the way two is always going to pick
up that exchange and interest here which
is I mean a beautiful position audible
is going to take a miracle and a mouse
slip for him to lose this one
I completely agree with that he's
picking
out first goes for the pawn now picks up
the rook and will pick up the game
meanwhile on the other boards top right
and we see nehal Serene he doesn't have
the bishop pair Advantage but so much
play on the e-line that E6 weakness
compared the two Bishops clearly nehal
in driver's seat in that one so while
adiba looks like he's gonna win the
point there nehal looks like he will
pick up the point for the yogi award
what's your evaluation on the other
other side of uh our bird's eye view
well let's go into this one first yeah
we go to this one first actually and
when we while we're here it's just easy
game for white I mean as we said from
the beginning here I mean this is a
really you're gonna it takes so much
patience and precision and experience in
these type of positions from even from
the beginning if we start is to look at
uh what how we even got here right
having these symmetrical positions these
are cool perfect right but then you have
this where this is one of the hardest
positions to play it doesn't even score
that well in the database too if you
look at it from the black side it just
doesn't score very well it's very
difficult to play this from black side
white just had a steady Advantage just
slightly better the whole game they're
for choice right and then we fast
forward to this position why still for
choice I mean look at the patience here
I put the King on H3 like you know what
I mean King H3 just to relax a little
bit and I can kind of do whatever wait
for you to make it move Bishop E5 right
I can slowly push maybe try to trade
rookie takes E5 play G4 trade a pair of
Rooks my King's already a little bit
more active than yours black can still
you know definitely try to hold this as
as much as as she can here with 1.5
being the engine evaluation that's still
closer to equal and practical Chances
with humans so this isn't not over yet
but definitely white is all always are
in this position for choice for sure
foreign
can't move any of the major pieces there
is no Square left the queen can't move
anywhere keeping contact with E6 the
Rooks can't move the E6 Pawn will fall
so there is so much pressure on the
board it's a slow game you're absolutely
right that white needs to find a way to
break but right now completely in
control for nehal he's also got about
two minutes on the clock but we know one
thing for now anything more than 10
seconds for nehal is too much time yeah
you don't want to give him too much time
in fact actually I remember when we were
doing cgc commentary you know he's
dubbing him like little Hikaru in a way
because of just the speed the accuracy
and also the resourcefulness so even in
positions where he was just worse he was
just defending and defended and somehow
miraculously sometimes win the game
obviously you can't win every one but
the defense is the resourcefulness is
what we call it there it was very you
know Hikaru asked because you only see
Hikaru do his kind of resource for new
things and you see me Hall you see that
a lot in the hall actually here when you
give him a good position I mean it's
very rare that he's I mean he's playing
for two here really for a while he wants
to win the game obviously but playing
for two results like this it's going to
be very difficult to lose this game if
you're new
and he does take a decision to trade off
the Bishops the only piece in Black's
position that had any movement without
losing material he gets rid of that he
cannot think about getting the queen to
E3 to 86 try to make control make use of
these dark squared weaknesses continue
to put pressure James this is going to
be a while before nehal is able to wrap
this up if he is at all while Savita
Shri has got an uphill battle we will
zoom out because I see we're about to
have a result on the adiban board take a
look on the madness that's going on on
that bottom right he's just taken the
bishop on D7 if you take that Rook that
was Rook F7 let's just quickly and
before I could finish it that is it has
Ivan wins the game such a great game by
the Beast aliban with a nice dub there
picks up a beautiful dub as he needed
that one for sure just for the team
there and as we look at these other
boards tiny where do you want to go yeah
wow we're actually playing on seconds
this one so I think we should go to that
she's got 14 seconds on the plot she's
playing against Arjun but apart from the
clock the position is in control for
vaishali she's not doing badly at all
the Rooks are active in fact I like
Black's position here you've got this
super active Knight on F4 you've got the
two Rooks really nicely placed on the
open files the bishop on C3 controls the
E1 Square I see the eval bar prefers
arjun's position but I think there's a
lot a lot of Trumps for black as well
here except the clock she's re she's on
four seconds she needs to start playing
fast super fast she actually had this in
the last game and time can be absolutely
the issue for every strong player every
player every player has an issue it when
time gets low it's just how it is that's
how it goes here she has like six
seconds you only get two second
increment here and you have to almost
move instantly and you're playing origin
but I do prefer her position she has a
lot of initial I mean there's stuff like
Rook E4 it is very popular it's a big
big threat rookie four with a discovered
check a disco as we call it will be
arriving
that is good stuff Chad let's go so what
happens after rookie for eign
it's sort of never coming into the game
white just wants to play G3 put that
Rook on G2 and then start pushing the G
Pawn that Bishop on C3 has got no future
anymore it's on a really beautiful
square but it does nothing yeah it's
sort of outside the game yeah this is
probably like the best worst bishop ever
like it's the best worst Bishop in your
life because it is very active like it's
hitting some squares but it's actually
hitting I'm seeing us in the chest book
it's like hitting air it's literally
hitting nothing and I'm never gonna put
a piece there I'm just gonna play around
this bishop the rest of the game now of
course it's obviously called the Bishops
a lot of times people think this is a
draw oh it's a draw opposite color
Bishop but in fact it's further from the
truth in fact from that it's not a draw
yet because there's still a lot of play
left but also when they come when it
comes to attacking and defending this
bishop can never defend any of the light
squares so if we attack on the light
squares if we're able to make an attack
with the light squares we'll be able to
win again name other Bishop can't help
here he's also out of the game so this
Bishop's not in the game you may have to
give up a pawn which are already down
one right so white is definitely for
Choice here being up to pawn and the
better pieces as well
wow and now I see they've Albert doesn't
like what arjun's done because it gives
a lot of activity to the king you can go
Rook cage for check but that allows King
G3 and black actually picks up G3 and F4
if all these pawns get traded off which
they are about to James then the bishop
on C3 is not the best worst Bishop
anymore because it's on the right side
that's right yeah he blundered very hard
there I'm not even a lot F4 is just not
the greatest move obviously but he did
fix it F4 he played rookies four Rook H5
Rook F5 and then take on C5 so this is
good we also could actually take this
twice maybe try to win this one too wow
okay this is really exciting but the
other board with nehal Serene and
savitas because this is an end game and
it might end in a draw we will quickly
go into that one as both players are
playing on seconds can nehal do
something in this position I see the
eval bar top right board there
completely crushing but I don't see the
winning blow Queen G5 Queen F6 coming in
this is big trouble one second for
savitasri
um yeah there it is something
Something's Gonna Fall somewhere and it
did there but why the evil bar go down
after that that's crazy okay Rook Cafe I
just moved the Rook oh what you take
here okay I take here on E6 oh Lord wait
she just landed a queen
you don't ever expect to see that like
what is that that's not a move oh
because the Queen's hanging bro
well yeah but the Ping On seconds James
we've seen crazier things happen than
that and it's not just this moment it
was the whole pressure of the entire
game and finally nihal takes the point
we've got the final game remaining our
generic SC with an extra Pawn but an
opposite color Bishop let's go straight
to that one where Charlie's trying to
hold with seconds on the clock but now
that the entire play is on the queen
side that best worst Bishop is actually
the best best Bishop now for black
everything under control James I think
even with seconds vaishali will hold
this against Arjun I'm actually gonna
play uh the other the other way I'm
actually gonna say Bishop check and I'm
gonna sack and I'm gonna actually sack
my Rook at some point on the palm of the
bishop try to win if I could sack my
rook and win both the pawns I'm gonna
win this game but if I only win one of
them then it's going to be a draw so I
have to see if I'm able to do this and I
think he's going to try to eventually go
for this plan but it's gonna take some
time you also have to be careful of a
counter sack like if I move King B5 or
maybe a rook at D3 you know yourself
taste takes and then I have to worry
about sacking myself so it is something
to pay attention to here but he's
definitely going to try to play on play
for some tricks here five seconds for
vishality can she hold oh my gosh
I love that idea that you're mentioning
sacrifice The Rook for D4 it's on
arjun's mind but he needs to time it
super well Charlie playing on seconds
and this is the decider game the teams
are on one and a half each whoever wins
this takes them round
yeah it takes around this is interesting
here uh let's see what we got we might
just take a draw like I just think he
drove Charlie's strong I mean he really
earned it here
he's gonna go Rook F4 and at least
threaten pretend to threaten Rook D4
it's a really great spot by you James
Goes rookie too he's still holding on no
repetition there
rookie 4 and takes on D4 I mean yeah you
could try it this is yeah this is
difficult to really win here and she the
problem is like she has the two second
increment and will Rook be fine no that
doesn't do anything it doesn't help you
because Bishop on C3 it's safeguards not
just stupid A5 as well you're so funny
he's like the the best worst Bishop
finally like that was the best best
bishop ever like I mean this was such a
bad bishop and now it's the greatest
piece on the board like it's literally
the greatest piece ever be holding
Black's position together now here we go
this might be it are you gonna do it or
not no I mean he made he made he's
thinking about it go back one time not
anymore you can't do it right now you
have to fall back with the bishop
also right that is very very possible
I mean counter sacks everywhere oh my
gosh
decision to take when you're playing on
seconds to just sacrifice your Rook so
one can understand the hesitation by the
players here no I'm good
nah I'm good don't do it yet don't do it
water's too cold water is too cold all
right
wow rugby one that's kind of an
interesting Square for The Rook I was
just against the pre-move king B2 sure
oh my goodness what are they doing wake
up wake up
wake up
Queen hang
oh my gosh
I wish Charlie she can't take it she
just leaves the board immediately what a
big blunder gifting the point to our
generic acid to team MGD one and that
means MGD one with that slip by vaishali
that one move blunder takes round two
same round same round different teams
but same round she definitely uh she was
she was holding that she was if she had
more time she would 100 hold that it was
just a time thing it really is tough to
see that that end game was fantastically
played by vaishali absolutely against
the player like Arjun she created her
chances she kept the fort and it was
being held super well and one more
blunder but that's what this format is
it demands the best in these players in
those time scrambles and now that means
mgd1 Strikes Back in round two two and a
half to one and a half James this is
going to be a super close match
absolutely of course we love to see it
the close matches the crazy stuff the
hangings the mates the wild attacks
origin goes down first round to the ward
four who's not really bored for he's
just you know board four for the team
obviously but super strong here as we
still have almost even match one point
game
or the Indian yogis and the one pair
who's made that possible is their second
good look at that a hundred percent so
far today James even in the
quarterfinals he was The Shining Star
along with it in that matchup and today
he is on fire in control on the clock
and on the board as well the first team
to reach eight and a half points will
win the third place at the protest
League absolutely got adipam with two
out of two and Niha with two out of two
that's great I mean that's a great star
for both sides here it's only a one
point game two matches two rounds to go
here so you got to pay attention we
gotta step it up and for both for both
sides actually you know especially if
you lost your blunder you did something
it is what it is get over it we got two
more games to do here and play out and
we'll see who wins who gets third and
who gets four
this is going to be a big close fight
chat call us who do you think will win
this match and the one player who's been
winning all the games so far nehal
Serene has been dominating in this
consolation match when we come back we
will see if the yogis can get one step
closer to claiming third place
thank you
the best way to follow any chess event
from the Champions chess tour to the
candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
I remember that day it was Unreal I
definitely felt like I was walking on
air
yeah it was like such a beautiful
feeling because I won the the first
championship that was actually combining
women and men into the same section so
in addition to winning the title and the
money which I really needed it was like
something like 9 500 but I was like a
college student at the time and like
literally that's like all the money I
had in my bank account after cashing
that check so that was really cool and
then also I kind of I have Norm so it
was like a little bit of everything
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this year saw the return of the protest
league and thank goodness chat so good
to have you back PCL this is nice
let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh one
hundred thousand dollars up for grads
the final day of the protest League
playoffs has finally arrived Queen to
Chief oh my God oh my God
I'm Out Boy the PCL is here to stay who
will be crowned its next Champion Oh
What A Move relax everywhere relax
she's bought for pranesh does it once
again for the Indian yogis
India number three visit Gujarati has
been a pillar for the Indian yogis
getting them so far at the protest
League he was one of the very few
players in the league who took down
Magnus Carlsen in the earlier season and
now we see with it with one and a half
points out of two he is looking for a
big win in this match leading from the
front as they face mgd1 and there we see
with it with one and a half out of the
nehal Serene with a hundred percent
score and James vaishali played an
excellent game against Arjun but a mouse
slip cost it all it's tough it's part of
the game and it is a you know it's part
of the game there I think you you have
to take something from every game and in
that game near first you know watch the
mouth slips also wants the time because
the mouse club came in another game that
she had time trouble the first game was
the same way she lost yeah even though
she was very very very low on time she
had 1.3 seconds left when she finished
that game so it's tough you know you
have to try to take what you can from
each gaming in this one and then this
round forget about the other ones but
also hey I gotta move a little bit
faster just a little bit and then we'll
see what happens
you have to focus on the positive is
right now for vaishali the fact that she
played such a great game against a very
strong opponent our generic as he kept
things under control there is a lot of
positive takeaways for her and that's
what she needs to focus on as she plays
her very good friend in the next round
it is going to be vaishali against
savitar these two have the same trainers
they work together they play together at
many tournaments we see them even stay
together so they know each other in an
artboard right now no friendship on the
board with so much on the line the yogi
is leading by just one point James I
think that both three will be really
important for this round absolutely
there's gonna be some heat there
definitely some heat and some animosity
and like hey I know you're my friend but
right now I don't like you don't look at
me don't talk to me we don't work the
same we don't walk the same we're not on
the same page we gotta you know
Somebody's gotta win that one there of
course board three and board four you
can really have your board three and
four setup is gonna be good look at Audi
the Beast
he's really been showing why he's called
the beast the kind of Chess that we've
been seeing in the first two rounds from
adiban he has been a great uh force to
reckon with in the protest League it is
his aggressive style of play and right
now he will be facing his good friend
visit Gujarati he will be playing with
the white pieces as you said James right
now none of these players like each
other they are just thinking about how
they're gonna win this game friendship
comes later yeah right you're like yeah
I'm just I just only see red or I only
see white and blue because that's what
color the squares are for this board but
here we go a knight F3 and Knight F6
okay here we go
okay first time I play this OTB I
actually I beat it I am in like 20 moves
I'm not gonna lie I felt good I was like
Wow ADI ADI talk to me and then I
watched in the same tournament to
another strong I am because I thought I
could do it you know back to back I'm
like shoot if this is what it's doing
Cowboys let's try again it didn't work
the second time the way did it worked
the first time but it was very good it's
a very good opening here it's very fun
Hikaru scores 60 plus with this opening
but he is he uses the E3 line let's see
what Audi goes for
1v3 well not one B three but two B three
in this case but it is a similar ideas
and for adipan this is also a very
psychological move because of course
there's so much talk around pushing that
beep on early on and we saw with it
slowing down he needs to think how he
has to counter it psychologically a
little shaky but with it goes for the
most topical most direct way of taking
control of the center this is the most
dynamic response against the cowboy
system the B3 whether it's played on
move one or on move two I'm actually
happy to see this E3 move here of course
uh because E6 I mean this is this scores
really nicely for white if you go E6
here but Bishop F5 and Bishop G4 are the
more challenging ones right uh you also
could play G6 too but the E6 is not you
know this is the Queen's game decline
setup you just go D4 you take so he goes
G6 yeah this is a nice setup G6 with a
G6 setup here you have Bishop B5 as a
move and D4 is the theory you go super
Bishop B5 nice should be five if Knight
C6 and I think we take first and play
95.
plays Bishop D7 takes on F6
and he takes takes takes and I think he
goes C4 remember the theory D4
okay yeah
strikes in the center with D4 but that's
quite an early decision to actually give
up that dark Squad Bishop on B2 on F6
now adibon of course is an expert in
this line he knows what he's doing and
the whole idea revolves around not just
not just spoiling the pawn structure on
the king side bit as he showed
immediately striking in the center not
making it easy for black to develop that
Bishop on f8 you want to arrive on G7
and I'm expecting black to do that
because after Bishop G7 there are all
these ideas of why taking the pawn on C5
F5 you can plant a knight on D4 so
Ashley it does get a little tricky and
Vivid has to think whether he wants to
take that risk but if he doesn't how
does he finish development
that's a great question here in fact uh
and and the problem here is actually
figuring out what you want to do with
your knight so he actually has told us
here what to do Knight takes D4 now we
have a constant weakness for the rest of
the game the subject can be bullied here
this is kind of nice for why we do just
have a strategic
advantage in that sense okay well now
he's giving up
this is still gonna be weak so mine can
be defended okay so that makes sense
definitely interesting but makes a lot
of sense
yeah he just wants to put pressure on
the D5 pawn and of course if black was
to take on D4 if you take with the
bishop you give up a big big minor piece
and basically compare the structures
white is clearly better the queen will
come to F3 hit that pawn on D5 hit that
pawn on F6 that's trouble so you don't
really want to capture that D4 Knight
James with the bishop and if we back up
if you take on D4 with the Knight trying
to dissolve that isolated Queen's Pawn
in the center you lose more Tempo again
the queen is landing on F3 soon rookie
one is a check that you don't want to
face and this is big trouble as well but
the point is that if you don't take on
D4 in the current position as we have it
white simply will fall back with the
Knight on the next move no more
opportunity and you have to kind of live
with that isolated Queen spawn on the
fire for the rest of the game absolutely
this is a quite simple one thing about
this opening is the plans can be very
simple and also of course him being the
Beast right very aggressive player is
positioned as it says there are a lot of
aggressive intentions of course and we
just already created ourselves a Target
to something to do two uh two pawns here
are actually quite weak right and
sometimes if we're able to even win this
one or 94 Knight F6 it's going to be
problems there if we can even get a
queen sometimes on this diagonal so
there's lots of play for white and of
course black has to tread lightly in
fact I mean as you see he's three minute
time ends right here almost three
minutes here and vidit is going to have
to figure this one out very quickly due
to the pawn here now of course engines
say equal they even prefer black by like
you know as you see it says like point
two here on the engine but that is uh
with for engine like Precision it's
going to be very difficult to uh to play
this as a human do due to the weaknesses
and understanding what happens with
these weaknesses Vivid knows oh I have a
isolated Pawn he's gonna try to bully
this he knows that so he's trying to
figure out what to do what is my plan
going to be around that
I'll tell you one thing but it doesn't
like positional weaknesses because he's
so strong in his positional
understanding that he would hate to play
long term with that D5 weakness which is
why he takes a decision immediately of
taking on D4 and in that way there's no
more isolated Queen spawn but now white
has a long-term Edge and we had a great
question there by Warden plays I think
that why did white give up the bishop
and the reasons were to destroy the pawn
structure and as we can see vidit was
forced to return that bishop and end up
in this middle game position with a
slightly worse structure this is going
to be a long one we'll see if adiban can
make the most of it but with it took his
time there let's zoom out take our time
to look at the other boards because
there are tactics everywhere take a look
on what is happening on that top right
board Now azerine versus Arjun aragassi
I was talking about vaishali Savita
being great friends James nehal and
Arjun they have trained together they've
worked together they are best of friends
and again look at the kind of Chess that
we is seeing the Friendship has been
thrown out of the window for now pawns
are on H4 pawns are on G4 the pawns are
being thrown at the opponent's king
what's going on there yeah first I
thought it was a job of London because
origen plays your Bible London then I
saw where there's a bishop on G2 so it's
definitely not that because the pawns on
G4 and H4 are very common jobava London
idea you put a knight on E5 you go G4
and H4 you go from eight every game but
the bishop won G2 this makes this
different so I had to actually look and
think to myself where did they even how
does this even happen where is this so
let's actually start from the beginning
to see how they got here Knight of 3d5
there was a king's Indian attacking away
sort of catalan-like Bishop G2 Knight H4
H3 right castles B3 a little bit of
space very creative G4 and H4 and this
is the live position I actually like
white because I have experience in
pushing my pawns like this a lot of
experience every night we play this and
we do this type of stuff so it is very
fun to play very fun to play as we see
uh even Niha wasn't a think tank he's
been thinking for a little bit here
because H5 is a thing if you push the H
Pawn we take on G6 damage the structure
play G5 ourself make G6 very weak you
can end up moving The Rook usually The
Bishop's on D3 so we can be able to take
that G6 Pawn that might be there so
there's lots of plans and ideas here for
white I mean it's fun you can also even
play F4 F5 but you do have to watch out
for Bishop E4 I do like white here we do
need to develop like I mean look at this
come on now excuse me we have to get our
pieces out that first game origin played
he lost because he didn't get his pieces
out so hopefully he's able to do that
here but G4 and H4 it is quite scary and
H6 is on the board we might see Knight
G6
yeah because H5 was a big threat you
were just trapping that Bishop if it
would have come to E4 there was F3
winning the piece on the spot so as you
pointed out the drawback off the spawn
move eight six is that it allows white
to capture on G6 and what black has to
really take not a great Pawn structure
there recapturing with the F Pawn it
would be a dream to take with the H Bond
and immediately Arjun targets it with
the move Queen D3 and it's clear that
what black could pick up the Knight on
Chief the pawn on G4 but the problem
with that is after Knight G4 Queen takes
G6 you hit the Knight you hit the pawn
on E6 and sure you can fall back with
the Knight to F6 but then you lose the
pawn on 86 there's a pin on G7 and this
would be ggs so Knight G4 is not
possible and that means there's a real
threat you don't want to make a move
like King 87 because that allows H5 to
come in and really putting pressure on
that diagonal it's not ideal for black
to let that happen but if not then do
you make a move like Queen E8 is that
the way that you defend the G6 Pawn I
was actually looking at Queen a for sure
Queen E8 is definitely a move I've seen
a lot in these type of positions not
only can I defend this one but if I move
the bishop then I can defend E6 too as
well so both my pawns to get defended
quite nicely or quite clever like
um with the queen here I don't really
make any you know uh committal moves
anymore as well and white still has to
develop you still have to get your
pieces out right so but it's 94 talk
about creative there 92 play instantly
hey bro nope I know what you wanted 92
now we trade because this Knight is
absolutely annoying so now you have to
move it for sure either 96 or F6 or take
1d2
because G6 is hanging so you've got to
watch out for that and nehal Serene is
playing ambitiously that is clear with
that last move he is on two out of two
so far we asked our chat will nehal
finish with a perfect score today and
James 59 saying yes he will well I think
this game will decide at all if he's
able to win with the black pieces I mean
it has kind of already been an MVP
player for the Indian yogis but today he
might be the biggest hitter
if he is especially we can take down
origin I mean that's huge absolutely
huge they're already friends um but also
Rivals and also like up and coming Stars
right at the same time so you know if he
can take down you know a strong player
like our generic I say that's gonna be
huge here especially this is the number
one for the team give him another ale
because he lost already it's gonna be uh
nice and anyhow it's gonna be feeling
really good about that but you know
Arjun wants to strike back himself and
just prove for the team also keep uh
trying to level the score we're down a
point here MGD one is so gotta figure it
out Knight to D2 and nehal is down a lot
of time here almost five minutes
James I'm telling you it doesn't matter
and a hall can be done any amount of
time his best chess is played when he's
got 10 seconds on the clock that's too
much time for now anything more than
that is a classical game for nihan
I I do agree I do
three there he is like 3100 in Bully
bully crazy like that so of course he
does living at times at that time uh
time deficit also just like grish it
gets stronger as the time gets lower so
that's quite quite scary here quite
scary five minute time Edge though Arjun
is up and we're gonna have to get a move
here from nihal
but I'm really surprised because if you
just pull up the analysis board how
quickly Arjun took the decision to play
Knight D2 that last move by nehal was
upon sacrifice he basically said you can
give up your G2 Bishop Bishop E4 D takes
E4 Queen E4 James to me that looks like
a free Pawn because yes you can take on
H4 but I'm spoiled for choice I could
take on E6 or I could take on G6 but
with a lot of speed Arjun decided to not
give up that Bishop he feels that's a
key defender in the position it's more
valuable than the pawn especially
because of the G4 H4 advances and we
were talking about development instead
he makes the move Knight to D2
there's also some huge weaknesses going
on with the bishop
um for for obviously black with the
light Square so he would be happy to
trade this bishop um this bishop for the
night here so that the light squares can
be a little bit stronger in fact so we
won't have to deal with the problems
that go with that in fact Knight D2 he
still has not moved he is in the tank
in the think tank for real nihar is
thinking thinking right now uh almost
under a minute here
yeah he's touching the two minute MOG
and Arjun is up by almost six and a half
minutes on the clock nehal takes on D2
he picks up the H for pawn and look at
the speed with which arjun's playing
he's calculated till the end of the game
it feels like look at the way they are
blitzing trade trade trade trade and now
E5 in the center and James how are you
evaluating who do who does this sequence
of moves
um workfall well you know we have the
bishop I do have the bishop pair wait
right which in an open position that's
what we want is the bishop pair but very
nice solid move from nihal here just
saying hey yeah we're gonna call this in
the books they say Bishop is biting on
granite that's what they say literally
in the books in the chess book so the
bishop is biting on granite here after
C6 move very strong and E4 can be played
I think this may be closer to a draw but
actually the fact that I have the two
Bishops you also have a weak Pawn on A5
that is already stopped by my A4 Pawn
I'm still gonna take y here I do need to
open up the game probably a little bit
more with some E4 get my Rooks a little
bit active and we'll see what happens
there maybe an F5 it does weaken the
squares maybe E4 maybe bishop F3 like
some improving moves things like this
maybe even a C4 but that's gonna be too
committal I don't need to do that at all
so maybe even something like this lots
of moves but I definitely think a white
definitely has a slight Edge due to the
bishop
really nicely explained there all the
points that you make James I agree with
you especially the bishop pair that
night on B6 is restricted by that pawn
on B3 so things looking good right now
for Arjun and we will keep an eye out
and make sure that we don't miss out on
the classic nehal bullet play that is
definitely going to come up on this game
but let's zoom out for a moment because
action is on everywhere now top left it
does look like a game that's close to a
draw but if anyone can push in that
position it's got to be white simply
because look at the pawn structure for
with it impossible to create a passer on
the king side for adiban with the three
verses too it is easier for him to
create chances but I think this one will
end in a draw where it should be able to
hold this because it just feels like
it's not going to be enough meanwhile
bottom left board so many pieces on the
board this is far from an end game and
James that's a really interesting
position and one of the standout points
is that you compare the outposts the D4
square and the D5 Square the fact that
white snake can get to D5 I think that
gives vaishali a nagging Edge in the
position
absolutely how to do let's actually step
over there yeah because our Knight can
get to D5 that is just literally the
difference but also I mean comparing
pieces is one thing I like to do when
you're looking at positions is to see
who has a slight Edge or who may have a
slight Edge right and I think it's
definitely white if we compare pieces
this bishop is just better than this one
it's tucked on f8 is hitting really
nothing here this bishop yeah okay I'm
biting on granite once again right as we
talked about this term before I'm
hitting both diagonals here pretty nice
but it's not you know I'm not
threatening anything but my Bishop is
better than this one this Knight can
have better prospects B5 sometimes maybe
even B5 than this Knight this Knight
can't get really get to D4 here it's
just kind of Defending right here I'm
sorry defending in D5 and at some point
if the queen moves we actually have
tactics like Bishop H6 with Queen F6
because uh of the looseness of this area
so white definitely is for choice we
have tricks if Knight D5 we can take and
put the Rook on D5 and attack the E Pawn
double the Rooks it almost looks like
the game
um in the last round with nehal that had
uh the two Rooks on the e-file and just
a better position where you just kind of
slightly improve every single move so
looks like one of those here from White
uh once again here but the shali is on
the end of this
yeah
absolutely and she's thinking what's the
way forward because Knight D5 you want
to play it but you want to play it at
the right moment right now everything
under control in this one where Charlie
is thinking it's clear even with the
eval bar that if anyone's pushing here
it's got to be the Indian yogis so let's
just zoom out because we do see a lot of
dynamic play happening all around we
will use this opportunity to also take a
look at that bottom right board because
there's a mate in one that has been
threatened by diptyan gosh he has just
made the move Queen C7 and I know we
keep saying this but the reality is that
players have missed a mate in one in the
Pro chess League yeah we've seen in fact
I think one round it was like two of
them in the same round like mating ones
like just gotten made it in one move
twice in the same round just doesn't
happen at this caliber of play right so
it was cool to see that but of course
Maiden one was threatened very easily
parried by G3 Bishop G5 hitting on The
Rook here we might have an F4 trying to
break this up unless we go F4 ourselves
this
is waking are weaking or weakening our
position though
like a middle decision it comes with the
tempo and he's definitely thinking about
this but the problem is the long term
things that will start affecting white
especially that E4 Square for example
after F4 black can think about
retreating and offering a bishop trade
it's by the way on the board oh it is
Let me refresh
uh I do not see it actually no F4 hasn't
been played yet the players are still in
the
tip and once again you can see the
weaknesses in White's Camp if White had
played f4s
right Rook D1 and we're talking about
here F4 Bishop here takes takes and you
see you can feel you can just feel the
dark Square weaknesses and the white
king being a little bit looser also C5
is a thing too like you just have to be
careful you have to trade very lightly
here but in the game there was actually
Rook to D1 to happen for D to D1 and
this is the live position
so Rook D1 still making sure that things
are under control and we do have the
have a have a first result of round
three with it against adiban we call
that one uh James The Rook Pawn ending
it ended in a draw so action on these
are the three boards and look at this
speaking of action on it's literally on
with that move F4 diptiangosh is going
for the win in this one absolutely I
mean you have everything lined up for an
attack you you want obviously maybe in
one more uh one more piece or something
in this attack but like a H5 H4 this is
gonna be it takes two moves which is a
lot of time in chess but Pawn takes H5
H4 is definitely something you want to
weaken it or soften the squares is what
they call it even a pawn takes and Tanya
Bishop H4 in some of these cases maybe
even if you take it this way for
instance let's just make a move I don't
know later rookie one on takes takes you
may have something like Bishop to F4 in
many cases or Bishop to H4 which is
really cool idea here is actually after
Pawn takes your queen takes now of
course you know uh this is there's
something here obviously in this
position or the position before as the
eval bar jumped there but we're just
showing ideas to understand black is
definitely on the attack right now
rookie 1X is on the board so we might
have something similar to this yeah and
that was a great point that you made
because James I'm still understanding
how does white actually survived that
position it's such a great attacking
concept you take on G3 you take twice on
G3 you put that Bishop on F4 gf4 Queen
F4 wide the eval bar not even not
approve of that because it looks Queen
H2 Queen H1 coming in maybe you just
take on C6 you trade something wrong you
take on F4 gf4 Queen F4 and I wonder if
Tanya oh my goodness the move here is
only is crazy oh my gosh it's Knight D5
what
I mean hey look you know if this is how
you lose and then like hey look his
chest is hard right 95 is ridiculous
okay that is everything that's a sick
movement James back up for a second is
gf4 a bad move okay we've got so much
action on gf4 was also I think oh it
doesn't work so great tactics there by
you James Knight D5 was the move but
none of this has happened instead of
going for this we've got the H Pawn
Advance as well and black eventually
falls back with the bishop to E7 there
are still ideas of H4 really putting
pressure on G3 that's the big dream and
I'm surprised that the eval bar actually
prefers pernicious position because I
would be terrified with white hair
yeah I mean I would definitely feel some
heat but after this Knight D6 move that
is quite annoying good if I take take
take take wow
that's pretty good all right 56 is nice
wow that's a sweet move bro Knight D6 it
really turned the table but we're also
seeing tables are being turned on that
bottom left board James Knight has
landed on D5 vaishali is winning that
position we were talking about it that
this looks very difficult for
savitashree mean while on the top left
things are equal so we will go into this
game James that Bishop 86 sacrifice that
you had mentioned it happened she
blundered into Queen C8 and you were
talking about the queen defending the
Knight as soon as it left vaishali went
boom Bishop 86 on the board and that's
just an extra Pawn
yeah we were talking about this I mean
actually sorry uh right around here
let's move this up here and uh uh eight
and here here here here so we got to
this position and like you know you can
spot Bishop H6 you see Knight D5 you
just see all the position the potential
I was even considering even the G4 H4 G5
because my position is so good as white
I can just kind of do anything
everything's nice and defended so
actually after the moves happened here
H4 and in the blunder there immediately
Bishop takes H6 and now we're just
winning boom thank you for the pawn now
I get the Knight coming in the D5 and
this is going to be pretty nice like we
have three I guess you kind of have
maybe you don't have to is there
something better I'm just curious yeah
rookie one and with the idea of just a
simple simple and if Bishop G7 you maybe
go Queen C6 I hit the tempo yeah rookie
one Bishop G7 Queen C6 and then I go
rookie three with G3 and just went uh in
many cases so but she played a queen F3
where like especially if I'm black I'm
trading that as fast as you put that
there right so you just want to trade on
I lost the pawn there I mean White's
definitely for choice I got the pawn
structure is bad but I do have Knight
versus Bishop here I think White's
definitely gonna uh I'm playing for two
results to say the least it is unless
she gets in that time trouble is having
a trouble with her clock in his last few
games so we'll see what happens yeah no
100 that Queen trade it probably could
have been avoided or delayed by vaishali
just felt like she had a strong attack
incoming but after this also she has an
extra Pawn she will try to fight for the
g-file another problem is you want to
make a move like H5 but that allows a
lot of activity for the black Bishop
landing on G5 it's on the board and I'm
pretty sure that Savita will make the
move Bishop G5
there it is Mr G5 and as we speak about
this game we have another result Tanya
board two is a draw board two is a draw
that is our generic icy in the
househaran with a draw on that board
which still keeps the yogis up one
wow and nehal with the black pieces now
at two and a half out of three so a
really great run by him so far in this
match now this one is so important will
vaishali be able to convert this now the
problem was that after Bishop G5 you
actually cannot keep your pieces
defending the C4 Pawn she didn't want to
exchange on D4 allows a passer now the
material is evil and James I don't think
this position holds that much poison for
Savita anymore
in fact I mean this could change this
could actually turn the tables I mean
it's nice so strong on D5 I really don't
see it's gonna take a lot to lose this
game I think but she is down a lot of
time and we saw in the last game with
Arjun she was holding if she had an
extra two minutes on a clock she would
have been able to draw our generic guys
see in that position easily but she had
no time and she actually ended up
blundering due to a mouse slip very
tough but it also is part of the game
and vishali here is down to six seconds
to a minute right so it is tough here
and I mean if I'm black here I'm
definitely pushing I got the pawn back
now you have the word structure and no
time so this could definitely switch
here I mean vishali really has to work
on the time management there to not give
your opponent these type of chances I
completely agree with you here and then
again the clock situation is one thing
but also look at Black's Rooks on the C5
fully fully in control black can look at
long term trying to create a passer on
the Queen's side that's the idea she she
starts with the trade on C2 also makes a
lot of sense you can start pushing for
the A3 Pawn what white wants to do is
get that Rook on the open file if
vishali goes through K2 which she has
Rook D3 defends it and now Rook C3 is
coming in trying to get some activity
for white species Black's hope here is
to create a past Pawn on the Queen's
side but James I don't know if she'll
have enough time to do that four seconds
three seconds and made that with three
seconds on the clock is up to 5.8 you
only get two seconds per move so you may
oh I guess this is two second increment
but you only got a few seconds every
move so you have to move almost
instantly here can't you go Bishop D2
Bishop E1 here is that tricky I also
wanted to go Bishop C oh Bishop D2
Bishop E1 that was nice time it should
be two Bishop E1 I didn't even defend
that that might have been something
time is getting a little bit closer from
Vishal and I'm feeling a little bit
better there's a time it's closer
because Knight A6 is it goes Bishop
shooting
she's going for the 80
th and if the Rooks are traded black is
clearly better if you have a passer on
the queen side now Rook D3 has been
played she picks this up and I think
this momentum is really shifting that
beep on is very dangerous
wow wow we have another result for next
one on board four per Nash one on board
four putting a Yogi's up two now wow so
Savita has to win this game to equalize
the match to equalize this round
yogis will still be leading by a point
but B2 has been played by James this is
not a winning position for black you
can't make any progress with that B Pawn
anymore
yeah this is this should be a draw let's
say should be
yes because anything can happen on
second you know what I mean I don't know
is she just marching down the board with
the King F6 oh my goodness oh gosh is
the evil bar right now evil bar evil
somehow this is completely winning
and now it's not second push or
something and now let's draw
yeah but then how do you win like how do
I win it okay easy
[Music]
they about to end it now they're gonna
I'm not gonna do it
wow what a game be Shelly James this
last position let's just show it you
take on E6 F7 you can't stop the pawn
feeding and that would be game over
there was no way to survive this and if
instead that's it James you can give a
million Jacks this will be game over and
if instead in that position you move the
king to E8 trying to be clever trying to
be tricky if we just go back here King
eat it you don't take on F7 the move E7
comes in and drip B8 would be
unstoppable you actually that's a mate
in one Rook beard you're absolutely
right that would be game over awesome
doesn't matter right this is GG you can
start a new one be Charlie with a win a
much needed win putting the yogis up all
they need is one now and they're taking
third place and the bragging Mouse
unbelievable for the second in time
today the Indian yogis win the round
with a 3-1 margin what a performance by
them and again nehal Serene where the
draw holds our generic acid the top
Board of mgd1 vaishali with a tough
start James and it's such a difficult
point to come back from two losses
especially the one against Arjun so
close to a draw she shows immense mental
strength winning this last game in
really great style a great end game play
there what was the highlight for you oh
the Highlight for me was definitely in
every Charlotte game she just won like
she won the game there right you hear
the sirens chat like it's that's crazy
it's insane here like it's really going
down here that's a great performance in
that round and much needed win for
vishali especially having the game
before that with origin where she should
have held but she could because of the
time time got an issue here she almost
lost but she ultimately won the game for
the team they are one away now from
taking the third place
James you need one point to seal the
deal they need one point to win this
match in the next round team MGD one has
to win with a margin of three and a half
to half to force the playoff
how where do you see that happen how how
is that going to happen against the team
with nehal vaishali bouncing back and
for Niche the 16 year old Grandmaster I
wonder if there's a stat for this but if
if there's a stat of course we may be
able to get this if uh for the The
Comebacks that did happen what round was
it because this is probably the round
that it may not be it may be the
lopsider rounds like maybe for around
two or round three when you're not
playing the board ones right and then
here you're playing your board your
respective board in this round usually I
mean that's just harder to do especially
at the tops the GMS they don't always
just cross each other a lot of times
they are just draws and they play two
draws and then the lower boards is where
you need your points but you need you
know three or four points in this next
round just to make it to the tie breaks
here it's going to be very difficult
uphill task for MDG one for sure
a hundred percent Indian yogis have been
dominating this match so far and with it
has played a great role in that and up
next we do have the board ones squaring
off it's with it and Arjun in round four
that's a big matchup for the Indian fans
who will prevail and claim the third
place prize we'll be right back with all
the action don't go anywhere
thank you
and becoming a chess streamer like your
favorite creators such as Hikaru Gotham
chess and the botan sisters come on look
at this
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
foreign
[Music]
my name is Edward Dawson I'm from
Chicago I'm secret Blackman my name is
Roberto bezo Jr and what I want to share
is I love tacos tacos and chests
[Music]
the chess program really even chess in
general like on the deck you uh you kind
of Lose Yourself you don't really think
about your case we learn to think
differently you know you strategize more
I sometimes come out uh 7 30 in the
morning I'll probably play until lock up
you know so it makes my day go by faster
it's competitive it's a lot of trash
talk it's it's crazy you know like the
chess players we got our own little
circle you know and all of us play each
other we talk trash about who be who who
garbage yeah I never played that dude
again he got rich I never plan but yeah
it's real competitive
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we are about to lift off the final round
in the fight for the third place for the
protest League it is between the Indian
yogis and the MGD one and all Indian
Clash for winning third place at the
protest League it's not a match that
either of these two teams wanted but
after a heartbreaking semi-finals we are
here and James it looks like a one-sided
Affair so far yeah 100 especially at
that last round round three is really a
deciding round we're like you know that
it it this could be it because round
four of course it's a huge up Bill Hill
battle we have to win on three boards at
least for team MGD one so you have to
figure out where those points going to
be if I'm Yogi's I'm just going to play
Super solid here not really give the
chances play my best game here team mg
D1 I'm gonna have to actually make some
some risks take some risk here in fact
and play what I usually wouldn't play I
need to actually win here I have to or
we just you know we get fourth place of
course we are still some money and it's
cool but we do want to third which is a
five thousand dollar difference
yeah it's so much to fight for and of
course the bragging rights of being the
strongest team in the Pro chess League
season 23 from India as these two teams
do fight it out we've seen some great
performances by the and by the Indian
yogis today and we also saw Savita SRI
she is currently struggling for MGD one
she will be playing against pranesh in
that last round James let's take a look
at our pairings for this action that is
coming up and there we see this is the
final round the Marquee round where we
have the most even match ups some big
big names they're fighting each other we
see Savita will be taking on pranesh
vaishali who are the tough start with a
big win against Savita in the last round
definitely a confidence boost for her
and then we've got nehal versus adiban
that's gonna be a fun one James no
that's gonna be probably a very a slug
fast hopefully as we see there because
they're both very aggressive players now
I think it's more Universal but his
tactics when you see them are razor
sharp so more of a universal player than
anything else the Beast is the Beast for
a reason we have arjunior geissy versus
vide that's going to be nice to see as
well I mean I mean absolutely powerful
chess Indian powerhouses going at it and
then you're singing here right now
Indian chess fans assembled because this
is the footboard one fight that is
coming up it is with Gujarati taking on
arjunargasi they have played each other
a bunch of times and Arjun leads with
two wins one losses one loss and two
draws James we also see their feet rapid
ratings Arjun actually is higher rated
in standard of course standard classical
rating with it currently at India number
three Arjun India number five this is
always a matchup that is super exciting
for the Indian fans it is the upcoming
the rising star the future of Indian
chess against the pillar the current
pillar of Indian chess with Gujarati
absolutely of course Gujarat we know him
I mean he's been around for a long time
and he's not going anywhere origin the
same way he's actually up and coming
super strong up and coming I mean wait
till he's 10 years from now where will
he be he's already 2700 super strong
player uh very likable right Indian
Powerhouse coming from nothing but
Indian Powerhouse is training with these
guys so this is going to be a class of
Titans here it's going to be nice to see
here as uh you know yogis is looking to
close it out now one point ends the
match you give him one point you go now
so you actually need to win on almost
all the boards here he went on all
boards you win the match but we need to
uh actually no four is uh yeah they
wouldn't imagine okay perfect
with three and a half wood force a tie
break but they need to get to that score
which means that the yogis can only
afford to give up half a point in this
match and look at this with it going for
a very attacking opening we are going to
see opposite side castling or we could
stick to his style and actually go
kingside gasoline we got a dragon we got
Castle Queen so let's go sex sack mate
oh man this about to get spicy chat this
is gonna get real spicy hopefully you
like a little side of spice because it
doesn't matter because you're gonna get
it this is actually a very sharp open
Dragon Sicilian it's gonna be very fun
as Bobby Fischer says the plan is very
simple we go G4 H4 a sack Sac mate this
is exactly what he's going for black on
the other side is trying to do the same
thing right open up some lines Queen hey
what a move is he what are you doing B5
you want to play B5 Queen E2 with an ic5
Bishop C3 we getting some Dragon this is
very dragon-like now I mean uh that's a
good move bro that's a very good movie
just hit go for it Bishop takes and
Bishop four is on tap your tactics
already Tanya we don't move 15.
this is an insane position and the speed
with which the two have been playing
they're clearly familiar with this this
is the first moment that Arjun slows
down after H4 of course it is a race to
each other's King black on the queen
side white on the king side H5 is coming
up next as you're pointing out does
Black start with Knight C5 putting
pressure on that A4 Pawn or will he
first trade on C3 I hate the idea of
giving that G7 Bishop that is the pillar
in Black's position for Arjun that
Bishop on G7 is an attacking Bishop but
equally the Defensive Dragon Bishop
that's not a bishop that's the dragon in
the possession that is this is the
dragon Bishop in fact I mean sometimes
if you're able to take a rook and the
rook and the bishop can be taken back
you actually don't give up this bishop
you would rather grab the pawn attack
the rook and go right back home because
of the weaknesses that it creates around
the king and also understanding how
strong this bishop is this is a very
very strong Bishop you also have H5 man
this is I mean I really like White's
positions here I do like I like the
accelerated Dragon myself
um because the dragon is very risky and
also if you don't get the right position
I remember Lavon said it's not all about
the mating attack and the dragon from
the white side it's more about you know
restricting Black's play and going into
a very nice end game I was like wow
that's just 2800 level because you know
it was 20 100 like 2800 level knowledge
there from LeBron aronian right so very
nice E5 F4 H5 all kind of stuff here G4
I mean at some point too so really nice
a little like White's position here but
you are playing Arjun so
and I want to point out the move E5 was
directed against black in fact giving
that Bishop physique for the C3 Knight
you block that because the A4 Pawn is a
big weakness so with it was not
comfortable going immediately with H5
allowing all these ideas on the queen
side he starts with E5 a nice move there
also now there is an outpost on D6 that
black needs to watch out for starts with
the move E6 so that there are no more
white pushing that pawn to that sixth
Square F4 plate G4 H5 you want that
Queen from E2 to slide down to H2 double
up on the H file as you said James
saxack and me but you gotta watch out G4
right now the bishop is on C6 so you
have to time it well you have to time it
well that you don't lose the H1 drug
absolutely we don't want to just give
that up I mean you can because it does
give away it like the exchange sacrifice
actually is quite legit after G4 and
Bishop takes and yeah I still have my
attacking chances I can play F5 your
light squares might be weak six you know
I mean 94 96 right so it is very
possible to play G4 but it's just not
necessary to play G4 like necessary
impossible or definitely different so
you don't have to do it it's not
necessary and you could just play
something like maybe Rook H3 first or
the problem is I do want to play G4 and
I want to be able to keep my work on H1
but you can't so you have to choose one
it was a rook and play G4 or move the
Rook here and here and play G4 but then
you can't get the queen in front of the
Rook which is something you actually
want ideally we want to play something
like G4 Queen H2 H5 take on G6 and play
Queen H7 we can't do that of course
because it's really annoying because the
bishop is on C6 so we can take on H1 so
we have to like he has to figure it out
here which you know is he's gonna try to
do in the next move here but first off
what does Arjun do where do you move
what yo we're looking at whites movies
H5 G4 all this other stuff what does
black
I think what black wants to do is go
Queen E7 and try and trade off as many
Rooks and get them off the board you
want to play Rook d8 or queen E7 here
the more Rooks that get traded the
easier it will become to handle the
attack on the king side so I like this
approach Queen E7 and we will see how
with it continues but let's also remind
everyone that team mgd1 has to score a
minimum of three and a half points to
level this match otherwise they will
finish fourth James look at the action
that we have all around the one board
you know which one catches my eye what
on Earth is that Knight doing on E3
bottom right board pranesh against
savitashri there's a knight on E3 a
check on B4 well it has to block it with
the bishop Bishop D2 feels like the way
to go why is white slowing down this is
madness yeah I think this is Theory
believe it or not let me actually check
this yeah I think this is Theory this is
that crazy one crazy 74 takes Knight F6
yeah Knight C3 correct E6 Knight takes
you play E5 yep here you go 94 yep and
then C4 or F4 C4 correct 93 Queen here
and then you actually believe it or not
you end up running the king up in some
cases you could like run the king up to
F3 your Sun lines with the King on F3
Bishop D2 was played
uh after a bit oh well shoot it wasn't
played oh Bishop D2 was gonna be played
here it was not Bishop D2 is actually a
simple move to make there's also weirdly
enough a king E2 and then put the king
all the way up here like this bikini two
there's Knight C4 like you have to be
careful you can also walk into this
believe it or not King F2 what a move
and after you check I go Bishop E3 like
this crazy stuff here this is some
Wicked lines you know what I mean like
this stuff is crazy it's so much fun but
that's what you needed for this round
too like they need to win so they're
going all aggressive everybody's going
aggressive here
it doesn't pranesh doesn't have to
Savita needs to create her chances but
as you said King E2 king after he just
looks like too much risk for white
Bishop D2 on the board and pranesh
continues to play confidently he
continues to play fast he's putting
pressure on C4 don't forget white cannot
pick up that quick Knight on either I
can't take this why can't I take the
Knight
what's going on here
so come on this is a free night uh oh I
can't take it oh baby you take my knight
I'll take your queen oh I can't take it
back oh wow that one's gonna hurt on the
way home
and that was not a possibility so the
Knight on E3 is still putting pressure
on that C4 pawn and I see that evalubar
didn't like Bishop A6 but James to me it
actually looks like a really strong move
because you've got a direct threat and
I'm just wondering does white have the
time to give a check on D6 Knight D6
check and the idea is that after Bishop
D6 I wanted to take on E3 but I see
Queen B2 is hanging as well so it looks
like the complications don't work out
for white yeah this is definitely
complicated complications right so this
is very cool stuff I am a fan of this
type of theory but you also have to like
you know you have to walk on very uh
thin ice here you have to be very
careful both sides actually the question
is what do we do right now
is oh yeah in the zone in the zone right
there I can't even see anything
under like you can't even see her face
like she she is in the zone locked in
locked in right now finesse looks more
calm he always looks like that though
this is nice I think you see that a lot
with the Indian players you're very
chill in winning losing very chill like
very chill very calm at something whoa
wait a second oh this should be two this
is why she was so focused what is going
on bro this is crazy 96 is coming in at
some point Knight D6 will come in at
some point but right now will white
bring in the Rooks first you can hit the
queen on B2 you can go Rook B1 you can
go Rook D1 lots of pleasant choices here
for white James that night on C4 you've
picked up a pawn but that Bishop on A6
is pinned that Knight is stuck on C4 for
a while you're still far away from
castling because D6 D6 check will arrive
D7 is weak I'm expecting a move like
Rook B1 and asking some well unpleasant
questions where do you go with your
queen I kind of only see one square
because you can't pick up the pawn on 82
Rook a one will lose that Bishop on A6
very nice here rugby one did happen What
do you do oh it's on the board bro what
you just took a pause did you just take
a pawn
you took a pawn there and says I got all
your pawns where are your pawns you
don't have any oh you got a few left
what are these what are those days what
they say these days what are those my
guy Queen takes E4 and look at all these
pawns like that I mean I do have a
tampons for a beast that's four Pawn
trophies James we gotta do a little
replay here to really understand because
the moves are Blitz start what just
happened there so Rook B1 attacking the
queen and as we were pointing out that
after Rook B1 you actually don't have a
good Square for the queen queen A3 you
trade and you lose the bishop on A6 so
that doesn't work
as we also pointed out that you can't
take on A2 because Rook A1 would win the
bishop on A6 so that doesn't work either
so in fact Knight E5 was the only move
and pranesh played it I have a feeling
that he's still in some kind of prep
here the speed look at his clock he's
got more time than what he started with
oh that's insane I didn't even notice
that that's what is I don't know man
make sure you got his fair play back
there yeah you got his fair play that
man 10 minutes bro he did not move he
instantly moved all the way up into move
20 21. yeah it's insane and he's got
four pawns for a piece and now even
though the eval Bar says white is better
this is far from clear this is a game
for all three results craziness will
happen but pranesh with still 10 minutes
on the clock a six minute a five minute
lead right now James let's zoom out from
this board every board matters for the
MGD one right now they need to score big
on each and every single board now let's
get an update top left board Arjun
versus with it with it in complete
control there he's the one who's got the
attack going we can see on Queen side
nothing has happened King side with it
has made massive progress Pawn on H4 is
going to land on H5 that night on D6
that's not a knight that's a stallion
right there this is completely in
control for white meanwhile the top left
the top right board are the band versus
nehal and that looks pretty level to me
absolutely I think it's quite level over
there which is I mean it is a result
that you know you're okay we like oh
yeah you can see that happening if they
draw the game with level position you
can see that happening I actually
thought it would be more aggressive
myself here too but I mean level hey you
know they're very strong players here
and they do have a position where both
sides have chances it's quite equal to
say the least so
James crazy stuff going on all around
bottom left as well quite an interesting
position where do you want to jump to do
you want to go to arjun's board where
Charlie's board I'll let you take a pic
definitely want to go to uh Origins
board over here with it as because
because of uh the attack that white
seems to be making up here it looks
really good black does not have the
counter play this does not look like for
instance if you ask yourself oh you know
what kind of game is this is a dragon
Sicilian and you're like what just not a
dragon like how you know you would
really not think that this would be a
dragon Sicilian at all Bishop's not even
on G7 there's no Rook on C8 there's no
Queen side attack and but everything is
pointing towards white attacking you
have H5 you have taking you know you
have the open Rook file here
how do you this whole threat right here
is just devastating then bringing the
bishop back maybe play C3 bringing the
bishop to C2 aim on this side how are
you ever dislodging the Knight besides
sacrificing on it which I have a good
hold on it I think this is actually a
clear win for why practical chances it
is only plus two I say only because I
thought it it seems like it should be
more or white here but of course engine
always finds uh everything and just
always like yeah it's it's equal like
okay bro what are you talking about but
here definitely taking white in all
areas H5 is a is a huge threat
yeah every day of the week every week of
the year you want to be white in this
position it just looks like white is
really coming for the black king
meanwhile whites King absolutely safe
and now the point is that where are
Black's defenses I I'm struggling to
find it because I think at some point
black will have to push that F Pawn to
defend the H7 Bond you either want to go
F5 at some point because it's such a
committed move though I would hate to
make it with black James because it
means a long-term weakness on E6
fine go first off trip and never play F6
says fine gold secondly it's just a
rough move to make in a position like
this but it might have been forced as
you mentioned H7 is a huge weakness
especially after we're able to play H5
might even see a G5 there just I mean
it's gross move but it is the fact that
I just want to keep that file closed
ASAP on takes is definitely going to
help us maybe we just take on E6 very
possible let's just take on E6 in some
cases take take maybe he has Rick and
for you counter play so you got to be
precise here steel you gotta be precise
F6 is the only way to really try to
create something
this is really an interesting approach
by black very direct now the point is
that if white actually plays the move H5
because that's what I was really afraid
about at the start but now black has to
move F5 it's a great Intermezzo James
because it just keeps everything under
control and yes black is still worse but
at least for the time being I don't know
for how long though you've made sure
that the king side is closed Queen G3
you make one move and I'm just thinking
what's my next move here do I have to go
Bishop G7 give up G6 put my Pawn on 86
but again it feels like a kind of
position that's just delaying the
inevitable I can almost sack everything
almost luckily it doesn't work there but
I'm already thinking of sacrifices
bringing the other Rook over going for
me but it doesn't work I was gonna sack
twice but then he could take on G6 right
so what I was looking at here is just
showing quick little sign here Rook here
of course wow that's actually equal
crazy you can actually do this the
position is so good that that's how you
can actually sacrifice but I mean yeah
it's in King G7 and I thought Queen H3
didn't work I'm just curious what is
three thinking though happens
if that is equal you know what I mean
like there's no way black is going to be
able to defend this uh without some
decisive uh results do you think with it
in this position will play H5 I don't
know if you'll go that deep and have
those crazy lines but this is a big
moment does he go H5 or does he pick up
the pawn on E6 I think picking up the
pawn on F6 I just want to point out
might be a mistake here H5 on the board
just as I was pointing out we're just
going for the win here H5 and we live
yeah I think it's the right choice
because you need to I think you need to
keep this closed this Rook F4 idea is
like real it's a real idea so you know
if if you let them take I'm at least
going to be able to open up shop if I
didn't play this move then you take on
E5 and then obviously E5 is weak and now
but now the files close forever so I
never have to deal with any Rook F4
ideas Queen G3 now on the board and we
might actually see a G5 because you
can't you can't allow this man to open
this file might as well hit the button
that's the resign button that is you
know just G5 just do it like you can't
exactly you can't let him open the phone
so he had to take it takes takes and now
we have this position if Bishop G5 I
have Bishops crazy tactics if you offer
a queen trade Queen G5 Queen G5 Bishop
G5
I was hoping I was hoping for Knight F7
but it doesn't work unfortunately
because the bishop on G5 just
let's show it very nice Knight F7 it
almost Works chat but the problem is
Rook is defended I mean it was so close
to working but these are the type of
tactics that are almost available here
after fg5 so okay Queen G5 does happen
but you lose e-6 Bond and I think that's
not just a pawn you're kind of your
whole position collapses and F4 is
desperation by black that is not bravery
it is just a very desperate position F4
played it had to be played you can't
trade Queens on G5 white would have
picked up the E6 pawn and I think now
you just go Queen G4
and you're still trying to win that E6
Pawn absolutely we just take on E6 here
I mean this is the worst Dragon you
would ever want and it was a night it
looks good dragon is very sharp you want
to play for a win absolutely that dragon
is one of those openings to go for here
but he never got the dragon type chances
he didn't even get the Rook open on the
C file when you actually do use that he
also played a strange idea I've never
seen before with Queen E8 we kind of
just got in trouble here this is
definitely all in uh vidit's favor here
and you know if the other games aren't
going well I mean this could be over
right here all it is is one point but
yeah
if whether wins this it doesn't even
matter what happens on the other boards
that's exactly yogis take this match and
that would be a crushing Victory and it
looks like they're on the brink of it
Arjun trying to create some Dynamics
trying to create play but James it just
feels as if Arjun never got going today
yeah absolutely you know what you're
right in fact it felt like Arjun I know
like at least we know how strong origin
is in fact I was in a Kazakhstan with
the world championship but I was also
there for Sadi zuldes where he played in
and he actually had nine and a half out
of 11. something ridiculous he crushed
it every game it's like Arjun what are
you eating like we eating the same
breakfast but yours is just different
from mine because he he plans some
excellent chess but then you know today
this is not the origin that we usually
are used to seeing and it's tough for
him as the team will suffer because of
that too as well so as we see this is on
a brink of defeat and it looks like uh
it may take this and the yogis will get
third place
you could just slide with the Rook to D1
hitting that queen queen can't lose
connection with that Bishop on G5 so
Queen E7 feels like the only option on
the board and white could maybe just go
E6 there everything under control the
pawn on G2 looks scary but it's
definitely not getting any more further
meanwhile after E6 I'm struggling to
find a move for black you can't you
can't leave that Bishop you can't get
that Bishop from G5 anywhere because
Queen G8 will be made and uh Rook D1 is
on the board James I won't be surprised
if Arjun I don't think Ashley he will
resign because that just doesn't help at
all he's gonna play this out till the
end he's gonna play it out he's
definitely gonna play
here I mean it's for the team we know
it's one point he knows look man I just
don't want to lose this game anything
can happen it's the last game here so
let's just see what happens he does by
Queen see it Queen g eight King eight
six is that is that a store Quincy at
Queen G8 and Rook D6
well the problem is uh there's a queen
here at the end there's a queen here oh
that's nice James let's just show that
let's just show that really quickly
because that's a great resource and this
would be over Queen G8 yeah and maybe
there's something better but Rook D6
would actually be a blunder because you
take a G1 Queen and it's black who's now
winning because you have an extra piece
that's very possible like in Heavenly
apps definitely happen you don't want
that to happen Nvidia is actually under
a minute as well so he needs to move
faster
James you gotta relax my guy don't be
hey man we got kids watching this stuff
that's a good move takes you take on G5
you take on G5 don't give a check on C8
because then the queen Retreat the
bishop retreats to eat it so everything
under control after Queen F7 Queen C8 is
not made because there is Bishop here in
The Possession but you take on G5 and
there is a piece landing on d8 after
Queen F7 Queen G5 would be game over
meanwhile if you take Bishop 86 there's
a mate on G on G8 and of course the big
threat of 86 Queen C8 is Checkmate in
one
and that would be game over we do have
our first result coming in it is in
favor of mgd1 diptyan gosh has done it
for his team but it is too little and
perhaps too late because it looks like
this board will decide the match 8-6 a
really nice move thereby with it we see
what's happening all around here Savita
SRI against pranesh upper peace down a
million pawns look at that pawn chain
it's super unclear James I would want to
be black here and the moment I say
there's a mistake on the board I mean
even nihal as well nihal's game is just
absolutely crashing over there you got
pigs on the sevens is what they call it
two Rooks are on the seventh rank up
there I mean just white is absolutely
for Choice as you just have the two
works up there you can move maneuver
your pieces around everything looks
really good for nihal's position as well
so let's say Vivid somehow blunder is
made in one well it looks like Miha is
going to be able to take it home for the
yogis
this position it says it's level bottom
right board but anything can happen
Bishop B3 check is coming in Rook B7
Rook B7 would be game over Rook B7 on
that bottom right board is a massive
threat you're threatening checkmates all
along the seventh rank so Savita SRI
actually might take that with the top
half of our screen both the boards it
looks like big trouble here James I
don't even see how white is black is
fighting because you can't go Rook F7
Rook F7 runs into Bishop B3 game over if
not recap seven Rook p7 is Unstoppable
if you make a move like Queen F2
then you go Queen E6 Queen E5 Bishop B3
I think that's game over James can we
just see that oh Queen F2 hitting mate
like ah you get made it first oh
actually no pretty successful oh he runs
away the H6 that's probably the problem
Oh you stop it this should be three uh
oh they should be three right and then
King here and then not clear
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
happens on this board because with it
Gujarati after a great game with the
white pieces has actually won that
position Arjun aragassi resigned Neha
Serene crushes adiban with the white
pieces and that is a heartbreaking
moment for mgd1 because the Indian yogis
finish third in the Pro chess League
they win it by a big margin and what a
crushing Victory it's been a last game
remains savitasuri playing on seconds a
winning position can this be the silver
lining the hope to go back with for MGD
one oh yeah you actually feel good with
this game you're like hey you know we
the team lost but hey I beat Prince
rightly like I'll be pronounced you know
like that's how you feel you feel good
yeah I feel great absolutely I beat
Pradesh or at least she's on the verge
of doing it she just has to finish it
out now but she also has
5.3 seconds so this is very easy to mess
this up but black needs to be you know
accurate right now it's only a plus
three Advantage Believe It or Not plus
three is like still a piece which she is
up remember this is a game where black
took literally all the pawns like I mean
look at this Pawn chain you never get
this and then if we get this Pawn down
here I mean like you should get like an
award for this in chess or like some
type of just something happens good in
your life if you ever get a pawn chain
like that but here uh yeah the yogis are
third place so if you had the yogis and
actually I was correct too so like what
do I get a house I did but at my house
so I said the Indian team was going to
win today so you know yogis are winning
and so what happens hopefully I get
something for that chat what do you
think
wow this is uh Savita sri's moment can
she convert this one we're not really
sure what is going on here because after
Queen F2 we did see the big Advantage
but James with the back rank weakness
Black's King is weak the black pawn
pawns are advancing we do have some
moves coming in at super fast space wow
and there's been a complete turnaround
and that's how dangerous this position
was
there's two Queens on the board yes it's
over yeah she just she blundered in time
trouble
blundered in time oh my gosh yeah we had
three queens at some moment some super
fast moves being played savitas redone
on three seconds on the clock but this
will end badly and James with it
Gujarati nihal Serene nehal it's got
three and a half out of four today with
it with three out of four today what a
performance by the yogis and their board
four does it as well the Indian yogis
take it with ten and a half to five and
a half against team MGD one and
absolutely crushing Victory there
yeah this is a very strong team both
teams are absolute beasts I mean you got
origin on the other team and adiba are
you kidding me right you know and then
your board four still 2400 right so
these are very strong teams of course
both of them being Indian teams here I
mean you that's all you would get is
strong chess and today the Indian yogis
were able to clinch the third place spot
here in an extra 5K open workplace spot
and the bragging rights as well so shout
out to kudos to Indian yogis here nihal
siren three and a half
[Music]
and this has been a great day for the
yogis they win fifteen thousand dollars
and all the bragging rights of being the
strongest team from India in this
protest League one of their star players
where Charlie has been great all season
so far they have been led by India
number three Indian you uh visit
Gujarati for the yogis and of course
nehal with some great performances in
the quarterfinals as well as today in
the fight for the third place he has
scored a phenomenal three and a half out
of four and James this boy at 16 he's
been such an MVP for the Indian yogis
his story is one of great and
determination becoming a grand master at
16 years old it's just been a
phenomenally inspiring player beating so
many Grand Masters it's been amazing to
watch absolutely it's been amazing to
watch I mean even the strong game he had
against Arjun in the first round that
set the tone he's like yeah origin I
know you strong but hey today right now
for the team I'm a little stronger and
it actually shows Darren Arjun was not
able to string up the wins as he usually
does here which really cost the team
here at the end of the day of course
they're still walking home with some
money fourth place is still some cash
there but a third place the yogi shout
out to them 15 000 richer for the team
awesome job from them great performance
all the way through the PCM
big congratulations to the Indian yogis
and for mgd1 I think it was also very
difficult to come back from that big
loss yesterday that was a crushing
defeat and today as well has been a
difficult day and Indian yogis do shine
and the chess keeps on Shining James as
the championship action is about to
start with the Shanghai Tigers taking on
the Gotham Knights on the top boards
that will be veggie Nakamura James
you're sticking with your Hikaru
prediction supporting Gotham Knights
there Chad I got one question are you
ready for the finals the finals is up
right after this chat I'm gonna need
y'all to Get Hype okay I'm gonna need
you to tell your mother hey Mom happy
Mother's Day I love you but I gotta
watch this right here have her watch it
too she will not even play chess she may
play chess better than you whatever the
case is ever watch it too as well
because you shouldn't go anywhere with
this final coming up next oh my goodness
it's the final of the PCL come on now
Tanya right yeah it's been an amazing
five weeks of the regular season and an
incredible playoff this week that we've
seen and these two teams James they've
definitely been the big performers
Gotham Knights have been Unstoppable
from the start Shanghai tigers have been
having their ups and downs but overall
like you said we saw the best game of
the season Yesterday by Julie we saw Wei
being absolutely amazing with his
attacks and you went in the three times
world champion as well Gotham Knights is
a power pack team but Shanghai Tigers
will come out with their fangs out as a
day it is the championship match Robert
and Danny will be taking you through all
the action coming up next it's the
finals chat with the Gotham Knights and
the Tigers the big question who will
claim the top prize they are fighting
for a big chunk of that 100K 25
000 for the winner
James it's been amazing doing this with
you this was a lot of fun and just
before we wrap up any final thoughts
yeah of course our final thoughts here
is I think I have Knights winning at all
but of course I'm gonna be watching very
closely I'm gonna be watching everything
and ready and hype and standing up in my
chair when I see ah craziness going on
I'm gonna just be super hyped because
you should be it's the PCOS the last
time Italian this was great hanging with
you I'll see you next week at the CCT
championships tour so you know more
commentary with us that's gonna be nice
if you guys are watching that and follow
follow here at the channel if you
haven't followed already so you guys can
get all notifications for when we have
obviously the events fire
don't go anywhere
but now we leave you no it decides and
the sounds from our third place match
goodbye everyone
originator guy C down a whole Rook here
for no compensation this is a disaster
for Arjun vaishali creating some ideas
tricky tricky queen of six
five oh he said go ahead I got some
tricks of my sleeve as well yeah and
it's crazy I I have to say you said that
you like these positions for a black but
I wow I think about to get crushed I'm
not even gonna lie this might be over
this is 17 moves this might be over in
another three to four moves here okay
Rook Cafe and I just moved the roof oh
what you take here okay I take care on
E6 oh wait she just blundered a queen
you don't ever expect to see that I was
just against a pre-move king B2 sure oh
my goodness what are they doing wake up
wake up this should be a draw let's say
should be yes because anything can
happen on second you know what I mean I
don't know is she just marching down the
board with the King F6 oh my goodness oh
gosh is the evil bar right now visit
Gujarati after a great game with the
white pieces has actually won that
position and that is a heartbreaking
moment for mgd1 because the Indian yogis
finish third in the Pro chess League
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this year saw the return of the protest
league and thank goodness chat so good
to have you back PCL this is nice
let's go with the postseason upon us the
stakes are only getting higher which
teams from around the world can survive
to claim the next PCO championship and
also bite off a Lion's Share of the
fresh one hundred thousand dollars up
for grads
the finals of the protest League
playoffs have finally arrived Queen to
Chief all
oh my God
I'm Out Boy the PCL is here to stay who
will be crowned its next champion
to one and a half
welcome to the pro chess League finals
it's Championship Sunday happy Mother's
Day to one and all alongside Grand
Master Robert Hess International Master
Danny wrench and boy are we pumped for
Tigers versus Knights Robert
oh we couldn't be more excited it's the
mother of all matchups these two teams
are definitely deserving of their spot
in the finals and Danny you know we like
to make predictions we like to put our
guessing caps on I have no idea who the
favorite is
I totally agree we're going to dive into
all of that do our best to set the table
but before we do we give a
congratulations to the third place
finishing team the consolation match
just wrapped up and is the Indian yogis
who beat the other team from India mgd1
in this awesome match and so the yogis
take the third place prize here in the
2023 Pro chess League although we have
the Tigers versus Knights above them
getting set to throw down in the finals
match Robert that's the one that we're
going to be talking about but again
congratulations to the yogis really
congratulations to all eight teams who
made the playoffs because it comes down
to these two teams who we got to talk
about starting now Robert
yeah it's a really tough season then
even tougher playoffs when the field
Narrows down so congratulations are in
order to the Indian yogis I know they
put didn't Gujarati back in the lineup
and he did not disappoint so congrats to
them and unfortunately for mgd1 Danny it
was a promising start to the season but
the end of it may leave a bit of a
bitter taste in their mouth
yeah well they they'll have a chance
next year I guess but before we before
we talk about next year let's actually
run things back in time we talked about
how we're going to set the table give
you all the different story lines to
chew on fans and chat make all the all
the predictions you could possibly make
on March 2nd these two teams met Robert
the knights and the Tigers and boy was
it a big win for the knights again like
yesterday they won without even needing
a fourth round your thoughts though on a
different lineup for the knights coming
in today and what the Tigers might need
to do to change their fate
well they say if it ain't broke don't
fix it but for the Gotham Knights that's
hard because all their lineups are
working for them they've won every
single match they played in so they will
not try out the same lineup as they did
when they defeated the Shanghai Tigers
but the Shanghai Tigers they have been
consistent in their lineups and I don't
think it's a mistake because that was an
off week for them it felt kind of wrong
that that final score happened but they
were obliterated it was Demolition and I
think we will not see the same score
line today
we should definitely highlight that the
tigers are the only team well they're
one of the only two teams left standing
but they're the only team who's played
the exact same lineup in every single
protest League match for the entire year
and it is that lineup that we will see
again today on that note let's go ahead
and bring up our lineups take a look at
the board assignments who is being
trotted out well we've already said it
it's the same players for both the
knights and the tigers that have played
this entire playoffs Robert how will
that fare heading into this final match
we have some great lineups from both
sides now I think we should talk about
the rating differentials look at board
four alua normanova she has had some
good results but she's much lower rated
than her opponent low yipping and then
at the top hikara Nakamura slight
favorite against Wei but then I'm
looking at phariseev that's where he has
the big rating Gap compared to Joo and
June on board two she is over performed
for the Shanghai Tigers Danny but we
know that sometimes those top GMS they
have no mercy
well and coming back to the board
assignment discussion though because
Norma Novo was also greatly underrated
yesterday if she ever got to facing
harika drone of Ali guess what never
happened she never even had to play
Toronto Valley right so here we're
highlighting a rating difference between
a Lua numer Nova and the fourth board
for the Tigers but will it even matter
at this point knowing that they already
beat the Tigers 93 again I'm with you I
don't expect to see that today I expect
to see an absolute barn burner a
thriller I wouldn't be surprised if we
get tie breaks but uh it is interesting
to see the rating discrepancy on board
four and then of course as you
highlighted as well Federal say of being
the favorite over human June which one
of those will uh will maybe play into a
bigger Factor at the end of today
a difficult question to answer but I
think for the Shanghai Tigers they know
what's needed them they need to beat up
on normanova I'm sorry to say that when
you see someone who's as strong as she
is she just is lower rated than the
opponent so they know that they have to
strike we may see some crazy games
involving her because when you need to
win you're playing for a result for move
one you tend to play some kind of
offbeat wacky openings yeah all right
well let's let's dive into the specific
lineups and how they will be paired of
course anyone who follows the protest
League knows this drill at this point we
start off with board fours versus Board
ones or board ones versus Board fours
depending on what you want to list first
I got I got that third match up those
circles given how the kid off has
arguably been the MVP for the knights in
the PCO postseason that matchup versus
women's world championship in June
Robert I think that's going to be a big
one to start things off yeah that is a
great matchup indeed and I like to focus
on the or two versus Board three
matchups just because board one versus
Board four tends to be a bit more
lopsided but Shu Yi speaking of MVPs he
played maybe the game of the year
yesterday in the semi-final so watch out
his rating mate only and I'm putting
that in air quotes people can't see it
2502 but Federal Sav has to be careful
because he's been a man on a mission has
been shuyi
yeah if you missed that game yesterday
do yourself a favor and find it anywhere
it exists uh five brilliances were
played in a game according to
chest.com's game review by that guy
right there and that was running at
depth 24. the game ended with a queen
sacrifice that uh anyone would would
take home to their mother speaking of
Mother's Day so how is that guy going to
fare today he's sitting right where he
was shuyi as you said and he has a he
has a big matchup to start things off
for the Tigers coming back to the uh to
the nights though Robert we've got this
guy fedo say of the big fish also right
where we've seen him for the last four
days been helping to lead lead the
knights to where they are how do you
think he's feeling going up against Zhu
and June here to start things
well Federal save is a fan favorites
that's the good news is that the fans
love him but he also loves online chess
and he thrives and I think he thrives
even more in the team environment but so
does Juan June we know she's the Women's
World Champion she has so many successes
to her name but she's been a star for
the Shanghai Tigers it's not just weigi
it is super GM rating at the top she has
performed very admirably over performed
her rating by a substantial margin so I
think that he needs to be careful
because well she is a very tough
opponent I actually think that one is a
close call
you know to highlight that by the way I
highlighted that matchup because they
are both board twos of course the kid
off plays juben June first just to make
sure I clarify that for the fans let's
also clarify what's at stake for
everyone you know we're here to
determine approaches League champion and
the better part of the 100 000 prize
fund of course but we're also here to
determine an MB pre an MVP prize excuse
me at the end of the day Robert Hess
among others will be helping to decide
that Robert are you excited for uh for
not just who's gonna win but who might
be taking the MVP prize by the end of
the day
course I'm excited to help award the
mvpcl award you know it's gonna be uh
fun trying to pick through the names
there's so many worthy candidates and
well if the first place team with 25 000
but this man right here he wants to win
that first place team prize and the MVP
yeah well of course the uh the team
prize first and foremost and I expect
everyone to continue to do what they've
done to help get their team here which
is make good team decisions hey Carla
for example on Thursday when he was
struggling made sure that he held his
ground got four draws to help the
knights move on when he didn't have his
best chess and then yesterday showed up
in vintage Hikaru Nakamura Forum going
two and a half out of three and helping
his team not even need a fourth round so
will it be Hikaru will it be the kid off
if the Knights win who would it be for
the Tigers if they ultimately won the
processity championship if someone there
took the MVP prize a lot a lot to
discuss and it should be fun first to
see how that plays out so
hey Karu yakking away right now already
live on on stream of course given his uh
commentary here we've got the man Wei Yi
also playing some impressive chess in
this PCO postseason all along in the PCL
really all year long yeah he has had a
fantastic season where he has been an
absolute star for them a very stable
rock at the top board he's 18 out of a
possible 23 points I mean that is
incredible and he was a super Jam at a
very young age and he has been kind of a
veteran at this point despite the fact
he's only 23 years old so Wei he knows
how to lead a team he's been a part of
the Chinese Squad that have won some
major events including the Olympiad so
yeah you can trust that guy
it's amazing because we we've seen the
Hikaru pedigree image a few times where
he had a 10-1 record but way Yi playing
every single match for the Tigers
getting 18 out of 23 possible points
Robert that is a that is a stat right
there that says he might be the MVP of
course if the Tigers were to win uh but
okay right now the uh the table has been
set we know what's at stake everyone is
excited thanks for spending your Sunday
with us no matter where you are in the
part of the globe this is a very very
Global Affair when it comes to the pro
chess league and we are about to see the
first moves made in our championship
match
and here we go and I want to point out
Danny that I think everyone looks at
this matchup things Hikaru Nakamura a
huge favorite no matter who he faces on
the Tigers Louisa paying us 2500 that is
one of the strongest board fours in the
entire league and let's not forget that
on Thursday Hikaru Drew all four of his
games including against Alice Lee and so
look at this quiet start thus far is he
on the iPad again that's my big question
for Louis
for those who he doesn't look like he's
on an iPad he looks like he's on a mouse
for those who don't know it was a wild
start to yesterday's matchup it's fun
it's fun now it was stressful at the
time for everybody but uh Lo yipping had
had some trouble logging in ultimately
had to switch to an iPad and but it
didn't stop the Tigers from moving on
and here he seems a little calmer I like
that that right hand on the mouse there
Robert
get some water it seems so he's trying
to well that's a very large jug of water
there he he tends to do that he tends to
switch moves and switch water glass I
mean who am I to judge we've seen me
drink it directly out of a water gallon
on more shows than we'd like to talk
about so so I won't judge a Carter but
all right let's judge the position we've
got a a Queen's Gambit Queen's Gambit
accepted sort of a tame variation here
being played with E3 on the board
and black typically wants to strike at
some point with C5 but Danny I think I
get what white is doing here he's just
telling you the most solid variation
ever is Black's decision to take on C4
but instead of playing E4 and getting
into the Vienna game he plays E3 let's
just keep our Pawn chain nice and
compact here let's take this pawn and C4
on the next turn I feel like he just
wants to make a drug that is match
strategy
it's not a bad idea to make a draw
against the coronakamura uh for really
for almost anybody in the world um but
here as you said E3 the much more
patient approach we can get an isolated
Queen Pawn position depending on how
black she uses to play it often C5 comes
as Robert's highlighting and then C
takes D4 will be on the board but an iqp
position while solid for white doesn't
doesn't mean that black is out of danger
necessarily you know there can be a lot
of tactics in those middle games so
it'll be interesting to see how Hikaru
wants to approach this something more
subtle Bishop E7 castles B6 or does he
want to strike immediately with C5 or
even an A6 B5 kind of Moran idea Danny
I'm looking at the bars of connection
and there are none for hikar right now
so uh that is my biggest concern I see
him talking I don't know if he's talking
to himself but I don't see him connected
because he doesn't spend this kind of
time I move five in the opening
I was just gonna say Hikaru uh speaking
of iPad connection issues that we know
Lo Yi ping had yesterday for the Tigers
Hikaru is remote right now just anyone
who knows hikara well knows that uh that
is not his normal streaming setup uh we
know that he's uh he's a Globetrotter
right now preparing to play and not just
the next Champions chess Tour event but
also the Norway chess event coming up in
stavengar Norway so uh so yes calling
what it is Hikaru is clearly on the road
not so sure about his connection we'll
see if that ends up being a huge
storyline of the day you don't want it
to be but you worry about the knights if
that's the case but you know the good
thing about Hikaru and the fact that he
plays all the time is unlike others who
thinks oh my opponent's just spending a
long time what are they considering the
E3 E4 he probably is aware that he's
having some difficulties but he needs to
connect he needs to get back on
he's going to have to figure out
something here to fix his connection
we uh
well he is aware it seems he's aware
he's trying to oh now he's played A6 so
there you go he is reconnected and just
like that it was a Moran idea as
discussed
before we move on back to the chess
highlight a little bit about the ideas
of this a6b5 robber because it will
allow Bishop B7 and C5 it's an
aggressive way for black to play in this
system
yeah it is because when black gets the
bishop fee encountered to B7 you control
the E4 square and look at how quickly
hit car would play C5 if you take we can
see a queen trade on D1 and then white
will have to take with a piece you don't
really want to do that unless it's a
rook and that is why White Castles first
you're not afraid of Pawn takes D4 that
doesn't scare you one bit but quickly
hikara will play Bishop B7 get this
bishop out here castle and compete for
the seed file and there's Pawn on B5
it's a double-edged sword either it's
great because at some point you put B4
and kick this Knight out here or it's
bad because A4 can chisel at these pawns
on the queen side so it's a game of give
and take
yeah indeed and we see Hikaru kind of
recognizing that he's lost a couple
minutes on the clock while he speeds up
lo you ping by the way not phased by any
of this he's like I don't really care if
my opponent's got bad connection issues
guess who had those and survived them
yesterday this guy so he's like you know
this is part of the game and of course
we do we do always encourage the players
to have a stable connection because
there's only so much we can control when
it comes to this type of remote major
chess event uh if we want to back out
and let let uh Lo Yi ping and Hikaru
figure out their middle game let's take
a look at the bird's eye view for the
first time three of the four games are
officially underway receive a keyed off
in June June I highlighted that match up
to me Robert as as a very big one to
start things off and they are blitzing
away
wow yeah they really are vokito has been
a hero for the Gotham Knights he scored
three out of four in the quarterfinals
then three out of three in the
semi-finals and he has been on a tear
thus far I'm looking at the top right
and bottom right just very early stages
but Danny I just want to point out in
the bottom right look what way he has
done he has played a modern defense with
the black pieces he is trying to play
for win no forcing variations for white
yeah I like that a lot flexibility often
King if you feel like you're better than
your opponent give yourself an
opportunity to outplay them so the
modern is a system that and look at this
B5 the re the aggressive modern here
Bishop B7 coming and this is an
interesting one because white will have
an edge right let's not pretend that a
Lua normanova won't have a better middle
game the center counts but if you're the
stronger player you often just want
opportunities for the position to get
weird and funky and outplay your
opponent so I I like it from a practical
perspective by way Yi why don't we head
over to vaquita for zoo in June and uh
dive into that one a little more closely
if we can
um you know we talk about how at the end
of the day Robert you will have the
result as it stands will decide who wins
obviously but these early realm matchups
sometimes you forget about them right
because it comes down to whatever drama
you have on screen time scrambles but I
really feel like whoever gets the better
of this one is going to set their team
on the right trajectory yeah we tend to
see a match be six to six or six and a
half five and a half going into the
fourth and Final Round And we think oh
that's the storyline but that happens
early right you set the tone and
yesterday there was no tone in the
matchup between the Gotham Knights and
MGD one the match was over after two
games were played from each player so in
this game we see volcano with the white
pieces this Pawn structure looks a
little bit compromised I think that
people tend to hate on double pawns when
they shouldn't necessarily do so these
pawns do occupy important squares
controlling the center here and they're
hard to get to D6 protects E5 of course
now Knight takes B6 and queen takes E6
to follow is the threat and you can't
even play Queen D7 because you drop a
Pawn on B6 so you might have to play
Rook E8 but Danny that's not what you
want to do because if white gets F4 and
opens up the f file you want to have a
rook there competing for it
I like what you highlighted about the
double puns I often like to say they're
doubled but doing it right those pawns
are doubled but they're doing it they're
helping the position uh when you talked
about the lack of tone in the match I
thought you were going over the lack of
tone on the on camera for rickidov and
by the way he's worn the same shirt for
all three matchups I think it's his
lucky shirt either he's got multiple
Gotham Knights swag or he doesn't want
to change out of this lucky shirt given
how things have been going you ever done
I think that I think that Levy can
afford to send you know a bunch of merch
to the team so we've got them Knights
are named after Gotham chess we should
give Levy the shout out and of course
Alex ostrovsky as their manager have
been choosing the lineup's been
coordinating with the team just getting
the team in the first place so they're a
great Squad and I do not wear the same
shirt over and over to answer your
question Dan I was gonna say let's let's
give him the benefit of the doubt that
he has multiple shirts like opens his
closet like Batman and it's just the
same shirt
um or or he's washing the laundry but
you never know you never know all right
Sometimes some players are more
superstitious than others all right back
to the chess we've got this queen coming
to C7 as you pointed out you have to
keep an eye on that B6 Bishop if you're
Jew in June this bishop on G5 has the
option to take F6 and fully open the
king talk about the dynamic there and
whether or not that's even a good idea
to give black the g-file you said open
The King and I wasn't sure whose King
you were talking about because black
king is the one that initially looks
open but when the king scoots on over to
h8 and a rook comes to G8 maybe it's
White's King that could eventually be in
some danger I don't see the white king
uh falling victim to some kind of attack
so I do think you can take on F6 but I'm
not sure you want to because you fortify
black center and then D5 becomes more
attractive because now the pawn on F6
protects the pawn E5 so it's a very
difficult question and at this stage
it's not about the eval bar off to the
side they don't know the evaluation in
King H1 very natural move guess what
Here Comes F4 and you may regret the
fact that Rook is not on f8
yeah it's really strange if you could
just play hopscotch and bring that Rook
from A8 to f8 you'd actually feel very
good about Black's position but that's
that's not how chess is played
um and uh and it actually makes it
really awkward I like this move King H1
with F4 coming whether you take F6 or
not this is this is uh gonna remain
tricky still a lot left to go a lot of
months from a from a subscriber there
shout out to you bjh staff member
working hard we love you man thank you
for that subscription and for the
support long before you were with
chess.com let's back up to the bird's
eye view
let's take a look at all four games that
are officially underway
the game we were waiting for between Shu
Yi and Vladimir fedosev that one's
rolling you've got Wei Yi and alua
normanova I mean all all of these games
are interesting Robert I mean find a
boring one yeah board one also looks
very interesting between loyiping and
Hikaru the position is opening up but I
want to note in the top right between
shui and Ferris have sacrificed the
piece white has four minor pieces black
has three but he's winning it back so I
think we should dive in there a little
bit just to see how that happened I
think the instant replay can be valuable
for people because as it stands white is
up an entire night in the center but
black is winning that night right back
so I think
he did a clever thing here just to show
whatever happened this Knight tickle
Pawn on E5 he went Queen E7 trying to
barrel down the e-file because there's a
pin on the Knight on C3 so we saw the
move Queen D3 and he took on D4 so after
Queen took on D4 he found Bishop C5 and
the queen had to move back to D3 which
means black takes this Knight on E5 so
it's even material Denny but the EVAP
bar is actually quite high in White's
favor do you think it's because the four
on three majority on the key side is
helpful and maybe there's a pawn push I
was just gonna say that you know I play
a scotch you know I play a scotch and
sometimes I put my queen on H1 we don't
talk about that though we don't talk
about Bruno I knew you're gonna say it I
said it before you could say it okay but
uh yeah if if white gets castled frankly
in this position both castles are on the
or on the table but regardless once
White's King is out of the center this
move F4 often followed by E5 to follow
as we say with E5 there's no Knight on
F6 look out for tactics this is a
position where black really wants to get
something on the e-file quickly
obviously pressure with the Rook or even
a move like D5 would be would be very
helpful if you could somehow make that
work before white gets the king out of
the center so
um
I'm I'm with the eval bar here I'm I'm
on team team white here with the idea
that the majority is coming and look at
this how many times this bishop moved
went from B4 back to C5 back to B4 now
he's just going back and forth but we
see his plan the Knight is protecting E4
you mentioned pressured on the E file
there's also Pawn D5 push I'm wondering
oh wow what a move Bishop D2 because if
captures captures you can take on e4
it's a lot of takes take take I'll show
it very quickly on the board he castled
but the point was that the bishop would
have grabbed the G7 Pawn when the Knight
cleared the diagonal so instead of we
see a castle and I think white can do
the same but E4 is a bit loose Danny
you did your best to carve impersonation
their takes takes takes takes and uh but
at the end white would have been better
and had the bishop pair this is a tricky
position because having played some of
these for white
F3 is like this warm and cozy move you
think but the moment you commit to that
often often it's not the right idea and
black will black will find a way to
punch D5 through so you're really
looking for tactical solutions to your
problem even aggressive moves like F4 or
castles long you'd it just to paint the
picture Robert even if Bishop takes C3
Bishop C3 Queen E4 happened there may be
something concrete but even if you just
move the queen and keep the bishop on
that diagonal with the pressure against
the king that's more along the lines of
what white wants here than something
like F3 and that's exactly what shui is
doing and I like that she hasn't played
F4 well that's the aggressive approach
we're talking about before now that
leaves the E4 Bond permanently
vulnerable upon's best friend is another
Pawn so F3 at some moment could create a
solid Pawn structure we could see him
playing A3 to chase the bishop and I
wouldn't be surprised Danny if the C7
Pawn becomes a weakness the queen C4
idea is something like that in the
future or even a knight B5 hopping
around to go up to the pond
and note now white can play of three
because there is no D5 that King got out
of the center everyone so as Robert
pointed out the solid supporting move
also here comes G4 maybe G5 watch out
English attacking style even if it's not
a sicilian I like juji's chances here
this this is the guy who turned
everyone's head yesterday with one of
the most brilliant chess games I've ever
seen actually not just in the protest
like just an absolute amazing game so
this guy this guy is feeling the flow
right now
um and and definitely feeling that that
bed set behind him you got to begin the
style to pick a bed set like that hey
and he plays G4 I think we're into that
as well nice play so far I'm sure he's
not afraid of anybody he's on a roll but
maybe we should roll to our bird's eye
view Danny because I think that some of
the other games are are also deserving
our attention I see in the top left in
Loya paying against the car knock more
there's a knight on A7 that's not
something you see every day so uh which
game should we go to
let's head back over there it is the top
board
um and and and the one of the biggest
stars in the world of course in Hikaru
Nakamura so fans often like that we keep
that one close I say we head back over
there see how that Knight got to A7
quickly the the material is equal
I just double check that I feel like
I've joined a few games now and not seen
a peace sacrifice I just want to make
sure material is equal
um I'm not sure who I'd like in this
position yeah just because the material
is balanced I think you're making this
point that doesn't mean the game is
going to end in a draw I already see
this Knight on C5 making contact with
this Pawn A4 which means if we get some
real trades that could be bad for white
and look at Black's Rooks perfectly
situated on the open file I'm worried
about this A4 Pawn Rook C1 would already
be a blunder thank you very much not for
the A3 square but for the A4 Pawn so
what move does white make here do Rook
trades help but yet need to move the
Knight where does the Knight go to a bad
Square A4 will again be loose so I am a
little bit nervous for Loya ping and he
already blundered
whoa king of two the eval bar doesn't
like it is it is it something to do with
E5 oh Knight has to move it's got to be
right oh yeah I'm looking at tactics
here yeah and Hikaru doesn't need a lot
of time to find it he by the way is down
on time because of those two minutes he
lost earlier if you're just tuning in
Hikaru had connectivity issues the kind
they don't make a pill for but he seems
to have righted that ship oh my gosh
that is a fork on D3 he walked into it
that's the problem you move the Knight
everything's Squad trade everything and
there's oh so he covered A4 which is one
weakness but the D3 square and you know
who taught me this Yasser Sarah won I
was already a grand master at the time
uh we were on the same team at the world
team championship and Yasser was just
like talking about squares and massaging
the squares and it sounded ridiculous as
only Uncle Yaz can but it made perfect
sense and it's it actually stuck with me
he's like you want to massage your
control of certain squares and this
Knight on C5 not only hits the pawn but
they're B3 and D3 and now the King on F2
walked right into a fork so I just want
to show this to make it clear for
everybody that once the oop that's a
mouse set by me always still a good move
but all all the way we see the Rooks get
traded and at the end Knight D3 is check
to the king and to the bishop black wins
a piece black wins the game
exactly Robert that's how you massage
the square Robert you see you recognize
the square and then you massage think of
all the different ways you could massage
the square I think Yaz remembers the
first time his Square was massage you
know it's just uh
I think he better and probably everyone
else remembers the first time they heard
Yasser talking about the first time his
Square was massaged because that's the
kind of story Gasser will tell from time
to time okay thank you yes sir all right
E5 has been played King F2 did indeed
walk into that blunder we see Lo Yi ping
shaking his head unfortunately uh he is
likely just about to go down despite
that edge on the clock he was spotted
due to hikaru's connection issues and
here comes the Bob there it is
hikaranakamura head Bob number 11. he is
back at it let's back this thing back
out to the bird's eye view because
Hikaru sees that he's winning just like
the rest of us do
uh we haven't looked at Wei Yi versus
normanova I feel like we should circle
the wagons completely make sure we get
all eight of Our Stars on camera before
the first round wraps up it's also an
interesting position with Wei just now
starting to get a slight Edge on the
board Robert
yeah it's a really interesting position
it kind of reminds me of the game
between a car and low you ping in the
sense that a lot of plays happening in
the center and the queen side but this
Knight on G4 Queen on B6 are making
Target of the F2 Pawn but let's not
forget this bishop on G5 because it
looks like you win a pawn by distracting
the queen from the 92 that Bishop is
very very importantly defending this
Knight so you can't take everything on
the F2 Square so what does that mean
what do we go for if we are thinking
that this from Waze perspective how
could you actually increase your threats
how can you attack something the E4 Pawn
is ultra well defended from these
Knights so any how do you play for a win
at this point
yeah a great question because despite
the eval bar slipping a little bit in
Black's favor as it was I'm sitting here
looking for a candidate move and I don't
have many like name them name a move
that clearly improves your position I'm
literally asking for a friend Robert
You're a Grand Master what is the move
that a bruised like I mean is there a 98
maneuver to come to C7 or D6 to try to
get rid of the bishop that's a plan
um I mean not right now no no I I know I
know but that leads me to maybe Rook D4
that frees the Knight up to move and he
plays it and there's also 97 to get
after this bishop okay Bishop E3 this
pin doesn't work there's a knight
covering the E3 Square so good call by
you that this Rook move does help and
also puts more pressure on the E4 Pawn
it's sometimes by process of elimination
when you don't see a move you ask
yourself and this is good advice for
viewers is like what pieces could I
improve right so you're not you don't
even ask yourself the big existential
what's my five six seven move plan but
what piece could be on a better square
and this idea of moving the Knight to a
better Square kind of allowed us to
maybe play this idea of unpinning the
Knight on F6 with Rook D4 so anyway it's
still very interesting in nurmanova
holding her own by the way look at the
clock she's doing just fine there so
give her some credit here going up
against the board one for the Tigers I
think she's in big trouble though
because this Knight on G4 is menacing it
can't be kicked with F3 hello thank you
very much for a discover check and mate
just to put this on the board Rook D1 is
a double check that is mate because the
Knight covers H2 as well so don't be
pushing the F Pawn is the main point and
that is why the queen went to A7 not to
d8 if F3 would be played successfully
this Knight is banished to H6 and it's
not getting back in the game so keeping
the pressure up is the name of the game
here and speaking of pressure excuse me
that E4 Pawn is hanging
and it's hard because you'd like to move
the Knight maybe from C4 to E3 yourself
you know if you could get into the D5
Square maybe played Bishop C6 but the
moment you do that the E4 Pawn Falls so
likewise it's it's hard to find moves
for normanova here which is why the
advantage he had on the clock is uh has
dwindled away and that Rook D4 move
that's was all important because it gave
wayi some optionality that he didn't
previously have this Knight moving H7
looks worrisome where's that Bishop
going the Knight hopping around like you
said D7 C5 we saw how car was not on C5
did some serious damage and now the E4
Pawn is loose away in good position and
oh what was that Knight takes
four and Knight G4
OMGs or snaps
OMGs or snaps what a move and look how
quickly he played he had already spotted
that idea he was waiting for it and if
Bishop E3 you must just be giving up the
exchange right just bring the Knight
right back to G4 Queen dominates the
dark squares we're gonna see it on the
board here what a find by Wayde he's an
absolute Beast he just goes Knight takes
Pawn back to G4 and where's this King
going it's on the verge of being
checkmated so this Knight comes into G4
play King H2 oh my God it's painful yeah
there's Queens in the knights doing work
the best dynamic duo since Batman and
Robin whatever happened to Joseph
Gordon-Levitt in the robin storyline
that Christopher Nolan was planning the
seat on that didn't go anywhere okay
um I thought you're gonna go all the way
back to Batman and Robin in the 90s and
Robin we don't like to talk about George
Clooney let's back up we have a result
here where he gets the dub by the way
right on cue Hikaru Nakamura follows
suit so both board ones have achieved
victories for their respective teams
some time pressure starting to get on
the board between Zhu Yi and Vladimir
ferrosev if we'd like to head over there
okay well I think it's time travel for
one and unfortunately chess is a game
for two because we see that shuyi has 23
seconds while ferrosev has over three
minutes on the clock it's one person
playing Blitz the other playing bullet
and if I'm doing my math the right uh it
blacks up a pawn now so E4 was
successfully captured by ferrosev and
he's not paying any price his pieces are
all on great squares protecting the E4
Knight
it's so sad to me because it was a
scotch structure I loved it I was
rooting for white in this game just on
the moral principle that I play this
position often it seems to have slipped
away like many of my own games black is
in a great spot and that pawn majority
as uh on the king side has actually
disappeared it no longer exists black is
just up upon but I think fedo save is
doing the right thing right now because
he's thinking at some points Bishop
takes E4 a problem for me I do I want
opposite colored Bishops opposite color
Bishops if you're down material are
great for an end game because you're
more likely to hold but also good for
attacking chances so he does play Queen
F5 he lines his bishop and queen up can
you take on D6 and give up C2 I know
that looks scarier giving him a palm a
check but Danny the more pawns that get
traded I feel like the better white
chances are of surviving
it's fair and it also opens up the E5
Square for business so he does indeed go
for it I kind of like it because if you
put a piece on E5 maybe C5 is targeted
also the more pieces that come off the
board the better you're drawing chances
so fedo save says no thank you
we'll block that e-file in a hurry I
mean A6 is a pawn I know Ace Queen A6 is
met by B4 but there you go I like that
idea H5 H6 there we go let's get
ourselves some dark squares even though
B4 is coming for black no I like what
you said Queen takes A6 would backfire
because B4 rookie thank you very much
for opening up the a file that's the
thing is when people drop pawns they
think oh no I blunder and I think oh yes
an open file and that's what we're
looking at here so Rook E6 stabilization
look at these pieces for black all
undefended squares but what is Black's
plan because White's plan seems a bit
obvious
yeah okay that's a nice move what's
funny is how much the bishop dominates
the diagonals on e4 you have this move
Rook H1 you want to play but there's a
bishop okay Bishop B5 quickly found
baiju Yi what are you gonna do with that
guy on e4
I don't know it's interesting because if
you yeah go ahead
up on the A8 H1 diagonal now maybe F5 is
on the agenda right not right away but
you're looking for dangerous ways to
attack if you're white and if you go the
other way then Rook H1 so okay yeah he's
playing for F5 like you said Queen 6h4
Here Comes F5 and is this King actually
safe over here that's a big question and
at some point Bishop D6 could be an
issue for black as well
yeah this is forget what that eval Bar
says here everyone we are going to see a
swing in a moment here this is a very
tough position to play for both sides F5
F6 you might be down a couple pawns but
be losing on the dark squares if you're
not careful yeah and he plays Bishop D6
apparently that was a mistake I was
looking to make Queen D6 was actually
better hitting a bunch of pieces but
Rook date you see the eval bar going up
going down F6 is played yeah and after
G6 he gets he's so careful as black
Danny this bishop on C6 that's why I put
it there covers the E8 Square yep yep
man if if there was Bishop takes f8
rookie eight lines where you sacrifice
your queen what a what a fun thing that
could have been Queen H2 it's a piece
like three different ways
I mean The Rook is hanging the bishop is
hanging
you're a little too late you can't even
play Rook H1
because the bishop on C6 guards it so I
think that move was the time pressure
finally catching up with shuyi and fedo
say of the big fish gonna get a big dub
for the knights here in the first round
huge win for federal Sav and you can see
on shuyi's face he knew that he was
bluffing he was going for some kind of
attack that didn't exist and look at
this G6 you can just take that pawn your
king is perfectly shielded and at some
point Bishop D5 Queen E1 will lead a
Checkmate and White's King is the one
yeah I was gonna say that might be a fun
way that this thing comes to an end here
at Bishop D5 is played from federal save
we have threats of Queenie one okay he
wants to do the the safe thing and just
go gather that pawn for no more tactics
uh but he's gonna take this one by the
way I feel like we're having Deja Vu has
vaquita ever not been the last game
being played for the knights since we've
been covering them I mean the kid off
shoe in June is going to be the next
game we head over to uh after after we
uh we let Federal save kind of get the
job done here
um all right it's uh it's Rover
save takes that one home as we see he
gets the Queens off the board let's head
on over to vaquita off versus you in
June
it's an equal game on the eval bar
Robert but again vaquita has been here
before he tends to like being the uh the
last player standing in the biggest
moment yeah he's been here there
everywhere and right now this night if
as I'd say it's on the rim it's got to
get back and watch out because this is a
blunderable position for both sides like
black could bring the knight in try to
get E3 and there could be a Checkmate
against this King it sounds ridiculous
but this king is actually a bit In
Harm's Way and the other side of things
that there could be some tactics where
this Knight jumps to E6 at the right
moment and this black king finds itself
a little bit uncomfortable
whoa whoa I was gonna say what happens
in The Rook ending because the E4 Pawn
is weak it's kind of a riskless position
for vikidov and maybe that's why he went
for it uh but there is there are these
small chances because it is a game right
it's not just a science small chances
that white kind of Corrals that E4 Pawn
although we do expect to stand in a draw
E3 anybody just go for this I guess the
pawn go up to F3 F3 and you were just
trying to avoid things like that she's
saying okay if I do nothing the game
should be a draw but if I try something
a little bit too hard then I could it
could back up but now F3 E2 and The Rook
is misplaced so it's clear that that's
not gonna help uh White at all
okay so instead the check is made and
probably the capture follows and
suddenly if anybody can win it's black
even though again we will we will we
will have a draw here the question is
how long do they want to play it out
save their energy or try to Swindle
their opponent they choose the former
save their energy they decide smart
thing to do I would agree yeah no this
was a well-fought game to a drop but
Juan June deserves credit she held a
strong Grandmaster with black that's
called getting the job done
yep well let's take a look at where that
leaves us after the first set of games
the Gotham Knights have a two and a half
to one and a half lead Robert any
surprises there
well I think the federal save game that
really told the story of the round that
he beats chuyi he gets the job done with
the black pieces and I think that it's
still close of course just a one point
spread but I have to say that impressive
stuff from federal Sav he is much higher
rated than the bottom three players for
the Shanghai Tigers so I think that he
needs to continue to keep that pace
yeah well he continues to show up he was
3-0 yesterday talking about Federal save
he is the one win that is giving us the
difference and that's a guy who wants to
continue to make a difference coming up
next everybody we have hikaranakamura
versus shuyi what will that game give us
it's the pro Chesley Championship here
on this Sunday don't go anywhere we will
be right back
foreign
[Music]
I really love watching games by top
female players and studying their games
in the past and I think that's like one
really cool thing that the test
Community could do more of I know my
friend Luciana is publishing a testable
course on some of the great games by the
early world champions veravan chick
rodengo and you can learn just as much
from these games as you can learn from
any game and yet it does provide
inspiration and like adds like depth to
our chess culture so I about 10 years
ago I published a book called play like
a girl with like tactics by female chess
players and actually redoing that book
and it's so much fun to just like kind
of like dig in and see some of the most
important tactical themes in chess decoy
in between move pins
double attacks and to look for like some
of the the best examples by top female
players so when you hear all these
discussions about women in jazz it's
great sometimes I'm just like wow you
should just like go study some music
games
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Hikaru does it again is like that's how
it's done and here we go
that was nasty
oh my gosh what a turnaround Levy super
team look at that trophy case Elena
Elena this match is over
got it it's official round three ends in
a 4-0 victory I don't think anybody is
even remotely looking forward to the
task of facing the Gotham knights in the
playoffs
those are the Gotham Knights for many of
you it's your Gotham nights we know they
have so many fans around the world the
team brought to you by Levy Rosman led
by Hikaru Nakamura Robert what can you
say how good have they been all year
they have been perfect because all
matches played have been won by the
Gotham Knights and with that man on
screen Hikaru Nakamura he's laughing
he's chatting but he's also winning and
that's great news for the knights
because in the quarterfinals he drew
those four games here he's in a winning
mood
of course it's not over yet and we know
the tigers are formidable we expect them
to continue to find their form as this
protesting championship match rolls on
thanks for being with us on this Sunday
if you're just tuning in Where Have You
Been we have some incredible chess going
on and on that note Robert Let's uh
let's set the table take a look at where
we stand and what our board assignments
our pairings will be as we head into the
second set of games here
well we see hikar Nakamura and Vladimir
fellow said they get the white pieces uh
these matchups can be a quick a bit
tricky because Shu Yi and Lily pink very
strong for the Tigers and then the
bottom two boards Wei needs to take down
volcano I think that is my big matchup
for the round yeah someone has to stop
bokito and if it's not way Yi who else
on the Tigers is gonna do it I agree if
they're gonna keep pace and maybe flip
the pendulum to swing the other way
maybe they go two and a half one and a
half in this round I think Wei needs to
be the leader in the clubhouse if you
will as we already said before we went
to a break at Kara Nakamura takes on Shu
Yi that's also a huge matchup a guy that
played an absolute brilliant C yesterday
in shuey if you missed that game last
time I'll remind you to go check it out
but it was just that good uh and of
course the color Nakamura hopefully he
solved his connectivity issues playing
from stavengar and is going to be ready
to throw down so uh wow this is uh this
is crazy you know Robert a storyline
will continue to dive into as we see Shu
Yi the Tigers board three getting ready
for his uh maybe toughest match of the
day although it's hard to say that given
that he just lost the federal say of
going against zakaru the knights have
just I wonder if people thought they
would be this good I want to talk about
that as we get on now again the match
isn't over they have a lot of work to do
they're leading to an F1 and a half but
it's something that I'd be curious what
chat and fans think about whether they
really thought the knights would be this
dominant heading in so okay here we go
we have E4 E5 on the board it's a Petrov
will it be a Petrov draw or a Petra for
the win Robert
has to be for a win Hikaru Nakamura with
the white pieces he wants to take down
shuyi and we see this Knight D3 line
that caught me by surprise but we have
seen this in the highest levels of chess
the queen has to slide up to E7 because
you need to break the pin with a queen
in front of your Bishop of your own and
this Knight is trying to aim for the D5
squares to be very careful in these
positions did we see this in the world
championship some kind of like Knight C6
Knight D4 weird stuff well 2018 you and
I were uh we're not quite they we
weren't quite in my closet we had moved
out to the room and outside the closet
for those who remember when we covered
carwana Carlson in 2018 but I think that
was the first time we saw this line at
the highest of highest levels
yeah no it Still Remains unfamiliar
because it's that rare and shuyi
thinking right now perhaps rare to him
as well and that means a strong
Grandmaster is surprised by Hikaru
Nakamura and that's I think people
underestimate how important playing so
many games is for Hikaru when he played
in the fide Grand Prix and he won
defeated Grand Prix everyone's saying oh
he's retired he doesn't play classical
chess and Alexander grishuk said he's
played more chess than anybody by far
he'll be just fine yeah let's let's
bring up the analysis board here when we
have a second because I want to show
those lines that you just talked about
because one they're super fun and super
instructive
um and two how often do we get to have
weird weird forks and queen sacks and
all kinds of stuff going on in the
middle of the board at the high level so
there you go this was a line you and I
first covered I remember how surprised
you were when it was played in that game
with carwana Carlson and how you and I
were figuring out those tactics for the
first time but go ahead and shoot he
figured out it might be his first time
seeing this position or maybe the first
time seeing it in five years since that
world championship match but the point
is that if this Knight takes this queen
the Knight takes the other Queen if you
take the bishop I take your bishop and
there's a big problem for white is that
this Rook is not in contact with the
knight in C1 but the black Rook is in
contact with the Knight on C8 so that it
Still Remains even because both Knights
will be lost or won depending on Whose
perspective you're looking at it from
but it remains a balanced position and
that is why after Knight C6 C3 was
played Danny none of this forcing
variations no Queen trades for you just
yet but what if he just play Knight F6
and swap the queens that way that's an
interesting and interesting idea because
the trade would actually leave black up
a Tempo if you will if and Knight F6 has
now been played if Queen E7 Bishop E7 so
Hikaru says no D4 it's funny because in
the end Robert what do we get out of
these move orders a very Petrov looking
type of structure a very symmetrical
kind of game but just some tricks that
got us there versus the more traditional
move orders uh but don't underestimate
how important those tricks were what
have they got in Hikaru well a little
more of an edge on the clock which in a
rapid game is huge and two maybe an
opponent who's a little uncomfortable
right even with just the little
idiosyncrasies that exist here
yeah because you can also be lulled into
a sense of complacency look at this
position we have the Queen's traded one
Pawn traded this should just be shake
hands in a draw and maybe hikar would do
that if you were playing Fabiano caruana
or Magnus Carlson but no I can't show
you he's playing this for a win we've
seen magnets do the same F3 G4 G5 Pawn
pushes this Pawn chain over here then
Knight on C6 looks a bit silly so even
though the evaluation Bar says it's
completely level it still with so much
life left in the position and I actually
think that White's structure is superior
for the time being
is that the voice you make when you talk
with you about it's completely level
dude what is that a voice you make is
that how the eval bar sounds in your
head
uh wow G5 that's a move that says it's
no longer completely level that's not a
move the eval board likes
I don't like it either you're just
creating weaknesses in your own position
I think that Shoei desperately wants
some activity and he was not expecting
this variation to begin with but when
this Knight moves away it can go up to
H5 for a trade and go back to D3 and
then white can play for H4 but I just
don't like this Pawn sticking out Danny
I think this is an idea that's going to
backfire yeah and Hikaru quickly puts
the Knight on D3 this time it doesn't
look as awkward as it did earlier but it
was in front of the d-pawn now where it
belongs behind the d-pawn that's where
Knights like to be all right well let's
let's back up to to where we like to be
a lot which is in the bird's eye view
look remind everybody as we've said many
times you can go to chess.com events and
follow the games yourself if you're into
choosing your own adventure or just stay
right here with us uh where to go wow
all four games go ahead
I was gonna say the bottom right that
just looks like a queenless position
we'll get there later but look at the
bottom left over there wagy and invoked
of their Pawn just up the board that one
looks fascinating yeah it's a it's a
nimso gone wild x-rated Edition here
something something messy is happening
over there and then it comes to H5 and
H4 played instantly by Wiki what is
going on in this game
yeah we're gonna bring it up here you
see a bishop here for white which makes
us realize it's likely was a nimzo uh
the Knight on A5 and Ace and the bishop
on A6 are a very traditional dimso idea
going after those doubled C pawns but
this whole G5 H4 Dynamic on the king
side not so traditional
sort of reminds me of the game between
Arch and aragaisy and volcano from
yesterday it was the night was on D2 and
things were a bit different but you
remember how vokito have gotten huge
trouble his King never found safety I
think Wei Yi is going for a similar type
of plan he says who cares about this C4
Pawn that's irrelevant that's double
it's not really playing a part in the
position Levy break open the king side
there are already tactics there you
could win white material so Danny I love
the strategy it's a bold one but I think
it might pay off hey there you go there
you go cotton that's good old-fashioned
family fun right there if we play H
takes G5 unleashing The Rook on the
Knight you can't take with the pawn
because then G4 straight up wins the
pinned Pony you'd have to take with the
queen which might have its own set of
weird Dynamics G4 still coming Knight H3
with Tempo it's it's a it's a weird one
so the kid off gonna take a beat look at
wayi more time than that which he
started with thank you Old English
language
that witch with henceforth
well this night henceforth drops to the
F4 Square it's going forward and I want
to just make a quick point that Knight
takes C4 will blunder a piece to Queen
A4 It's actually an instructor tactics
I'm gonna show on the board that if you
take on C4 it looks really good give me
a free Pawn but Queen A4 hits the Knight
and the bishop and you say okay I'm not
gonna allow you to take my knight or my
Bishop then the bishop is Unleashed from
F1 to A6 thank you very much for a free
P so just to note that Knight takes C4
is not the threat for black Bishop takes
C4 will be the move you have to play
yeah and that's often the move you want
speaking to fellow nimzoo players out
there because if the Bishops are gone
one you've removed the bishop Aaron two
that Knight that lands on C4 at the end
is an outposted Pony usually causing
more problems than the bishop would if
it was standing on that diagonal so
anyway good good stuff there Knight F4
played but way Yi even though he's now
using a little bit of time
he has an opportunity to keep an edge
here is it HG I keep wondering if I can
just play G3 by the way and just say get
out of here a hundred percent correct I
think those moves take on G5 the queen
takes then play G3 kick that pony back
to G6 then play F4 and we know that you
love Steve moving those pawns up to King
side that looks very Troublesome for a
volcano you can have the C4 Pawn when he
doesn't care I don't care I don't even
think vokidov cares about it anymore
he's like I will do anything I will
change the structure let me put my Pawn
back on G7 please
yeah I love I love it when we talk about
how pawns could go backwards what an
interesting variant to consider and uh
again one of my favorite ones that the
Google deepmind project did all right
the uh the move G7 sorry G5 to G7 is not
legally possible way you gonna take a
beat before he decides how to play this
probably calculating lines that Robert
pointed out with HG and then G3 and F4
um
let's let's back this thing up to the
bird's eye view take a look at the other
games that are rolling
because all four are underway Robert
they are indeed in the top left we
started there with Hikaru and Chewie
that still looks relatively balanced the
bottom right also looks balanced between
Zhu and June and Lulu Nova but Danny the
top right yeah Eva bar quite heavily in
Louis Pink's favor that's where I wanted
to go to Federal say of the big fish
he's been playing perfect chess if you
go back to yesterday he's won four games
in a row but this is an awkward start
for him
low Yi ping with this last move Knight
to D7 which I really like gets the
Knight out of the danger of the coming
G5 Pawn storm it threatens the Knight on
E5 let's bring that one up here as soon
as we can and take a deeper look at this
opposite side castles so very very
dangerous position
yeah but I'm gonna put the King on G in
a bit of green and the King on C1 in red
because I am worried that B4 B3 ideas
will happen fast uh Knight can come to
A6 and try to go to B4 and you like the
move so I just want to show an instant
replay Knight F6 went to D7 not the B8
Knight because C6 was loose and you know
what else the Knight on a D7 does that
F6 would have been a bad Square for it
prevents G5 we talk about a hook and it
just is a hook if you had H4 and G5 that
Knight would have been under attack now
you don't have to lose a Tempo in any
way and already you're threatening to
win a pawn yeah and F4 is obviously
being considered by federal save but
very double edged right the moment you
play a four that's a pawn that can't
back up you already can consider F6 for
black in some positions because the E3
Pawn is weak at the end of that line but
even moves like C5 are more on the
agenda once F4 is played because you get
in these positions Robert which we love
talking about when kings are on opposite
sides of the board everybody what often
matters is just who gets open lines of
attack throw everything including the
kitchen sink if it costs a pawn to open
up the board that might be okay
I like this move A3 black is preparing
to play a move like C5 in some positions
where even if D5 or B5 might fall again
at the right time if the board opens up
that white king is very very exposed at
the end of those lines
this is terrible for federal sale this
Knight comes out to eight look how
quickly look at everything is playing
now Knight comes to B4 that's kind of an
outpost I I know that white has an a
pawn but you can't push it to A3 as that
A3 pawn cements it in place so here
comes Knight before your idea with C5 is
certainly on the agenda and white has no
attack look at White's moves that Knight
went to E5 and back to F3 and black is
just really on the prowl at this point
who cares about this B5 Pawn you're
gonna get C5 and you're gonna open the C
file and White's King is really in
danger not not a good sign and for the
first time we see a slightly kind of
dejected Federal save right we saw him
kind of pulling his hair there something
went wrong nobody plays Knight E5 and
then Knight back to F3 and pretends like
they meant to do it right I think Knight
fd7 was that strong of a move Robert I
think he missed or underestimated if you
will how strong that idea might be
if night before and C5 comes this could
get out of control in a hurry
it looks really tough for white because
where's this queen going you probably
slide to D2 but then you're giving up on
this diagonal and you would love to put
the bishop on B1 that's White's best
idea it attacks and defends this A2 Pawn
in some positions but this King not C1
is going to be In Harm's Way and it
doesn't have time to start running over
to the king side it's too far away
how many times have you stared aboard
and just been so unhappy that you can't
play Bishop to be one move a piece
through on your own pieces for me it's
he can do it again
way too often
yeah but he can do it next but
unfortunately you're not getting your
queen in the diagonal this reminds me of
my loss to Tamir nabati at the 2019
Grand Swiss and I just got obliterated
down the queen side because I thought oh
let me play some enterprising chess
casting long you end up regretting it I
can tell you yeah but oh here comes C5
it's the idea we talked about and look
how fast he's playing too like literally
taking what he wants honey badger style
doesn't care about the B5 Pawn let's go
low yepping I saw yep that means yep he
might get the dub big yep town for low
European coming up
this is terrible for why but Queen 65
apparently a mistake because
I said it's too long of a journey to
bring the king up but maybe you do have
time and his rook and slide to see one
and this Rook H1 to D1 and the King runs
away
don't tell Frodo what he can't do that
was a long journey and he got the job
done
okay you are correct I I apologize sorry
for everything D2 has been playing I
actually as much as the eval bar loves
black I do like that move because if you
play Rook C1 next suddenly White's
pieces are kind of coordinating you get
the king to E1 after the other one comes
to D1 and who knows so low yuping has to
think about how to break through now
because if okay this is interesting
what's he gonna do
so you're gonna
is there like a 982 and beef but the
problem is the Knight takes which is why
I didn't say it
yeah
I blunder all the time I think Knight C6
then just go back why do we have to get
sacrificial and then play B4 is a big
threat and not just B for D4 comes to
mind your king is on D2 after all
okay I like I like this idea yeah Knight
C6 does the does the things you talked
about right gets the night out of the
way so the B4 is a threat unleashing
that Bishop on A6 to the queen and
immediately threatens the most powerful
punch which is D4 look at this so the
engine says this is helping Federal save
but from a practical perspective this
looks very tricky
how can this helpful say that's what I
really am wondering at this point
because uh B4 is such a big threat D4
doesn't look Pleasant to me either so
there must be one move here I'm guessing
it's a tight position if you don't find
the move here you just lose yeah exactly
the the is it it's like a knight A4 or
something right no it doesn't even work
you can just take it in fact and then
take the queen on E2 because F3 hangs
and everything falls so uh so I got
nothing
you know what it is Robert I just saw it
I think it's Queen D3 I think you
threatened mate with Tempo and then you
can play 92 with Tempo and then put the
Knight on D4
well that actually really helps out so
Step One is complete and let's see if he
does play 92 here because then the queen
is under attack the Knight behind us the
queen has to step back and the Knight to
D4 as you're saying that does seem to
help out a lot but I am worried about
timely Knight E4 check as well so
there's so much to calculate here and
phariseev is on the clock
maybe you voluntarily know if you play
Queen C2 that Knight will come right
back to B4 I was proud of myself for
finding Queen D3 you know look at me no
hands look at me dad oh yeah
um but then it turns out I'm still in
trouble oh wow
three minutes both sides under four
minutes at this point
Danny I put on my calculation hat I
think Knight takes D5 is the move
Knight takes D5 laughing in the face of
Danger on the D file
s he finds it
oh my gosh if Federal save gets out of
this one
yep he's up a pawn low yipping is like
wait a second he can do this his King is
in the center he's like what
not only is the king in the center this
Pawn on A2 is in trouble what is
happening down this diagonal
how is this okay yeah it's just it's
like low you ping is is a is a is one
move away from just like you know
pounding the table in frustration how
did how did white slip off the hook
there
Knight takes E3 oh the king can take go
to F4 so that doesn't work that's a good
way to lose the game on the spot
yeah
Knight C3
V4 Knight C3 also makes sense that's
coming
what a game we've had
seriously
key E2 is the safe move to play but I
wonder if white can find some sort of
tactical defense like Rook H to C1 and
just again laugh in the face of the
Discover check I I would assume there's
a good discover check but I don't
exactly see the win
so there's Knight F4 but you're right
this Knight can always go to D4 and
That's essential so good call by you
Knight D4 first would be a mistake he
plays it wow
no hands no I play better chess with no
hands apparently
yeah and I think that Pharisee is
playing like a combination of the two of
us but like you know on steroids it just
is elevated play but coming up with
these ideas and what a turnaround in
this game Danny and by the way he killed
fokito I just am noticing that okay wow
we missed one that's unfortunate that we
didn't look at that because what a
storyline bokito has been and what a
call out we made when we said someone
has to stop him it might be way ye we
will probably make a quick run through
that game everybody just to see what
happened but OMG a big dub for way Yi
over vikidov
yeah but for federal save here he can
offset that damage with a win of his own
and he put his Rook on C4 B4 is loose
and you can't defend it you can bring
your knight back but you don't want to
go back and forth with your knight when
you're down to pawns he's Bishop E4 he's
trying to make A2 tender but after
Bishop takes Knight takes the king
escapes to E1 this Rook can slap to C2
Danny I think this is certainly heading
White's way that's just crazy what
happened here I mean he was in huge
trouble getting smashed on the queen
side and now he's up a pawn as we head
into a rook and Knight end game and this
isn't even this isn't just winning for
white Robert this is like it's falling
apart in a hurry white even has Knight
C6 night before if you I mean this is
like just like that it's like Federal
say have planned it all along
made natural moves but it's a collapse
in the position that is one tactical
shot Queen D3 Knight takes D5 and that's
why we say don't take positions for
granted Louis pink didn't he just got
caught off guard a great tactical Vision
by veto but you can't take a single move
off in chess it went from great attack
for black to suddenly liquidation and
pawn down end game and now it's supposed
to be two pawns down
well we need to back up because uh two
pawns down low Yi ping will be and two
games down in this round the Tigers
might find themselves because the Luna
normanova also
looking pretty good against you and June
over there
wow
now that would be an upset yeah despite
where Yi taking down Paquita and again
apologies we missed that game but in our
in our defense uh it ended very very
fast that was shocking I thought we had
some time to circle the wagons uh but we
didn't and here we go
okay and B5 so this is time possession
Danny where black is up two pawns and my
Master's me well uh but white still has
chances and I'm not just saying that
because the rating differential this
Rook honey too that's not exactly where
it wants to be we typically like Rooks
on the second or seventh rank but this
Rook can be kicked around at the right
moment this bishop can swing here this
bishop on C8 has not developed if the
Knight moves to free the path The Rook
comes a d8 so black is up two pawns
objectively we see the evaluation but I
think if you look at this position you
could see white winning this a large
majority of the time
agreed the more I look at it it feels
like a position that the computer could
keep playing accurately move after move
but humans have a very hard time how
does that Bishop on C8 develop well it's
hard right now and if that Bishop
doesn't develop how does that Rook get
in the game well she tried with A6 but
just like that you see the eval turning
around white has B6 and they even Knight
A5 if that Knight plans itself on A5 how
does black ever untie the queen side
she trapped The Rook that's exactly what
she went for she opens up her Rook to
defend but this is a trick it's like oh
I'm just protecting my Pawn no no no
Here Comes Bishop F1 and that Rook is in
fact trapped so the game is turning
around in White's favor I don't care
what the Evo Bar says I think this is
troublesome for black
yeah agreed it's probably some weird way
for black to take B5 and sacrifice The
Exchange on E3 but again I'm also liking
white those Rooks are primed and ready
to pounce on the open file the moment
that Knight moves from D2
what an interesting position that was
okay
and we got there just for the turnaround
and the game did not turn around for low
y painful to save one quickly so that
means that the match remains one point
lead for the Gotham Knights but this
would be a huge game for the Tigers and
the clock about even I just expect June
just the base on the trajectory based on
the fact that she'll have an upbeat up
an exchange in her experience as the
Women's World Champion playing a lower
rate opponent yeah I think she has this
one
yeah agreed and uh Norma Nova
okay she plays Bishop D4 I like that
move you might meet Bishop F1 with Rook
takes E3 gobbling a pawn for the
exchange right that's a good price shot
oh can we change our tune and take in
the brand Knight C4 and again rook dhek
and Knight B6
you can make your own kind of music
Robert and play your own kind of song
wow that's uh the sweetest thing anytime
you want man
appreciate that but you know what I mean
sometimes we're so tunneled on one idea
that we lose sight of the fact that it's
a chess game they're moving parts and
they're moving pieces let's take and
play Knight C4 maybe I'll take on A6
first but my point is I'm gonna get
Knight C4 hop my knight to B6 and try to
get my Rook to d8 these pieces can't
move
yeah they're stuck
development is important even if you're
up a pawn that's the lesson that you and
June is gonna remind us all of here
in this game
I also like takes D4 and Knight C4 I
don't see why you would go for the
exchange and let black just to show
everyone Bishop F1 Rook takes E3 Pawn
takes Bishop takes with check and black
has plenty of things going on for the
exchange so you don't want that
I think just from an Optics point of
view you just I can't handle that I
don't want that so you say Bishop takes
and there's also Knight takes E4 as a
possibility and this Knight on D4 is
loose so you have tactics available to
you but now June is down under a minute
so she needs to start moving
yep I'm with you I'm with you I'm with
you the red I see red on the screen that
means time pressure time pressure is
here
she's double checking all the variations
but sometimes you can overthink it if
you're looking looking at a position
you're trying to find The Knockout blow
before it exists and you should just
move right because from the perspective
that if you get yourself under time
pressure and you haven't won the game
yet you did yourself a disservice trying
to be too accurate earlier on so easy
for us to say here for me to say in this
chair but it is something to watch out
for because look now she's made a
mistake
wait what if I just take B5
with the Knight I think she wants Bishop
F1 then she's trying to trap on his back
okay
you know what there might be E3 in a
pawn 6 Knight C2 kind of stuff with the
Knight hopping around and riding some
Forks
that's probably it but computer likes it
but we'll see if normanova can find it
it's so tricky and Shu Yi is in time
travel against a card Nakamura does wow
E3 play it's a good find by nerman
Hikaru maybe he'll be able to find a
victory out of that position
yeah that's that's uh the victory that
the knights really need you want a car
to keep doing a car with things he has a
check another check with a knight
and he's forking and winning
it's a small board but you can see it
clearly Hikaru Nakamura has just done
what he does often swindles his opponent
won the exchange and he's gonna go on to
get his second win yes small board but
big tactics and he is now up in exchange
the game isn't over yet because white
only has three pawns and black the same
so if black can trade off enough pieces
then we may see a black hole down but
yeah a car is too strong here comes a
rook to the seventh Rank and these pawns
are weak
yeah I was gonna say don't play Rook H1
there that would have been a forking
problem on F2 but Hikaru knows better
than that gets The Rook to the seventh
rank I want to go back to the to the uh
the Juan June normanova game because she
found E3 and she has found her way out
of the worst of it the Jew and June has
some pressure but if Norma Nova pulls
off even a draw against you and June
that will be that will be what the uh
the knights want big time yeah and this
is a situation in the bottom right hand
side of our screen uh that it's getting
better and better for Norma Nova and is
it Rook A5 she does in fact play it you
take my Bishop I take yours suddenly
nurmanova's winning
oh my gosh dude this is
dude wait that's a great move I thought
it was a blender but it was gone it was
a trick
in 4k3 you win the game on the spot
oh she misses it Rook A3 was over Rook
A3 was over
but she could still run over is nervous
she just brings her King over and she's
gonna win she's winning clearly with the
King March anyway and and boy did this
one get away from Jew and June but
but oh my gosh that would have been a
knockout and just like that the knights
are continuing to show up and dominate
I'm just I'm so impressed right now from
their board four
was
just super tricky position and she not
only held on she out calculated her
opponent who is the women's world
champion and a strong Grandmaster
completely over at this point
it's over and this match is is heading
the night's way yet again what a huge
upset this was and we we kind of sensed
it right you and June have pressure but
she took almost two minutes on that move
Rob what we were looking at and then
didn't find the best move and you were
like Bishop takes d49 C4 you get what
I'm saying I think that there's a there
was a practical sense we could get there
that this uh this position was slipping
away from June June and nurmanova sticks
with it she's gonna go on to win this
one and with it the knights are going to
have an absolutely commanding lead in
this protest League final match I was a
very quick instant replay because this
is such an important instructive moment
that right here uh uh before this excuse
me when we got this position that it
looks like a blunder because I thought
black could play rookie five and then
white gets Rook B6 and you see the
evaluation about go to zeros because
what when both of the pawns trade the
Bishops even end game but she actually
induced a mistake Rook D6 is a mistake
because after Rook A6 you protect the
bishop through the rook and after Rook
D3 now black can trade everything off
and that leads to the winning end game
that we saw Rook a three was maybe more
precise but Bishop B3 did the trick so
Rook A6 great tactical awareness from
nirmanova she earned that point
and let's back up and see where that
puts us speaking of earning that point
the knights have earned their lead that
they now hold in this match they are up
three to one after this round man just
just wild wild chess there and uh you've
got to just tip your hat because you
know the funniest result the kid off was
finally stopped Right Way Yi said uh
said I got you I got you Tigers I'm
gonna slow down this guy but
unfortunately nobody else was able to
get the job done yeah that game ended so
fast that we didn't even get to see the
Finish but you should go on chest.com
events and look at the game because it
was a beauty it was a masterpiece from
weigi he wins the game but the rest of
his teammates they couldn't get the job
done and the Gotham Knights do have a
huge lead
they have a huge lead they are within
Striking Distance to end the match
within the next round okay it would take
another 3-1 score to reach that
touchdown of eight and a half points but
it is possible and at this point just
they seem unstable it's possible and
they seem Unstoppable Robert
yeah this is not Mission Impossible but
it's getting pretty close for the
Shanghai Tigers I'm worried for them
they need to just start getting
victories but their bottom two boards
have zero points between them that just
can't happen
it can't happen and I'm gonna I'm gonna
before we head to a break remind
everybody but something else can happen
and that is if you're a title player you
are eligible to compete in the 2023
Champions chess tour if you didn't know
it now you do you don't want to miss
your chance to qualify for the tour's
fourth event we host qualifiers every
Monday if you didn't get that memo
excluding days of course where there are
champions chess tour events your next
chance to join is actually tomorrow
that's May 15th for details use the
command qualifiers in chat alright
everybody don't go anywhere when we
return can Wei ye continue to have put
the Tigers on his back and he avenge his
loss to Federal sale from earlier this
season we'll see it's round three of the
PCL finals after a very short break
we'll be right back
all right
thank you
welcome to check with mates the only
podcast by chess pieces for chess pieces
I'm a rook and I'm a pawn let me ask you
this you ever feel like you're
undervalued absolutely everyone's like
oh pawns they can only move one square
they can't go backwards new we don't
want to go backwards you know maybe
we're focused on the future yeah I feel
that sometimes I wonder why we're even
protecting a king he wasn't elected
through a democratic process maybe I
want to be king dude I think about that
every day yeah okay real quick shout out
to our sponsor hellofresh I don't use
them because I'm chess piece but I'm
sure they're great you guys play chess
you want to talk about it let's do oh
yeah where do you play chess at you know
okay when I say chess the first word
that pops into your mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice yeah if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
is good right yeah then yeah instant
swipe right okay super into that right
I'm into it you're ready to just look
that's probably whatever the swipe is I
don't not interested you're not
interested in chess players I'm not
interested chess players are on Tinder
oh I get that I in fact that checks out
if I ask you to name one chess player in
the world can you name a chess player
yeah no not gonna honestail La Joy
capable
wow name another one oh Kasparov Kasper
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm Gonna Give
You fifty dollars
ski
and
on holy you get 50 bucks dude oh my
God we just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
foreign
thank you
this year saw the return of the protest
league and thank goodness Chad so good
to have you back PCL this is nice
because I got a queen let's go
with the postseason upon us the stakes
are only getting higher which teams from
around the world can survive to claim
the next PCO championship and also bite
off a Lion's Share of the fresh 100 000
up for grads
the finals of the protest League
playoffs have finally arrived Queen to
achieved oh my gosh
I'm Out Boy the PCL is here to stay who
will be crowned its next champion
eight and a half to one and a half
we are backed we are hyped and we are
about to have Wei throw down against
Vladimir fetto sayev he's had quite the
career yarbert uh yarbert hey Robert
take us away Albert yabba dabba doo yes
I will way ye has been you know a star
since he was a teenager there's been a
lot of pressure on him when you break
titles uh Records excuse me and you have
the youngest Grandmaster the youngest
2700 in history when you do those kind
of things people expect big things from
you and for way Yi some say he hasn't
lived up to the hype he hasn't lived the
expectations he's 2700 plus has been for
a decade and he's still only like 23
years old so Wei is an absolute Menace
on the chessboard and he's two out of
two in this match he needs to keep
winning but his teammates need to help a
guy out
yeah and he's been dominant in the PCL
all year the loss of federal state of
one of the only ones uh that he actually
actually had so we'll see if he can
continue to play the chess that he's
known for but as you said his teammates
really need to back him up and on that
note let's take a look at where we sit
with the overall scores and of course uh
how each player is performing you see it
on the right side but the problem is way
Yi is two out of two nobody else has a
single point
yeah we see Jew and JuJu her first game
against vokito who has struggled himself
he just got demolished by way Yi but the
Gotham Knights it's not just Hikaru and
phariseev you also see nermanova she
just scored a humongous upset over June
this match would be quite close if that
game had gone the other way but Norma
Nova says no don't forget about me I'm
not just here to have a name on the
roster I'm gonna score some points and
she did score points maybe she's going
to do it again let's bring up the
pairings as we get set for round three
we move to the back half the Tigers
would like it to be a back half and not
have it be a back one third as we ended
up having yesterday when the knights
absolutely dominated MGD one uh they
need to get at least two and a half out
of four here if not more Robert how do
you think they get that done
I think here's where you become a team
player if you're Federal save if you're
Hikaru maybe you don't take the risks
you would if this were the regular
season or a closer match just shut it
down like if you're Hikaru and June
tries to force to draw maybe just take
the draw I think that's a good result
for the team and you see June probably
doing some last minute preparation uh
but she needs to score and that may just
be a half point but it should get a full
point against Hikaru that would perhaps
be a huge swing in the match
yeah and I like that that point because
not only does Sakara probably only need
a draw to protect his team's lead he's
also playing Black so unless you and
June comes up with something really
spicy and forces the issue Hikaru might
be fine with just letting it Peter out
of course uh he knows how strong Zhu and
June is despite just losing that game to
normanova she's obviously women's world
champion for a reason he doesn't want to
overly risk it for an unnecessary
biscuit I could go for some biscuits and
gravy oh I could definitely use a
biscuit or two but right now we see in
this opening the nimzo Indian defense
from Hikaru Nakamura Bishop D3 so that
leaves white with a flexible approach
this Knight can go up to F3 as it just
does or in some positions or it slides
to the E2 Square so Danny this approach
from Hikaru I think it's a good one
we're still very early yeah but what do
you think his mindset is like
well I think what you said you know is
true that he's he doesn't want to risk
it unnecessarily right so he's gonna
play fast and do what he does and see
what zoom and June creates right it's
nice when you're leading because you can
sort of Let The Game come to you right
to uh to use a sports cliche you don't
have to go looking for problems and you
see hikara playing very fast he knows
these nimzoo Indians very well he's
already got himself on the right foot of
an isolated Queen Pawn kind of position
it's again it's good for white too but
this is uh gonna be a position with
three results possible
yes and A3 played in the engine starts
to like Black's position if you take and
the bishop takes on C3 then we prefer
white but instead Hikaru backs up to C5
so I think we can ignore the evaluation
bar for now because we just want to talk
about the motifs here D4 if you can play
D4 and get rid of your isolated Queen
Pawn you probably want to do that ASAP
and if you're white you know that's what
Black's intention is and how do you stop
it move like Knight A4 to get rid of
this bishop off the Diagon comes on and
she plays Knight B5
she's gonna head to D4 and hope that if
white has an isolated pawn it costs
black the bishop
yeah it's just it's interesting and if
you give white another move white will
play Bishop C3 as you highlighted
earlier uh if that Bishop gets that
diagonal White's happy the Knight can
come to D4 the problem here for Zhu and
June is okay you avoided D4 but you also
invited a completely symmetrical
structure black has really nothing to
worry about apparently black has a kink
in his arm Hikaru is shaking shaking it
out over there on the left we could we
could all pause and do some stretches
you know what I mean just everyone when
was the last time you got up and
stretched your back just health health
first
it's been a few hours because I've been
sitting in this chair talking to you I'm
not complaining about it I'm just being
honest with everybody that my back mate
started to hurt a little bit but we see
in this position this night was on C3
now it's on D4 this Knight can come to
E4 for black so it's a it's give and
take we say this in every single
position when you see what changes with
your opponent's moves this Knight has
blockaded the iqp that's what Aaron
nibsovich taught us in his uh all of his
books including my system but this
Knight could go into E4 for black so
you've given up control that square
typically when you have okay I was just
about to go in an isolated Queen Pawn
education rant for chat but instead I'm
actually just gonna save my breath
because Knight takes D4 we're probably
transitioning out of the iqp okay shubas
you can take with the Knight
uh and uh then black maybe does continue
with the plan you highlighted with
Knight E4
typically in an isolated Queen pump
position you want the pieces on the
board because you want threats uh you
want pressure and usually the isolated
queen Blood is the further Advance
Center Pawn just like it is here so that
gives you a little more access to the
power squares in the middle of the board
uh but zoom and June also got to be
considering taking with the pawn and
just going into a symmetrical structure
you get Bishop G5 to follow you gain a
Tempo on the bishop what do you think
she'll play guess the move
I think she'll play Knight takes D4 and
after Knight E4 tries some kind of
Bishop B4 thing and just try to you know
stay in front of this iqp but I don't
love her chances right now I have to say
that a car seems to have equalized
without issue and with all four games
now underway I think that we might need
if you're a Shanghai Tigers fan to rely
on the teammates to score some points
agreed Town population us let's set
let's head over to the bird's eye view
town
there's a lot of bird sighting over
there wow a trade on the on D4 twice
Hikaru takes without thinking it
instantly played Queen B6 there you now
see it in the upper left corner of your
screen but as Robert said all four games
are underway all four looking close to
equal
uh what's happening in the bottom left
between vokita and Louisa ping
yeah another weird opening from vaquita
right he's he got himself in big trouble
if you missed it way he destroyed him
because of a very awkward overextended
King side nimzo last game vakidov got
punished and in this position again I
don't know that I'm
actually I don't know I don't know who I
like here this is weird the double death
Pawns
no one's happy about that
black is up a pawn right so there's an
extra Pawn here but the double up ones
look terrible which means you're getting
castle and I'm reading the notation so I
actually want to go back because I see
what happened and there's a trick so
we're just gonna show you a quick
variation this Knight went back to E7
which allowed the shattering of the pawn
structure it also looks like you've
Blended upon E5 but black has the move
C6 here hitting the bishop on B5 and
this oh wait there's no queen of five
because The Bishop's in the way I've
actually there are lines like this so
maybe just Bishop D4 is simpler and the
Knight or the pawn on B2 but what weird
stuff in a position like this where the
bishop goes back and you start forking
pieces Knight D6 yeah I can't calculate
anything
you're not you're not you're not doing
anything wrong because you're
highlighting instructive tactics for the
viewers but this position is just so
unique that the tactics aren't normal I
mean normally that idea exactly A6 and
B5 gets the job done not C6 and normally
that other idea you showed of C6 and
queen A5 check is actually a really
important one to watch out for because
the queen on A5 can win the 995 so I got
your back but yeah that was funny yeah
no just showing that I make plenty of
mistakes everybody so it's okay for you
to do the same and instead in the game
we saw the captures the pawns structure
is fractured the King goes to H1 and
Danny I have to say that the Shanghai
Tigers they're kind of in must win
territory for their games at this point
I think that Loya ping is doing the
right thing like he's playing a strong
Grandmaster but he has a position where
vokidov certainly can go wrong
yeah agreed it's a very double-edged
position and remember they're not
technically in every game must be one
territory yet but they're pretty close
to it right and so getting Dynamic
positions with uh with all kinds of
three results possible that's what you
want here if you are low yipping and um
and he's at least got that
it's a mess yeah up a pawn for black
open G file B2 is under attack Bishop
pair some point maybe D5 and this bishop
gets out so uh this king is likely
castling Queen side I just like the way
the game is going he might lose the game
but draw it's not match over with a
bunch of draws but we see the scoreboard
five and F2 and F the Gotham Knights
need three total points and that's the
end of the match so I think for lo you
ping he's doing the right thing he's
really giving bokito a lot to figure out
agreed agreed agreed vokidov is thinking
about what he wants to do next let's
let's think about backing up again
take a look at all four games in
progress remember you can go to
chess.com events and check it out you
can also listen to us providing
commentary there the uh the twitch
player is embedded shout out to everyone
no matter where you're watching twitch
YouTube the whole gamut there's a few of
you still wondering where mixer went I
got a long story to tell you it involves
ninja and some weird things but if
you're not if you're not on mixer then
you're watching our show
[Laughter]
uh well where should this show go to
next because all the games besides this
one look pretty stable so this was the
game we just looked at between the
bottom left between vokito and Lui ping
that one seems the most fun so where
should we go to that's a little bit more
nuanced and strategic
Norma Nova has an isolated Queen Pawn
position that's the iqp structure we
almost could have gotten
um in the uh
Zhu and Jun Hikaru Nakamura game the
very traditional iqp over there if we
want to head on over normanova again got
the huge win last round over women's
world champion Zhu and Jun and here she
is her currently holding her own against
shuyi
yeah she has a solid position with the
white pieces but I have to say it feels
like black is down a few Tempe this Rook
this bishop not in the game and look at
all of Black's pieces they're in perfect
places rookie eight Rook d8 those moves
come to mind and maybe Rook dated
punching that D4 move we keep talking
about isolated pawns but you do have to
watch out for Bishop G5 that's the one
tactic you don't want to walk into so as
long as you cover that maybe Rook E8 to
start with I think that
white is a little bit underdeveloped
it's funny because Rook E8 you have to
look at Queen takes D5 it feels like a
move too risky to play right it feels
like Ah that's can I really get away
with that with so many pieces Under Fire
like Bishop takes F3 you think about
that move everybody's pinned yeah we can
even look at this end game and it says
that white is better but I think from a
distance it looks like black certainly
has compensation I wonder instead of
Bishop takes F3 what the move is because
is it like a Nike five stacking this
bishop on C5 is it could that be it
95 looks interesting
yeah oh you get you guessed right you
guessed right
eval Bar says I will giveth and take it
the way your happiness Robert
95 what a nice move there and again it
does highlight the point White is
underdeveloped you may you made the
comment that it feels like normanova is
down a couple Tempe and I agree the lack
of development means the Rooks are not
talking and Rooks like to talk they're
real chatty Kathy's the more Brooks are
communicating open lines of
communication the key to any healthy
relationship the Brooks are no exception
no they certainly are not but watch out
for this move by the way is that this
bishop pins the pawn on F2 to the King
on G1 so if you made the move G4 you're
losing the spot because the queen walks
into the G3 Square so wait for played A4
A4 played
Queen G3 is a move here
it is
94th you have to start calculating these
things yeah that's good for black though
strategically it's good for black
because you can start trading on D4 with
take with the bishop take with this this
bishop here and white is left with this
bishop against this Knight and an
isolated Pawn on D4 so that would be
good for black
yeah I agree it would be a very weird
series of exchanges shui feels the
tension though and he builds on it I
think that's a smart mature move and
also that he played it fast Robert right
didn't spend too much time making sure
that Queen G3 worked he plays rookie 8
which means any tactics that occur now
which by the way Queen G3 still an
interesting move Bishop H4
is is a move for white but then Bishop
takes F2 but then there's King F1 what
is going on here I can't make sense of
that position uh
I think you did make sense of it though
that actually looks like it pans out for
uh white but what about H6 because
White's idea is to play Bishop H4 and G3
and we're talking about how you can't do
that so after H6 Bishop H4 G5 I think
white suffers because your Bishop is
nowhere to go so where does this bishop
retreating after H6
yeah and if you if you go all the way
back to D2 or C1 once again Queen G3 is
on on the agenda and The Rook on the Y8
oh
the tactics are only getting better for
black here right they're not getting
worse whether there is a knockout or not
and that's why I like that he played
rookie I think it's instructed to see
not just that he played rookie eight
everyone but that he played it quickly
and that's kind of how you want to
handle these practical moments
I like black chances here good for the
Tigers great for the Tigers indeed so uh
maybe shuyi we can leave him he is down
a couple minutes on the clock so he'll
have to watch out for the time but let's
see how his teammates are doing because
just a single win it's not going to even
the score so we'll see how the teammates
are doing because every game at this
point is very important
heading into the round you see the score
everybody five and a half two and a half
and uh the Tigers have got to get some
wins
so shuyi looking good you and June
holding her own against hicaro in the
upper left we haven't looked at the
matchup that we really highlighted as
the matchup of the round we should
probably make our way to Wei Yi versus
Vladimir ferrosev you see that very
powerful knight on E5 supported by the
F4 E3 D4 Pawn structure uh a lot of a
lot of Chess left in this one
oh yeah because we have a position where
only one night for black has been
captured for a bishop and then only one
single Pawn has been traded for each
side so A6 look at these calm moves that
means C5 is definitely something to
think about and he didn't want to give
up the B5 Square for example Bishop to
come into B5 would kick The Rook back to
f8 so these small moves are actually
very useful and for way Danny I know
you're gonna be happy about this is it
H3 G4 and go for the attack you have
three you have to ask me I mean you have
to my opinion or whether it's good okay
queen of three you want to see it happen
I do I do and I like Queen of three as
another way to go about it now you might
even play H3
just to control that G4 Square make it
harder for black to take E5
and uh if you play G4 right away there's
probably Bishop takes E5 followed by
taking on G4 so you can't do it so H3
makes sense
also but but I want to highlight
something again we keep I keep talking
about the Practical aspects of things
today don't know what's gotten into me
but I want to highlight that Federal
save is up on the clock regardless of
what we feel about the position
objectively I think he's just being very
smart and it shows maturity in these
rapid time controls to just appreciate
Robert that hey we haven't reached the
critical position yet I know way he's
gonna bring the heat I need to have time
when it matters most and I think that
that that's just really pays dividends
down the road when you see a guy like
Federal save up on the clock it's how he
beat shuyi earlier in the first game of
the match is it was about balance based
on the evaluation bar but it was a messy
position and he had more time I think
that way you should play G4 and the
reason why is I don't think you can
successfully take on E5 and take on G4
their tactics in White's favor where
black loses the piece I'm gonna show
that very quickly because I I forgot H3
can just come at the end of that very
nice right Knight takes you for H3 this
Knight has nowhere safe to go and
somehow the evil Bar says black is still
in this probably because White's King is
very open and the queen can come out of
something like that but still white is
in the driver's seat and if you take
with the bishop yes you're attacking the
queen but once the queen moves anywhere
let's say for your knight is under
attack and your knight moves you lose
this bishop on G4 so G4 definitely an
idea for way Yi but he's not playing it
because then you like to talk about
match strategy and when to go for the
win this is going all in and he may
regret it because his King doesn't get
to be protected down the line
yeah and it's scary though because if
you don't go for it now when look you're
now down to two minutes on the clock and
if the position is the same way but both
sides are down under a minute now maybe
you've lost your chances right so I
think he's calculating G4 I think you're
right Robert whether he goes for it or
not he knows that uh time is of the
essence literally and figuratively
he needs to figure this out and look at
his clock it sound under now about a
minute 45 seconds and federal saves five
and a half minutes he is playing
brilliantly throughout this championship
match
yeah sorry I didn't have much to add
there I'm just I'm looking at his clock
I'm getting nervous I feel like the
Tigers chances are twiddling by the way
81 of our chat agrees with that of 1400
votes people think the knights are gonna
win and at this point at this point
they're leading so you know uh you're
safe better you you know you
bandwagoners
at the same time the same time I can't
argue with it and uh
then okay
okay he goes King H1 so I think G4 is
top of mind and he wants a I think this
is actually really good restraint
because he wants to play G4 but he wants
to do it under perfect circumstances and
now that C5 is played he hasn't
committed himself to G4 and instead he
goes for F5 and the D5 Pawn is loose
he's gonna win the D5 Pawn but Black's
pieces are also coming to life there's
Bishop takes E5 enter mezzo if you play
Knight takes D5 and if you take D7 first
okay he goes for it we're gonna see
Bishop takes E5 and who's better now I
mean I don't like where this is headed
at all for way Yi what you said is
perfect Bishop takes E5 the pawn takes
here you can take with the Rook on E5
but you can also just keep trading
pieces and I think that is what's gonna
happen and there is an important point
at the end of the line for Knight takes
Queen takes you can just move your
Bishop to C6 this bishop is loose the E5
Pawn will drop and black has the upper
hand as White's pawns are going to be
disconnected and overextended
and black will be up on the clock and I
think you just you gotta tip your hat to
Federal save at this point I mean again
won all three games yesterday he's won
his games today playing like an MVP I
don't know how the Voting is gonna go at
the end but this guy is certainly you
know certainly right there at the top of
everyone's mind he if he takes down way
Yi with black
book it
yep and I don't know what this feature
chat is that looks like a queen blunder
of some sort so I I don't really know
Queen H3 Bishop H3 Knight I have no idea
what that's referring to but keep
chatting maybe a different game
could very well be in fact different
game I just poked at the other games and
I see there's a queen takes H3 tactic
four actually nurmanova and Shu Yi very
interesting we should head over there uh
okay this this game might be deciding
the match and federal save takes him
down with black but this game in the
lower right between nurmanova and shuyi
that's the feature chat call out
okay well then let's go right to it
because uh that game in the bottom right
between nurmanova and chuyi this last
move and let's remind everybody should
play to Queen takes H3 that was a
brilliancy here it's a little bit more
straightforward this is pinned over here
but is it as straightforward as you
would think because you could take away
yeah this bishop which is pitting the
pawn
if Rook takes E4
it's D takes E4 right gotta be
and we're gonna find out because here it
comes all right Rook takes E4 D takes E4
both Queens are Under Fire
take that and then but black is gonna
take this Knight it's called crazy
people
you gotta sacrifice your pieces back and
forth
good I thought you were doing Campbell's
makes everything
good not a sponsor of this show I was
about to say that so I didn't think I
could make that kind of reference
sound and I just had to say it okay
coming to D2 and F2 and B2 being loose I
think this is great winning chances for
Street
I love Black's position here play a five
I would just do it instantly he does
Here Comes Rook D2 this is an exchange
sack I can get behind
but lots of cash are coming
it's just a button up for black it was
like oh it was yeah it was for a moment
but no yeah now he's just up a pawn yeah
my bad yeah he stole a pawn but white
gave up a rook for a bishop but then the
queen took the rook and the queen took
the Knight and then at when all is said
and done black is simply up upon an end
game and should be able to convert this
unfortunately for the yeah you're gonna
say the same thing go for it yeah yeah
you've got a a huge advantage in the top
board the top left corner Hikaru
Nakamura over shoe and June if we want
to head back to the bird's eye view
that's that's the game that uh
that's the game that everyone's looking
at because if if Federal save takes down
way Yi those eval bars are symmetrical
but both players playing Black have huge
advantages with Nakamura and federal say
of Robert
yeah sorry to have cut you off their
partner I was looking at the same thing
where suddenly the bar dipped all the
way down to the bottom and it's because
Hikaru Nakamura well he is now up a pawn
in a queen and Bishop ending and that
pawn on D6 I like to say that it's about
Pawn quality not necessarily quantity
but that pawn is going to be lost and
that means black is going to be two
pawns ahead
I mean this is by the way Federal say
have just took down Wei with black it's
over it's in the books I'm just like
they're just they're out of control the
knights Gotham is safe again they've
been protected welcome back to the city
everybody because Gotham Knights might
indeed go 3-1 in this round if Hikaru
wins Federal save already did the only
other game we haven't touched on at all
really is vaquita versus logi Ping and
that's also going into favor of the
knights
and look at home dude gosh Queen you
want check he he trades on a purple
Square so this is super instructive you
were just browsing the game you wouldn't
notice let's just go back a quick second
here he could have taken a mid show it's
still going to be good for black but the
king is a little bit more advanced so
instead Hikaru swaps on G1 so the king
is less active we call that ruthless
chess and by the way this might be the
call we might be about to make the call
for the pro Chesley Championship if
hikar was converting but let's back up
to the bird's eye view just to really
give the fans the full look this is
almost over
Federal save is one Hikaru is following
suit and vakidov's Advantage it
continues to grow on board three and
your Gotham Knights are on their way to
winning the 2023 protestly championship
unbelievable stuff from the Gotham
Knights because you see in the top left
hikar is well on his way to winning up
two Pawns in the bottom left vokito who
had a very adventurous start to the game
oh well that bar is dipping down a bit
but he does have the upper hand
okay low Yi ping holding on let's bring
up the kid off low Yi ping if we can
that uh that's the only game we haven't
checked on I mean I huh any one of these
games could be the game that officially
wins it for your team uh that's the one
difference between the team event and an
individual Championship Robert where you
only have one game to focus on only one
player can win any one of these players
might be the one who kind of officially
punches the ticket for the Gotham
Knights yeah look at this position for
vokido the King on H1 feels safer but
I'm also looking the clock two extra
minutes and look at this Firepower down
the D file you want the El jekins gun
you don't want your queen to lead the
way would like to be us and D1 switch
places with the Rook but it is what it
is and there is so much pressure in the
position
yeah and again that clock you know Lo Yi
ping he's had a great season he's been
dangerous but something about the clock
management can sometimes tell you how a
player's feeling Robert as far as
confidence feeling on form he's been
under time pressure in every single game
and you can't pressure can't live on the
edge like that I know it sounds fun it
sounds like well I'm daring but for Loya
ping I just think it hasn't worked out
for him because five seconds to a minute
and a half in this position good luck to
you
Hikaru Nakamura has officially defeated
women's world champion Zhu in June that
means the knights are one win away from
Pro chess League Championship
immortality only a few teams have won a
PCL title in the Gotham Knights are
trying to join that list
I've really just excellent display from
the knights and Rook to B2 that Rook
wants to get to B7 and queen F4 played
and the engine approves this Rook C7 in
some of these positions and the queen
defends
yeah that's a nice idea we shouldn't
underestimate that white can also
blunder especially now that the kid off
is under a minute F3 is tender okay here
oh that and that's what you're trying to
do you're trying to play C4 because F3
Denny I know we've been almost calling
match over but black could actually win
this game
yeah
no I'm with you I mean right as we uh we
as soon as I saw the red on the clock
and I started going hold the hold the
phone low you ping is not out of this
yet oh it's just like that we have Rook
takes G4 and you can't take because
Queen takes E4 and queen G2 is gonna be
mate
hold the phone everybody we're likely
having a fourth round just like that low
Yi ping despite the time pressure says
calm down Dan
this ain't the PCL title just yet he
gives up the he sacrifices The Rook but
he gives out the bishop because the king
could keep running away you only have a
few checks on the seventh Rank and the
King finds safety because the Rook that
only attacks but defends Danny this was
an amazing tactical sequence
seriously
what a hold right now he grabs a pawn
and gets out of Dodge and now he's got
an open G file and with it a Checkmate
thrown on G1 he pushes the C pong
where's the queen going back to F2 and
now you gotta go back to F2 C3 too many
problems not enough time low Yi ping
single-handedly keeping the Tigers
chances alive oh Queen G2 you could take
it so that doesn't quite win the game
with a spot of Queen G6 that's a great
move hitting E4 Bishop C6 now
Rook B8 also pretty good here comes Rook
B1 that's a ton of fun Rhyme Time and
he's attacking on all cylinders don't
take it because politics will be checked
to the king and the queen he just trades
pieces didn't he is doing everything
right
and finding all of these moves with no
time on the clock
he's now reversed his fortune he has
more time than baked off
defending and attacking Queen F3 check
that is also Gonna Hurt
you have seven I'm so impressed right
now with low you Ping's game what what a
hold right now it's not over though he
gives The Rook cause he takes the enemy
Rook
dude
takes takes Rook D2 to pass Pawn
okay
there should be a check there's me
kiddos oh we didn't see it he missed his
chance with Bishop a check oh the piece
will fall
oh my gosh that was it
had his chance
again to draw the match is probably not
over even if that happens but
wow how in the world did Logan save this
game
that's crazy man
dude great chess great chess is not over
yet if you're if you're the knights
oh now you can now you gotta you gotta
play a fourth round
oh my goodness and you know still going
to be difficult and a great win there
from Louis Peng look at him he can't
believe it yeah yeah excited shaking his
hands he's like I did it it saves our
chances big smile smile young man he
does he's texting Mom happy Mother's Day
I got the win for you
where'd it go
I mean wow okay it's not over yet go
ahead Robert that was just unbelievable
the defensive resourcefulness of Louis
ping in time travel look at him smiling
and that's just you just can't believe
it
he should be smiling and whoever he's
texting you know uh by the way everyone
text your mom before you do anything
else do it right now happy Mother's Day
Lo Yi ping keeps the Tigers PCL title
hopes alive they get a 2-2 deadlock
score in round three we see the top two
boards Nakamura and federal say have got
their job done with black no less both
of them just playing Super impressive
chess but it was the reversal on the
bottom three boards with low Yi ping and
shuyi getting the job done Robert
wow we still got chess here
that's the most exciting part more
chests to come the Gotham Knights are in
the driver's seats they have been on an
absolute Terror their quarterfinal
matchup was their closest against the St
Louis archbishops when Hikaru Nakamura
made four draws but now that he's back
to his winning ways the opponents in his
path are no match for him and the Knight
so it might not be vokidov's day he has
struggled but the rest of the nights
they are living up to the hype
you see three out of three for both
Nakamura and ferosev they're competing
against each other maybe for an MVP
prize should the knights hold on but the
Tigers want to shake their finger and
say hold on everybody three-game
deficits have been overcome before yes
it's going to take a massive score but
the game is played for a reason Robert
it is indeed because we have seen teams
Win For Nothing in a round and while
it's unlikely it is possible and
anything is possible after watching
Louie ping save that game
absolutely we have the uh the matchups
that get us the closest on paper and
also it's the storyline we didn't get to
see yesterday because Norma Nova really
is the underdog against the board four
for uh sorry for the Tigers in low Yi
ping so interesting stuff don't go
anywhere it's more of course from the
pro chess League Championship on this
Sunday the title has not been won yet we
have Hikaru Nakamura coming up against
Wei Yi it's the board one versus Board
one battle that everyone has been
waiting for we have more chess we're
gonna take this thing out but way Yi he
doesn't want the Tigers to be taken out
just yet don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
wow
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Hikaru Nakamura
the top player for the knights he's LED
them all year
wants to get the job done one more time
should he do it should he take down way
Robert
then the knights won't need anyone else
to get a win in this round four
yeah the Gotham Knights they don't even
need a win they just need two draws
somewhere and for Hikaru Nakamura we see
that he has the rating Edge but these
suit they don't have decisive results
that's interesting to know
yeah that is interesting three draws in
the book a 12-year age gap between them
both of course incredible careers but
Hikaru Nakamura the favorite on paper
the favorite I think in many people's
minds and uh
obviously he's he's done well for the
Tigers he's going to continue to need
help they've really had their backs
against the wall what what is going
through Wade's head right now going up
against akara Robert
yeah for Wei he's just looking at this
matchup and thinking you know what do I
have to do I tried to beat Federal save
I failed now I have to beat Hikaru after
that disappointment I just think that
maybe is the player who can afford the
draw because only one of them can yeah
and then you say to the others you go
for it
well especially because we use black and
as we bring up the scores remind
everybody of where we sit headed into
the last round eight and a half points
is a match Victory which means the
knights only need one point collectively
they can get it in any way somebody can
get a dub they can get some draws the
Tigers have got to figure it out way in
a very tough spot with black against
Sakura Nakamura of course he didn't get
the job done as white against Vladimir
Federal save or you just give Federal
save credit let's jump right into our
board assignments Robert and actually
just talk about the color Dynamics
because if we had to script the uh the
final ending here if you had to say this
is a three a three-game comeback for the
Tigers where does it where does it
happen
so I just said that Wei ye you know he
can afford the drug in Sakara but then
Jew and June's block against Federal
sale and this is a nightmare scenario
for the Shanghai Tigers maybe you say
the Jew and June okay you make the draw
and way he says all right I'll go down
swinging if I lose so be it but the
players they know what the white pieces
and the bottom two boards they have to
win and then between Wei and Jew and
June you just pick one
yeah that makes sense you gotta get wins
from those two those two players playing
the white pieces there's one of them
shuyi got a big win yesterday a
brilliant game played solid chess
unfortunately though his team is down
way Yi he knows that there's only one
way that they continue their title hopes
of life you gotta get three and a half
out of four here and uh or or just go
4-0 the other mindset is just win all
four games right NBD right get the job
done beat Hikaru Nakamura guy on camera
no problem yeah beat him with the black
pieces let's see he plays Sicilian so
Wei maybe in for a fight here but a
car's gonna play Bishop B5 check so
Hikaru doing what he needs to do for the
team he doesn't need to win this game he
would love to win he wants to win every
game he plays but today this is the
perfect system to play against Wei
yep
castles the uh you're highlighting the
E4 trick do we want to show it well it's
not really even a trick it's a Gambit
and you play rookie one you play D4 and
black lacks development look at these
pieces they're not in the game look at
these pawns they haven't moved which
means the Dark Star Bishop can't get out
so if you take on e4 maybe you do it
because you have to win but in against
Hikaru you're more likely to lose
yeah although at the same time if you're
if you're looking for a fight okay he
doesn't do it I'm just saying looking
for a fight you got to get a win grab a
pawn and pray Sometimes the best way to
do it all right no but he says E6 I'm
gonna play solid Here Comes rookie one
so we're gonna get a dynamic game as you
pointed out a perfect way for white to
play the Rossa limo is so solid these
positions are very very tough to crack
you're not going to get you know trapped
in some deep theoretical line of an open
Sicilian right an English attack night
or something so Hikaru avoiding those
types of pitfalls with this repertoire
yeah and we see where he's playing
principal chess he's just pushing his
pawns forward if you play D4 or even D3
I'm going to take on passant now and
you're just gonna take back maybe A4
comes to mind to go after the B5 Pawn
Denny this is just one of those openings
where white has no real risk at the
moment
yeah
it's a it's a Lopez kind of opening in
some ways but then after the structural
change you already have A4 coming and
and here it is it's on the board the
Queen side is is getting undermined
white very very comfortable in these
positions
but again at least there's at least
there's uh there's chess it's not a very
forcing draw if you're way ye you're
going to get a position that's a mess
and uh maybe maybe hope and pray for a
blunder
that's at this point what you need to
rely on we don't have a symmetrical Pawn
structure that's the good news and after
this
Pawn caption A4 if you're going to win
that pawn back you may have to give up
the bishop pair so Wei is doing all that
he can I'm looking at this now I'm
starting to take back what I was saying
he does have some chances here because
it's not just some healthily balanced
Position hikar will need to figure
things out is E4 hanging for example on
a turn near you
yeah and the A4 Pawn is uh is irritating
because you don't want to take and give
it the bishop pair but if you don't it's
holding back the B2 Pawn which will be a
Target you give black some moves Bishop
B7 and Castle somebody's going to the B
file whether it's a rook on B8 or the
queen on B6 so this is a
it's a position where you've got to
figure it out and that's kind of what I
was sensing too yes it was safe for
Hikaru but also
also at least at least there's some
chances you're telling me there's a
chance I'm telling you there is a chance
Mary Swanson that here uh is that's her
name tonight
Swan tonight the briefcase remember oh
Samsonite or it's once I forget it's
once and I say yeah it's been such a
long time Christmas one of the best
characters
he must he goes 92 principal chess here
I'm gonna stick the chest in my pop
culture game is failing at the moment uh
but E4 is well defended this A4 Pawn can
be captured soon black has to play
Bishop E7 and Castle but when is White
going to take on A4 that's what a car is
trying to figure out
yeah pausing thinking it over
head rested comfortably on wrist
position you see a car win a lot that
U.S Championship Bling on his right hand
there
there you go
all four games have been started why
don't we back this thing out and take a
look at them real quick make sure
everyone knows you can go to chess.com
events you already know that check out
the games we have a very very quick
Kings Indian taking place between Lo Yi
ping and alua normanova in the lower
right it's a zamish Kings Indian that
could be a spicy one Robert let's keep
our eye on it yeah that one I like I
like it as a winning idea go ahead I'm
sorry no no don't apologize I like that
I like the game next to it too in the
bottom left shoe Yi again shamsin evoked
of white has sacrificed the pawn but
black has developed none of his pieces
so that one promises to be a battle in
the top right we see Vladimir fellow
save with the white pieces he's just
going for the Anish giri line played in
tots of Steel of this year uh that is
known to just give you the isolated
Queen Pawn but some attacking chances
for white
perhaps ironic given that Federal save
and Anish giri are from the same town a
lot of people don't know that fun little
chess trivia for you
and uh
yeah Queen it's an isolated Queen Pawn
at the same time I'll say that Zhu and
June is gonna have some chances there at
least to keep the game going and if in
the end if way Yi can do something
magical against Nakamura she would only
need a draw assuming the other two get
the job done with white so
so it's not over everybody the game is
played for a reason as much as it's hard
sometimes to Hype up a close match when
a team leads by three we're still
playing chess and as long as we're still
playing chess there's a chance that
something crazy happens here so don't go
anywhere tune in with us for the rest of
this Sunday
please
while you're begging now but I actually
I actually do think that these games
have gotten off to the best start
possible for the Shanghai Tigers because
you look at the bottom two games white
has good chances to press for win they
will be a tactical skirmishes on the
bottom right Louis ping just has a solid
position of Roxy bind that tends to
favor uh the white side especially
against lower rated opposition and then
we see in the top games uh way he is no
worse against Hikaru and Zhu and Jun she
doesn't seem to be worse although there
are going to be tactics that she needs
to watch out for
could have said it better man I agree
it's you don't know what's going to
happen mistakes happen when humans play
chess that's usually how games get won
but you couldn't have asked for better
opportunities
I kind of want to check out shuyi versus
vaquid off if that's okay
it's uh
it's a bit wild we have a Castle's Queen
side
that pawn on G4 is kind of calling my
name I'm looking at it
so it's Timothy shallow man is what
you're saying yeah
and then Knight H5 look at that that's a
nice little anchor
put the pony on H5 dare you to take me
please and thank you because the Rook on
G1 is happily now on an open file so H2
can be captured things like that but
Denny you don't want to keep grabbing
pawns here I think that some of the
people in the audience say oh I was told
to check for checks captures and threats
I can capture that pawn over here but
you haven't developed your king is in
the center and Knight D5 is played
I like centralizing the Knight
but look at the crisscross applesauce
crisscross applesauce
yeah sorry I was trying to think of
something funny to say to challenge
challenge your reference for another
Rook G8 played quickly
agreed with chat shooting he does love
to attack
um
that nine on H5
working on his night moves kind of
awkward over there but also super
dangerous
spying G7 and F6 I want to just play F4
and just go I also want to play Bishop
G2 first I wanna I Want It All Bishop G2
F4 F5 I'm thinking shuyi is gonna get
some real pressure in this one
yeah I mean Bishop B7 Castle's
Queensland might be necessary black
cannot play G6 that allows the Knight to
hop into F6 especially if the bishop is
in range with his Knight on D5 so it's a
lot to work out for the players I like
to vokito as a head on the clock but
volcano has not had a good day of Chess
today he's actually only has half out of
three so for a Shu Yi especially with
the magical chest he displayed yesterday
he should feel like he has a shot
because G6 isn't a move you want to play
I'm now considering Bishop D3 instead of
Bishop G2 I know the natural diagonal is
the long one but Bishop D3 hits H7 right
and if G6 there's all kinds of weird
lines Robert like Bishop E4 you take H5
I take D5 and if you take here comes the
E file right I mean let's let's look at
that line like what's going on here I
mean now you can even take H7 as well
okay yeah
but just to show the line I was looking
at for everyone exactly
exactly Robert exactly thank you for
showing what I was looking at uh it's
just brutal I mean you're just showing
winning variations so Bishop D3 it's
hard to put your Bishop in that
direction but it makes perfect sense
because you're poking at a pawn that's
loose
and if you play H6 there's like this
show the idea of this nice Tempo where
you play Bishop H7 Rook h8 then back to
E4 you hit the Knight on D5 g7's hanging
this is this is nasty stuff I I'm I'm
not feeling good if I'm baked off
I'm feeling terrible and if he plays it
was Queen D3 so similar idea uh the
engine seems to not approve quite as
much but Bishop G2 now so he same exact
idea same idea of course
oh the engine loves it well I think
going in depth then yeah now it loves it
yeah I I think Queen D3 and Bishop oh
and he has to go for this by the way
Queen takes H7 is coming uh Bueller
Bueller there's Rook takes G4 so The
Rook is not completely trapped
I feel like we're moments away from this
game ending quickly and vaquita went
down in flames against Wei Yi quickly
obviously the young guy has had a great
playoffs not taking anything away from
but I think some of his some of his
openings got got exposed a little bit in
this final match Robert I think we can
say that right and he's a young player
plenty of time to improve of course but
he's getting himself in trouble in the
first stage of things here yeah although
Queen takes H7 maybe it was a bit rushed
because it could have been G5 available
to white but if Rook takes G4 is white
just gonna try to grab this that may be
a pawn to grab because the black king
remains in the center I still prefer
white especially Denny that H Pawn it's
a pawn for now could hit McQueen later
yeah no you're right it did it did slip
a little bit
it's
you can take you can take the H Pawn but
I'm looking at tactics
uh maybe they just don't exist if you
just play Queen takes H5 here I like you
said white has the H Pawn and
you're a wizard Harry
awesome I think all the way down but I
don't like what's happening the clock
because vokito is playing quickly not
accurately necessarily but he is well
ahead on time and that could help him in
the long run
or now
whoa
Bishop F6
interesting
um
queen of three Queen F3 hits the bishop
hits the pawn on F2 also threatens
checks if you're into it watch out for
things on F4 just in case things go
wrong
and if that Bishop moves black might
just Castle along because guess what now
the F7 Pawn is protected with the queen
on F3 that's actually a really important
point you can get the king out of the
center I didn't really understand Bishop
F6 it was a movie that came to mind he
wants to stop castling but he does walk
into Queens maybe he wants queen h8
there so perhaps what he's doing Danny
is sacrificing another Pawn on F2 and
saying your king is stuck in the center
so now that I'm actually looking at a
little more it does make sense to me
okay
okay if you say so but there's queen of
three Queen h8 can I even play Queen
takes F2 or take you you know
it's scary it's scary
agreed
but uh you definitely don't want this to
slip if you are the tiger speaking of
the Tigers let's back up and take a look
at where the other boards sit because
they need a lot of points not just this
game was ju Yi Wei Yi doing well against
Hikaru Nakamura as is you in June
against Vladimir Fidel save
oh my goodness so the games that we
thought that the Gotham Knights would
not struggle in Hikaru Nakamura is down
material if I can count correctly here
he's now an exchange against Wei
what happened over there
let's check it out
this is this is exactly how you would
draw up an epic comeback it would start
with Wei Yi doing the improbable or
rarely achieved beating Hikaru Nakamura
with black so you said how do we get
here the bishop took an A4 the Knight
took back and black protected the a pawn
and went for this bishop C6 idea and
look at this queen it can't keep in
contact with the Rook on A5 so Hikaru he
understood this he goes Queen before
allows D5 a nice Discovery the bishop is
loose but so is The Rook on A5 and
that's exactly what happened wow what an
idea from Wei Yi gets away with it and
now Bishop B7 because it's Bishop A6
this should be six is on the board the
king will get out it's not checkmate
and white does have decent drawing
chances here a very well centralized
Knight the dark swears can be helpful
for white black can't challenge them but
still you can't ask for a better
opportunity if you're if you're the
Tigers in way I mean this is
this could be the start of something
right it just could be the start of
something I can feel it coming in the
air tonight help me out here I've got
more songs that talk about big things
happening you know oh that's a bit of a
surprise so he doesn't take on F1 yet D
takes uh E4 if the Knight comes to B5
there's Queen A4 back and that means
that Knight can't move it's pinned to
the queen and black gets the material
okay well okay where are you getting the
job done
the line that we predicted in the
vaquita position is is ha has happened
it's it's kind of funny I think we
should back up and go well wait no
Knight takes
c68 Bishop
oh no that's it that's gonna be it
where you where you didn't see that move
the only way you didn't see it he found
it
oh wait I'm sorry he found Bishop C8
okay so I went full fobby there I went
full Fabi and I changed I changed my
colors there you go Wiggy is gonna get
the dub oh my gosh I mean Hikaru played
a great season of Chess he's led the
Gotham Knights the whole way and to
stumbled the finish line that is not
what the doctor ordered and Denny this
is a queen against a night bishop and
pawn but unfortunately for Hikaru these
pawns are coming fast and I think this
is dead lost
sorry I I was I was looking at the
player looking at Knight takes E6 the
idea of course was if F takes Queen
takes hikara would have won the bishop
on A6 if we want to show that blunder
but that's the game right there Knight
takes E6 a blunder from Hikaru is gonna
give away everything because Here Comes
F3 The Mating that is real
yeah this is just over and F3 Queen G2
is going to be made and that's that how
do you stop this E3 the E3 is also
pretty good
the idea is if takes
you play F3 next no is there oh is there
a way to win one of these pieces because
they're disconnected
but I don't see it
okay after the night moves wow
wow
it's over look it's completely over
it definitely doesn't Inspire confidence
for nice fans this is not a game you you
plan to lose on paper
but
if you're a tiger you are roaring right
now fun fact Tigers actually Roar and
lions aren't as loud as people think
despite what the movies would tell you
yeah but I'm looking at the other games
too so Hikaru is just dead right he's
gonna lose this car is dead Black's
gonna bring the king up and win the game
but look at the bottom right Loya ping
completely winning and then the other
games are messy
get the job done early Robert don't
underestimate the psychological Factor
too it gives your teammates confidence
right it's like hey we're not done
stay focused big big things can happen
here
oh my wow goodness yeah this match is
not over oh look at
vokidos King by the way in that game but
we'll tune in here just to show you that
Loya ping has passers on the c and b
files is up upon Black's pieces hardly
have breathing room this I think
position as they say it explains itself
yeah white is just completely dominating
white White's pawns are so strong you
look for the peace that they sacrifice
to get it but they didn't sacrifice a
piece to get it right there the white is
so dominant you're like where's the
compensation for black what did white
have to give up but instead no white is
just uh absolutely crushing here so okay
okay let's back up I gotta I gotta take
a moment to to appreciate what's
happening here okay Nakamura has lost on
board one it's in the books that early
Victory gives so much confidence to the
rest of the Tigers teammates if Lo Yi
ping can get a dub against Norma Nova
I know the eval bar loves vaquita over
there but we gotta go back what is going
on in that game
the engine says black is winning and I
look at Black's King really feeling the
Heat this looks so dangerous
it does look dangerous but there must be
a move here that helps vokito about
because uh if we dive into that position
and then when we're looking in the
bottom left with Shu Yi he is in a tough
spot it's the evaluation bar is all the
way towards the bottom uh but we look at
the material black is up a pawn so maybe
there is something available to Black in
this position that allows him to take
control of the game
well we're going to find out and vaquita
may have struggled today but he's been
great in the playoffs for the knights
they may end up relying on him
to do what the engine says he should be
able to do which is when this game is
black but it looks so scary
Robert if black plays D5
white can move the bishop right and then
immediately threaten Queen B6 check
Queen F3 of Rook D7 does he want some
kind of King C6 and his background
checkmates
so hard to figure this position out man
that's just that works for better it
gives me the Shivers you play a move
like Queen C6 with a championship on the
line
yeah Queen F3 seems to work because just
to show everybody Rook D7 King C6 and
unfortunately your Rook is under attack
Andrew Queen a4shek the king takes the
bishop there are no more checks against
this King the bishop protects the pawn
on B4 so any I I'm not sure what white
should do maybe it's like a rook slide
somewhere but then you can see that
White's attack isn't quite as strong as
you would hope
I'm looking for ways for shuyi to keep
it alive
super tricky
this is why you give your king Luft kids
back rink problems white has 99 of them
yeah I'm not seeing what to do
I think you have to play Rook C1 like
you just have to make a move that's a
bit sad but you keep the game going this
bishop is Tethered to this Pawn on B4 so
you think Bishop H6 might hurt but Queen
takes B4 and the King on B7 is In Harm's
Way so he plays Rook C1 Denny that's a
good start but I think Federal save I'm
looking at it I'm just gonna say outside
he's doing well the white Rook is
Tethered to the first rank the Tigers
hopes are Tethered to more than just
this game they are also tied up in June
June's performance against Vladimir
faroev and it looks like it is turning
around for the big fish he wasn't in a
great spot as white but if we want to
back this thing up to the bird's eye
view and take a look at Vladimir
fetusaev's game versus you in June
because
he's completely turned around I feel
like I was looking at a position where
if anything black had a small Edge in
the iqp and now White's pieces are all
on their ideal squares they're
dominating
yeah the other results don't matter
everybody else can lose as long as
somebody in the night scores a point and
for federal Sev it looks like he may be
the person to do that and June June down
to 30 seconds
foreign
we see red on the clock that means that
the Tigers chances might be dead in the
water if if she can't figure something
out here you see her you see her leaning
in she's nervous
a single win that goes in the Gotham
Knight's favor everyone is your pro
Chesley championship
literally on the edge of our seat here
if the Tigers can't hold and win these
games
yeah look at that
look at what I the eval bar kind of
shifted a little bit so I shifted in my
seat oh okay you're you're you're you're
in Rhythm right now black just can't
move look at these pieces they're all
stuck here and white is ready for a
sacrifice at any moment on E6 that
moment could be now there's Knight H5
with D5 at some point and Checkmate this
way I'm looking at everything and black
is cramped and struggling the only
problem is D4 is hanging right now so
white either does something or black
takes on D4 so I'm with you and
obviously the eval bar certainly agrees
White's moment might be on the board
but I'm just looking at Queen takes D4
coming so can we take E6 is that it do
you just take everything
I think you can but um I mean Danny this
game he does 96 but vokita also looks
like he's winning so I don't know which
game is going to decide the match it's
gonna be one of these two I think we'll
probably stick right here because with a
discovered check about to happen
this is a queen that has to part ways
with the board
shoe and June is the queen of the Chess
World in many ways the top and strongest
women's player but she Parts with her
Queen and with that the Tigers chances
are are coming down to it
yeah this is already just devastating
attack with material down and I saw
vokito as well he looks like he's
getting it done for that in fact vokito
Danny
guess what
the kid off wins
it's it the protest League Championship
has been decided ladies and gentlemen
not just Federal save but for kid off
gets a win for the Gotham Knights
rallying from a tough day to help the
knights get the job done and just like
that two results hit the books Federal
save wins vaquid off wins and the Gotham
Knights have won the 2023 protest League
Championship
congratulations to the federal say a
four out of four Danny he he did
everything that you could ask and more
for the uh Gotham Knights he has been
sensational
he sure did he showed up by the way if
you look at the last two days of chess
Vladimir fiddle save you know what he
put up
eight points
he went 8-0 Robert vakidov that young
guy also helps the helps the Gotham
Knights wrap up their 25 000 first place
pro-chestly Championship but I uh I
gotta say you just you just gotta love
what the knights did here of Akita and
federal save
there he is hikaranakamura Robert didn't
have his best chest in the last game but
it's a team sport it's a team event and
he's got to be pretty thrilled with his
overall season
yeah no he did really well throughout
the year and Danny there's something to
note he lost the first game of the year
to Josephine heinemann and he lost the
last game of the year but in between he
was sensational
that's fantastic actually in fact I
remember providing commentary for that
first loss of the year against Josephine
heinemann and uh Hikaru got his wake-up
call then had a great season he does
lose the last game to Wei Yi but it
doesn't matter the Gotham knights with a
nine and a half six and a half victory
over the Shanghai tigers are your 2023
Pro chess League champions what a world
to live in right now what a day what a
weekend for Vladimir fedrosev and Robert
your thoughts on the overall season for
the Gotham Knights here and uh and what
we have here on this Sunday
they played the bare minimum number of
matches because in the elimination Swiss
they won all three then in the playoffs
it was a close call against the St Louis
Archbishop some may have said that that
was the championship match because the
St Louis archbishops have been champions
in the past they were formidable with
Fabiano caruana at the top and Alice Lee
drawing kikaru Nakamura from board four
but after the Gotham Knights got through
there they steamrolled mgd1 the Shanghai
Knights the conclusion of this match it
looked closer than the match felt it was
but the Gotham Knights they are
deserving champions
I like what you said it was funny
because it felt existential at the time
when we had Knights versus Bishops of
course the Gotham Knights versus the St
Louis archbishops it was a very close
match and in the end it was the closest
match the knights had throughout the
entire postseason they end up dominating
mgd1 as you said they've now beaten the
Tigers Hikaru Nakamura with the fist
pump reaction that was as it came
through that was Federal saved look
backs up smile give a little shimmy and
Shake you deserve it man eight and oh on
this weekend vaquita off the uh the big
moment I think this was also the big
moment for him he just kind of takes a
sip of water calmly and alua normanova
had a huge win today over women's world
champions June June a big part of how
the knights wrapped up the protest
league and there Robert is the final
standings
yeah the final standings give 25
000 to the knights team the Tigers 20K
not bad for second place but I think at
this stage for you the money is great
but you still think about what could
have been and the Tigers I think we have
to give them their flowers as well they
had such a good season they were so
reliant on Wei Yi and their roster
construction Danny was super GM at the
top and they're pretty balanced Sports
two through four and when he delivered
he was a superstar for them he just beat
it Karo Nakamura On Demand with black so
for the Shanghai nice there are a lot of
good moments throughout the season a lot
to take home away and to think about
what it can be next year and for the
other squads the yogis they earned their
third place earlier today but it was all
about the knights and the Tigers
I want to give a shout out to the other
teams as well of course they all took
home some cash they all had great
Seasons to get in the playoffs the
Gnomes the Bishops the Blitz and the
Wizards of course they didn't they
didn't move on to the weekend but they
all had great Seasons Robert but as you
said the knights I I'll be honest I
touched on this in round two after they
dominated there and we didn't get to
talk about it but they were even better
than I think I thought they could be and
I'm not taking anything away I've
watched Chicago Nakamura do his thing
for years Robert I know how good lamb
lay is I know how good Federal save is
but I just didn't see this type of
dominance coming I'm gonna be honest it
was almost not even close
yeah no it didn't feel close right
that's why I had to go back to the
quarterfinals and talk about the match
against the archbishops that one was
close but the last two matches semis and
the finals it felt like a breeze I don't
know what the Gotham Knights did to
prepare I don't know how Levy and Alex
ostrowsky huge credit to the manager and
captain of that Squad because they
really care from the beginning we heard
from Levy in interviews we know that
Alex ostrovsky was the driving force
behind the team he went he looked
through rating lists he's like let's get
nermanova she's great and she makes our
team ratings fit so you have to do that
as a manager and it's not just about you
know the players they of course do the
heavy lifting but putting a roster out
each and every week that works for you
easier said than done but it worked to
Perfection for the knights totally I
mean you shouted out nuremova also for
kid off Wright was a find biostrovsky
and working super hard to to again
construct a roster that allows the top
dogs to do their thing but doesn't run
up against the rating caps and I think a
lot of people love that part of the
protest league and it definitely was
something you have to tip your hat to
you to the knights not just the players
who won but the managers who helped give
them an opportunity to do so all right
on that note Robert we now know who our
PCL Champion is it's time to reveal our
MVP
oh we're gonna go to a break I'm gonna
tease you that the MVP is is coming and
uh we're gonna have a break instead so
don't go anywhere we're gonna let you
know who the MVP was on the other side
of our break it's the final moments of
the 2023 Pro chess League season when we
return
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone and here are the
results for the 2023 Pro chess League
MVP voted by our panel
you uh you got it right there Robert you
were on the panel you feel pretty good
about your boat
oh I feel very good about my vote
because Vladimir fedexev earned the MVP
it was a great tour to force throughout
the entire season but especially come
playoff time he came ready he came
prepared and he did what he does best
win chess games
you obviously see Hikaru Nakamura taking
the second prize and then Grand Master
way Yi I agree with those results
completely I wasn't a part of the panel
and maybe people don't care if I agree
but I love I love how that broke down I
think it makes sense obviously Grand
Master Vladimir fetto say have dominated
not just today with a 4-0 score Robert
he went 4-0 yesterday as well he hasn't
lost all weekend it's uh it's currently
good to be the big fish and we're gonna
catch up with the big fish
right now uh well pretty soon
um and uh I can't wait to to see what he
has to say Robert yeah no he actually
only won three games yesterday not
because he lost any but because the team
was so dominant because of him and the
others they didn't need a fourth game so
he had a clean sweep throughout the
weekend he beat Wei ye with the black
pieces he deserved I just want to say
that for our team of panelists uh we
were talking behind the scenes a bit we
all voted independently but there was
some conversation about for example
pranesh he did so well he performed so
much above his uh rating to start the
season so credit to him Fabiano caruana
was in the mix leading the archbishops
back to the playoffs and there were
other names that were considered as well
but I think that Federal save deserved
it no question about it and then after
him he beat Hikaru in the last game so
that was a close call for the voters but
throughout the season hikar did have the
higher performance rating and you know
that game it could sway your voting a
bit but I think it helped Federal save
over hikar even more versus helping
Hikaru compared to Wei
love that transparency by the way I wish
more sport voting systems told what was
going on behind the scenes so uh thanks
for sharing that but right now we're
going to catch up with the guy who took
the MVP apologies I kept saying he went
8-0 I forgot you guys were so dominant
yesterday Vladimir that you only won
three games yesterday but
congratulations on the MVP prize
Vladimir and congratulations on the
season overall how you feeling right now
yeah it's absolutely amazing science
2020 it was my dream to get VIN in
purchase league with Gotham Knight and
uh I I can say that if in 2025 they
would organize a team I would play for
them uh 100 over a little bit of shares
team chess visas which won in 2021 also
and I'm very proud about our our team
because uh I guess in the playoff uh
they had a very hard match against Saint
Louis and quarter final and in my
opinion he was under performance here
myself and Hikaru and it was from
sitting who went for three out of four
in the first match and help us to be in
here and also a lot of credit for our
board for free just took down world
champion today and during zip playoff
she also got a lot of points for us so
amazing people by all of us
of course it's also
um very nice to play in the team with
Hikaru on the camera because uh use sort
of feeling QR favorite in any matches
because he is in the team and even he is
under performing he's still like
[Music]
the weapon which which destroy opponents
just by being in the gym it helps a lot
yeah for
for success I I guess
whatever that was beautifully said and
it seems like playing on a team is
something that you enjoy so what has the
experience been like throughout the
season was there preparation together
did you guys talk when you uh weren't
playing throughout the week so what was
it like being on this team
um yeah I like team stuff and I I I I I
I would say is that I was in contact
with our team captain I guess during the
whole
another whole tournament uh and uh I
like uh how it went and uh
um much more I like to dissolved for
sure
yeah the result is simply amazing to be
I can save it just dominating playoffs
uh despite the hard match against Saint
Louis in quarter final but yesterday and
today it's
nearly dominative performance in my
opinion
yep later speaking of being in contact
with the manager and and the
conversations that go on behind the
scenes you guys played the same lineup
the entire weekend right for for all the
matches what was the discussion there
was it was it logistical based on the
fact that you were all available was it
once you started playing well it you
know keep it going because everyone's
playing well was there ever a
consideration to to change up the lineup
at all
um I think yes it was a consideration to
change the lineup but uh after the
quarter final it was Korea's at Trump
said in and otherwise performance very
well on board three and four and with
such a lineup we have uh we just add
more orphans for our roster with
ramsidian performance like custom
matches I guess he he performed even
better than me I I can say he was
amazing in uh quarter final and the
semi-final also
but
today it was not a day for him but still
for world free it's very impressive
performance what he did in the playoffs
um and also I believe if we're playing
this fancy then it was impossible to
change me for uh Liquors maybe it was
not possible by Rachel I'm not sure but
um
yeah suddenly it works well that we
played all three matches with the same
line but we also put change for uh
both line up like we beat a tight guess
during regular season and in the game
three like it was line up myself Hikaru
and then kaflinsky and mikola Barney
this is also I guess was very strongly
and we also had Liam liquid glam
princess so and Natalia books uh
everybody so
uh I believe everybody could help but
uh we had this line of quarter final and
then uh we saw I I believe it we just
asked this lineup till the end
um I don't know why but
it pays off in the end so maybe it was
not a bad decision after all
seems like great decisions from the team
and from you as a player and you know
congrats again on the MVP award but
Vladimir we have a question that someone
in the chat asked and it was Ramesh
gavan saying how did you prepare to get
a perfect score of four out of four
today
but actually I did near the zero
preparation today I was just
uh sleepy all all day before before the
matches uh I I had a huge motivation for
the final but
um I I simply had the
uh
not enough energy to prepare today
um but I had sort of
uh feeling what what I will do uh
in in the game yeah and I was trying to
play good chess
uh make a good decision during the game
I didn't plan to go four out of four I
played game by game but eventually it
happened I I just won all four games but
I never mind that I will score for out
on Photo they are
Thompson Craigslist
I was just tying to playing could just
moved by more
it's a pleasant surprise I guess to go
404 right when when you didn't really
plan it but seriously you played great
I'm gonna also get you with another
feature chat question this one comes to
us from Lucas Wallick uh I I think I
know the answer about how much you
enjoyed playing for the team but to hear
you talk about your teammates it really
is clear how much you enjoy playing uh
for the protest league so just talk
about that and did you think this team
was as strong as it was at the start of
the season
yeah even before the start of this the
season I believe it's uh uh Champions
Contender team uh because we simply have
Hikaru in roster and also uh myself I
I'm think I'm uh I'm a decent player too
I can score like three or more points
like nearly every matches if I'm unfair
and also uh we had Trump siding who is
underrated in my opinion uh simply
underrated
and we had Alina caffeine's Natalia
books uh also
I didn't know her but we selected her
and it was uh I I think it was a Premium
Selection
also uh and yeah I I feel like we are
champions Contender team during the
whole event
but uh that I actually was not sure that
we can play like six oh during the
season it's just amazing
we won every matches in the season and
this is uh special in my opinion yeah
it was a perfect season uh from the team
it was a perfect day from you and well
you are the MVP but we have a question
from the featured chat asking who do you
think the MVP would be if it wasn't
going to be you
uh I believe Chicago dish of uh MVP uh
during this regular season he was an
amazing uh he was performing well in
every matches and
if not today I believe it could be from
Sydney also just for his playoff
performance
but uh I I actually think I have some
chance to win MVP awards after we've
also won Ariana oil and there was no
Hikaru at this day and I sort of lead
the team to Victory and this performance
like yesterday and today I think it's
it was a high high chance for me to win
MVP award
uh but I actually didn't know uh that
there is some money prices for uh MVP
that's good another good surprise right
you didn't think you'd go 404 and now
some an extra five thousand dollars to
go with it uh well again great answer I
I we got one more featured chat question
for you before Robin and I have a couple
of our own but I want to go to to gray
mexes who wants to know you just
dominated Rapids yes when's your next uh
classical chess tournament
uh I actually managed to want uh first
classical tournament in six years yeah
not a very strong tournament at ferment
there but uh I managed to win here it
was just months ago and I also tied for
first at Menorca open uh also this year
and the next step is playing French
league and after this I I will play at
the World Cup in Baku so uh who knows
maybe I can play Better In classical
just too it seems I improved in Blitz
and Rapid over the last couple of years
but for me it will be interesting to
know if I'm improved a lot in classical
chess
yeah and I mean you've had some great
results over the years in classical
chess of course during the pandemic more
things went online so a lot of my
question for you is what does it feel
like to play in front of so many fans
because historically chess you know you
don't see as many people you're playing
in a silent room but now you know that
there are thousands and thousands of
people watching does that motivate you
at all
um yeah it didn't the game you you can't
mind it you can't feel it yeah the
you're out you told it online you can't
feel it yeah but I remember my feelings
in uh Dortmund super tournament in 2017
there was some 500 people uh
game one of the tournament I played with
black and I managed to win and uh it's
it was absolutely Unforgettable
and uh
uh now I'm only proud that uh chess
Community is growing in Internet and uh
that it's so many people who interested
in
interested in chess uh who is like to
watch chess uh on chess.com uh
and I'm just
proud that our community is growing and
it it came in and now days it became
bigger and bigger day by day it's
amazing
so I'm only like this process but
you you can't feel that there is a
thousand people who watching you at this
moment during this game you simply have
no time to think about
purchasing during the game
well amazing to hear you say that the
Chess World is growing and even if
you're not thinking about it during your
games Vladimir they are thinking about
it you have thousands of fans and you
deserve it your performance was
incredible congratulations one more time
to you and of course the entire Gotham
Knights team and uh your fans will be
waiting for you guys next season what
are your what are your chances that uh
the whole team stays together as you
come back for a 2024 season and try to
repeat what you did this year
I hope we will have this opportunity and
it's actually my next version to the
team stuff so I hope we will stay all
together and
win the title once again
well we we wish you the best of luck
can't wait to see it thank you so much
for being with us Vladimir we're going
to let you go enjoy that Victory and uh
best of luck next year as the knights
return to defend their title
and on that note Vladimir fetto save
leaves us Robert one more time reflect
on the brackets you got here and there
2023 campaign
yeah with all the focus on the Gotham
Knights as the Champions it's easy to
forget about all the other teams that
took part but there were some great
matchups we had matchups go into extra
time the blitz throughout the season
they had some fun lineups of course the
Gnomes just anywhere you look there are
some great teams but I just want to give
another shout out to Vladimir ferrosev
you can tell how much he loves the game
of chess I mean he is somebody who said
when I played in Dortmund and I'd be
crumbled with black and everyone came up
and congratulates me that was such a
moving moment not just because the game
I played which is a lifetime achievement
but because everyone is showing the
support you can tell how much he loves
his teammates he is talking about giving
every single one of them credit how you
know he thought maybe he could win MVP
but you heard him he's like oh well we
wouldn't be here without shamsin Hikaru
is just a force even when he's not
playing his best chess even when he's
not winning all the games he's a weapon
that people are afraid of and he talked
about Aloo on board four saying she beat
Juan June today so I just have to say
one more time that it's just so great to
witness the level of Chess we see from
Vladimir fellow save but even better to
see him share his thoughts talk about
how much it means to him you can tell
that it was a crowning achievement
amongst many in his already illustrious
career so federusev he earned my MVP
vote here in the chats MVP vote he won a
lot of Hearts today and his team is
definitely going to thank him because
they are the protesting champions
couldn't agree more you can tell he
talks like a manager thinks he mentioned
a bunch of people who didn't even play
today too right he just he thinks about
it he cares about it uh an awesome
interview awesome guy and again an
awesome team it wasn't just Vladimir
Federal save congratulations one more
time to the 2023 protest League champion
Gotham Knights the entire crew that went
into that I'm going to thank our entire
crew and uh thank the whole team who
works hard to bring you the protest
league so many I can't name everybody I
want to thank the fans and of course the
moderators as well everyone who helps
bring these things to life on that note
I'm gonna say that that's that's gonna
be it for us folks we are we're gonna
leave you with a congratulations to the
Gotham Knights as well as a quick
summary of their best moments in this
victory over the Shanghai tigers on
their way to winning the 2023 protest
League Championship
Danny I'm looking at the bars of
connection and there are none for hikar
right now the E4 Pawn is loose away in
good position and oh what was that night
before
omg's or snaps Bishop takes f8 rookie
eight lines where you sacrifice your
queen what a what a fun thing I mean H2
huge win for federal sale wait that's a
great move I thought it was a blunder
but it was God it was a trick in 4k3 you
win the game on the spot he out
calculated her opponent who is the
Women's World Champion it'll say have
just took down way Yi with black it's
over it's in the books I'm just like
they're out of control hold the phone
low you ping is not out of this yet oh
it's just like that great win there from
Louis pink look at him he can't believe
it it's kind of funny I think we should
back up and go whoa wait no Knight takes
E6
one game
oh no that's it that's gonna be it not
just Federal save but for kid off gets a
win for the Gotham Knights and the
Gotham Knights have won the 2023 protest
League Championship
foreign
[Music]